in this course you will learn how to
create a full stack instagram clone
using flutter and firebase
ravon is a great instructor and will
teach you step by step how to create
this full stack app
let me show you the demo of the app
first so as you can see we have our
instagram feed over here we can either
light the image let me show you the like
process
and this is the animation we are going
to build with flutter
and we can dislike it and you can see on
all the three screens that if we like
the uh
image it shows up on all the three
screens real time this is powered by
stream builder and flutter and firebase
firestore
now
i can even comment on any post so let me
show you the comment i'll go in the
comments as well to show you that it's
real time so i'll comment
nice
pick
and i'll post it and you can see over
here that nice pick shows up
now you can even
go back over here in the search and you
can see our images showing up we can
even search for a user i'll show you the
user
the name of a user is naman ranavat so
i'll just type numan and it shows up
this is powered by firebase's
search query
now if i go where i can either follow
this user
or i can unfollow you see the like and
this
you can see the counter going up and
down
i'll keep it followed
now if i go back over there you can see
that this
is maintained and the user is showed as
uh followed
i can even go to the another user and if
i go to my own profile you can see that
i get the option of sign out
then i can even upload an image
so i'll take a photo i'll choose it from
gallery if i do it on my real android
device which i'll do in a while you can
see that we can take a photo from our
own gallery
i'll take this picture i'll write a
caption of
the scenery
is awesome
and i'll post it
you can see this indicator showing up
as long as it is getting posted to our
firebase database
and you can see that our image shows up
at the right time
in the real time
and if we go over here we can see this
now keep a track on this if i click over
here you can see a little of animation
happening over here we're going to build
that as well
and the next thing i want to show you is
the profile screen
and this is the number of posts the
following and everything so what i'm
going to do is sign out from here and
you can see that we get signed out
immediately and only from one device and
not all the devices
and
we can again
you make use of the authentication now
i'm going to login
and
put in the password
and you can see there is no user with
this email we have proper validations
with firebase as well
so this is what we are going to build in
this app the prerequisites for this
tutorial is to have a basic knowledge of
flutter and dart no knowledge of
firebase is required not even
knowing what firebase is actually we're
going to go step by step and learn
everything about firebase
and we'll also uh you make use of a
provider if you have a bit of knowledge
with provider it will be a good thing if
you don't that's no problem you're going
to have a look at that and i'll explain
it to you as well
and we're going to have a cross platform
app so you can see over here this is a
completely responsive build now let me
increase the width of this app
this website over here
and you can see it has a different
layout altogether because instagram on
web looks completely different it has
the different background color it has a
same app color
and it is easily accessible as well
it's similar to our app
right so we're going to build completely
responsive ui as well
let's get started with the code alright
so the first thing we need to do is open
our terminal and over here migrate to
our desktop
and after that
we run the flutter create and after that
we need to
mention the name of the
folder we need to give so we can name it
instagram
flutter and make sure to use underscore
over here and not uh you know
a hyphen or something because it will
give you an error
and after that is done just click enter
after this process is completed you can
just migrate to your instagram flutter
folder
and you can open it in vs code by doing
code and after that putting a full stop
and clicking enter
this will open in vs code
and uh
what i want to do now is run this
boilerplate code on our ios simulator so
that we know it's working pretty well
like the boilerplate plate code is
working so i'm just going to run open
dash a
and pass until simulator so this will
open uh like create a simulator for us
and this is working now you can run the
command flutter run to see if it's
working but what i like to do is in this
main.dart file go over your
run and run without debugging
because this gives us the option to hot
reload and whenever we save a file it
will start hot reloading which is a
pretty cool feature in my opinion now in
the meantime what i'm going to do is
i'm going to remove all the boilerplate
code but i'm not going to save the file
so that we see the changes that are
happening
and i'm going to remove
this
theme data from here as well
and i'm going to name the title as what
the title of our app is going to be i'm
going to name it instagram
clone
and over here i'm going to pass in debug
show checked mode banner to false
the banner that shows up in the top
right corner
will not show up if we do this
and
let our app finished by that time
see you when this app loads up all right
now our app is loaded and if you see if
we click over here our counter
app is working pretty well so now i'm
going to remove this text over here i'm
going to replace this class that we have
removed and going to replace it with the
text let's say
let's
build
instagram
so this is going to look very ugly but
let's see
and it's giving us the right output
so uh the next thing we want to do is
add theme to our app what we can do is
pass the theme over here
and what i want our app to how i want
our app to look is you know have a dark
theme but i just
want to copy everything that flutter
provides us so
there is one theme data
and if we put in dot dark it will give
us all the features you know the flutter
has built in in this dark so it will use
all the colors of dark
and we can just save it and if we
wrap this home with the scaffold so that
we see a
good output and not a container type
output
we should see something cool happening
and we can see that our app has turned a
fully dark mode but i don't want my app
to you know look like this
i want its colors to look a bit
different like the background color over
here so what you can do is
go to this url over here github.com on
our instagram flutter clone
and i'll mention this link in the
description below you can just copy all
of this these are just colors for our
app i don't want to waste time writing
all of these colors
and we're going to create a lip folder a
utils folder over here
so that it contains all our you know
utilities and i'm going to name it
colors dot dot file
and i'm going to paste all of these
colors
now
you can see we have mobile background
web background mobile search blue color
primary color secondary color
so
what i want to do is
keep all the methods like whatever dark
has whatever color dark has
i want to keep them and i want to so i
can do copy with and i just want to
change the background color over here so
what i can do is scaffold background
color and i'll turn background color to
mobile background color
now if we go over here we can see that
we're getting a good output
a changed background color
that's what we wanted now the next thing
we want to do is create a responsive
layout whenever our screen
size of the browser extends a certain
width it should display you know a web
screen layout so to say and uh if not
then it should display a mobile screen
layout
so what i'm going to do is create
another folder over here called
responsive
and in that i'm going to create
layout
screen
dot dart
and
over here i'm going to import material
package
for now it's going to be a stateless
widget later on it will become a
stateful widget because of the init
state we are going to use in
future
so uh over here i want to return
a widget named as layout builder
this helps in creating responsive layout
basically it will give us a builder
function which will return to us a
context
and constraints this constraints is a
very useful thing for us it will give us
various methods like
if i do give constraints dot it will
give us max with max height
minimum height minimum width
so it will give us the constraints of
our app basically and for now uh since
we are going to use it over here which
is basically a parent
uh we'll have the maximum width of our
app so we can do mac constraints dot
maximum width and if it's greater than a
certain height
so what i'm going to do is create a
variable i create a file over here
dimensions dot dot
and over here first of all let me import
material package because of the
several stuff that's going to come in
later and over here i'm going to give a
web screen size of 600 beyond this size
our
app will start looking like a web screen
layout so if the constraints.max width
starts to extend this a 600 uh variable
that we have given over here
it it should display a web screen layout
right so we'll just pass in web screen
and if not we need to pass in a mobile
screen layout now this value
over here can be changed easily so
that's why i've created it in an
external file
you can just pass it over here but uh we
are going to use this web screen size a
lot in the future to make further
responsive layouts so just keep it over
here or else you'll have to
keep taking 600 and move it everywhere
which is not really a good coding
practice
so i want to return a web screen so
what i'm going to do is
call a widget i'm going to accept a
widget from our constructor over here
and i'm going to call it web screen
layout
and another widget which is going to be
the same thing
and i'm going to name it mobile screen
layout
and i'm going to require this via the
constructor
web screen layout and required
sorry
required
this dot mobile screen yeah so i've
accepted this from our constructor now i
just want to return this so i can do
return web screen layout
else what we can do is return a mobile
screen layout
cool
now we can just take this widget from
here
and replace our home with this
and we need to import responsive layout
screen dot dart
and we'll have to pass in a mobile
screen layout and a web screen layout so
that is what we are going to make over
here
a mobile screen layout
and a web screen layout
cool
now
we for now it we are going to uh you
know create a stateless widget in both
of them
so i can just pass in mobile screen
layout
and i'm going to copy this from here and
paste it over here
call this
web screen layout
and we can paste it over here as well
i'm going to return a scaffold
which will have a body of text
this is
web and let me just center it as well so
that we can see
and i'm going to format this document
over here i'm going to do the same thing
i should have copied it earlier i forgot
to do so
and i'm going to pass in this is mobile
i'm going to take this widget and pass
it over here
mobile screen layout
and over here
a web screen layout
now all of this is going to be a
constant widget since we are not going
to have dynamic values passed into the
constructor
so
yeah we can just refresh our app and see
we are getting this is mobile over here
which is the correct output now to run
our app on
chrome we can just do flutter run dash d
chrome
flatter run to run and dash d for debug
and then we want to debug chrome version
so we can just do this
right now let's wait for our chrome to
load up as you can see over here we are
getting this is mobile over here which
is the correct output actually now if i
increase the width we should start
seeing this as web
and this is exactly what we are getting
so that means our responsive layout
widget is working pretty well cool now
that we have a responsive layout the
next thing we want to do is make a
connection to our firebase
but before doing that we need to install
some packages and these are the packages
we'll need firebase core
cloud firestore firebase auth and
firebase storage let me install all of
them and i'll tell you the users of all
of these packages in our app so uh what
i like to use and uh not to put all of
this manually in pubspec.yaml file i
instead what uh what i prefer instead is
you know using an extension whose name
is
pubspec assist
so you can see over here if we just do
command shift p
you can see pub spec assist popping up
and you can click over there and put in
the name of the package you want to add
i want to add firebase code i'll click
enter
and this will automatically add a file
in my pubspec.yaml file with the latest
version
of the same dependency you can see over
here
now uh
like this we are going to add multiple
packages like cloud firestore make sure
to add cloud firestore and not firebase
firestore which is a deprecated
dependency we need to add firebase auth
next then we need to add
firebase
storage
and these are the four packages that we
need to install
and uh while this is happening the next
thing we want to do is go to
console.firebase.google.com
i'll mention the link in the description
this is where uh you need to create a
project i hope you have your gmail
account already
then we'll click on add project and our
project name will be instagram
tutorial for me you can just write
instagram clone since i already have a
project named instagram clone now we're
going to disable the
analytics for this project since we
don't need them
and i'm going to create the project this
will create a project for us now since
we added some dependencies in our
pubspec.yaml file we need to stop all of
this uh our app running basically and
we'll not run it again because we need
to make some configurations before you
know having them
we'll have to make some more
configurations in the ios folder and
everything for our ios
so we won't run our app now
the next thing i want to do is go to the
authentication tab
i want to click on the get started
button
and over here i want to go to this email
or password provider
and
i'm going to enable the email and
password
now if you know how to add any other you
know
sign in method like google sign-in or
phone authentication you can just click
over here again add new provider and do
google facebook phone anonymous sign up
as well github there's a lot to do with
this
the next thing we want to do is go to
the firestore database
over here we need to create a database
and i'll start it in test mode and click
next
i'm going to select a location that is
near to me you can select us europe
anything i'm going to select south east
asia over here and click enable our
firestore has loaded up
now we'll go to the rules over here and
we're going to make some changes over
here i'm going to remove all of this
rules that we have created
and i'm going to publish these rules so
that anyone uh can read and write in
this database
we're not going to look at the rules in
this tutorial if
you want i'll mention the resource from
where you can look it up and make a
rules on your own
then we're going to go in the storage
part we're not going to use real-time
database in this tutorial we're going to
use firestore database
and over here in the rules you can see
that of storage has been set up now i'll
go in the project overview again and i'm
going to click on ios app first that's
what i'm going to set up
now i need the app bundle id for this
project so
you can go over here you can right click
on the ios folder and click on open in
xcode
this will open your ios
part of the you know ios build of your
app and open it in xcode
now you can just click over here in the
runner and you'll find bundle identifier
over here i'm just going to copy this
go over here and paste it
i'm going to call this ios
app
and we're going to register this app now
we need to download this google service
in 4. list file and
move it to our application
so
let this install for me
i'll go in the downloads
over here and you can see
what i'm going to do is drag this
to our runner runner folder and make
sure to tick this add to targets runner
and finish
and this should be in the runner and run
a folder of your
ios folder now you can just
go back
next we don't need to follow this step
we can click on next again this step is
not needed we can click on next and we
can continue to the console
now after having that we need to close
this i'll close this as well
now i'm going to migrate to my ios
folder over here and i'm going to run
pod install
and i'm going to wait for this to happen
and as you can see that our request of
pod install has
not worked over here this is because we
need to go to the pod file over here we
need to on uncomment this line
and we have to change this 9.0 to 10.0
and save it
and then we need to run pod install and
this should work for you and in case if
it doesn't work for you i'll mention a
stack overflow link in the description
below generally this command for if
you're on a macbook air m1 should work
arc dash x86 underscore 64 pod installed
repo update and this should work for you
cool now that we have that we need to
run this over here and see if it's
working we're going to run that dart and
flutter
as you can see our app is loaded up and
ready now we need to add in a firebase
and initialize firebase in our app so
what i'm going to do is add async tag
over here and
i need to avail
firebase
and you can see that we can import this
by firebase core
and we can put in firebase dot
initialize app
and with this our app widget will get
initialized i'm going to
close this and run it up again
after this is done we need to make
configurations for our android app now
in the meantime i'll tell you about you
know why we chose to use firebase in
this tutorial this is because firebase
has a lot of products used as you can
see authentication firestore real-time
database storage hosting functions
machine learning kit
and we can even make predictions of a
user alpha beta testing cloud messaging
in-app messaging there's a lot to do
with a firebase and this is why we've
chosen this and also one of the reasons
is that firebase and flutter both work
really well and in sync with each other
also the reason is because you know
flutter has been provided by google
along with firebase which is by google
itself
so uh they work pretty well
now you can see that we are getting uh
an handle exception null check operator
used on a null value this is because uh
our firebase have has been initialized
even before we made sure that the
flutter widgets have come in so what we
need to do is call in widgets flutter
binding
dot ensure initialized this will in make
sure that the flutter widgets have been
initialized now we can
stop this process and start it again now
let me explain you the uh
now let me explain you
now let me explain you the
now let me explain you why we have
chosen to use these uh dependencies
firebase core firebase or firebase
storage cloud firestore what their users
are basically cloud firestore allows us
to save our data data in our database in
the
firestore database over here where we
are going to store user information
posts you know all sorts of stuff
then we have a firebase auth which is
basically for authentication as we can
see sign in method and allows for
various sign-in methods
then we have firebase core this is for
the connection with our flutter app
and uh lastly we have firebase storage
this is to store images in our app
as you can see
now we can see that our app is loaded
and we're not getting any error the next
thing we want to do is you know i'll
stop the process for ios now we're going
to run the process for android now we
can go back to the project overview over
here add app
we're going to add an android app now to
get the android package name what you
can do is
close this ios first
go to the android folder in the app
folder and you can go to the
build.gradle file
and you can see
in the default config application id and
you can copy this
and paste it over here i'm going to name
this android app
now
we don't need to pass in a debug signing
certificate because this is usually
needed when we need to do phone
authentication or google sign-in
authentication
so i'm not going to pass in that and
then we're going to register our
app then we need to download the google
services.json file pretty similar to the
google services dot in google services
info.list file that we had in our you
know
uh ios we can take this go to our app
over here now make sure to put this in
the app folder and not the src folder
take this
and
drag it to your app folder over here
cool now we have the google services
info this basically contains all the
information in our app like the url of
our repository all the config stuff
basically
then we can click on next now as you can
see we need to add this in our project
build.gradle file so we can go over here
and instead of you know manually just
finding a file what you can do is click
command p and type the name of the file
you can see android app build.gradle but
we need the project file for now we can
just click over here
and we need to add this in the
dependencies so i'm just going to add
this over here
cool now we have this setup for the
build.gradle file
now we need to go to the app level
so we can go
in our app build gradle file
and you can find this in the app folder
if you want to do it
folder wise
now
we can
copy this line from here apply
plug-in com google this line over here
and we need to paste it down over here
cool now i'm going to
take all of this from here cancel it and
i'm going to the main.dart file
and you're going to click on next and
continue to the console
i'll take this opportunity now to tell
you that uh
i'll go to the android manifest.xml file
over here now make sure that this
package over here is not
com.example.instagram flutter if you
need to upload it to your play store
because com.example files are not
allowed
you need to replace example with
anything since i'm not uploading to play
store i've given it the name of example
but you need to change it
i'll mention a link in the description
uh from where you can follow and change
the name of this package in your app
successfully cool this is a setup now
let me run our app now you can see that
we've
gotten an error over here the reason is
over here that flutter has given the
minimum sdk version as flutter dot
minimum sdk version we need to replace
this with
minimum sdk version 19
and
this still won't run since we need to
make another configuration which is we
need to enable multi-decks
and we can do this by multitext enabled
true
and we can save this and we need to
re-run our app again welcome back our
app has loaded up and it's not giving us
any error and if we see over here it
shows this is mobile which is a pretty
good thing our android setup is done as
well the next setup we need to do now is
for the web
what i'm going to do is run like run
this on our web as well
and we can just run it using flutter run
dash d
chrome we have looked at it before our
web has loaded up but the we are getting
some errors over here now if we inspect
the errors over here it's saying
firebase options cannot be null when
creating the default app
basically we have initialized this with
this we have initialized for our android
and ios apps but not for our web app our
web apps usually require
an options tag over here
and which
which is of the type firebase options we
have not done that
so if we put in options over here and
put in firebase options
you'll think that this would work but
that's not the case because then our
mobile apps would fail running so
instead what we need to do is we need to
run this when it's in the mobile stage
and other thing when it's on the web
stage so what we can do is put an if
condition over here if and to check
which platform we are on we can just do
if k is web
and
if it's web
we need to do
other part of the you know initializing
of our app and if it's mobile we need to
do this
so i'm going to paste this in both the
places and we need to pass an options
parameter over here now our options is
going to be of the type firebase options
and
you need to pass in some stuff over here
but before doing that we need to add an
app over here which is our web app
we are going to name it web app
we are not going to set up firebase
hosting for this project we are going to
host it on a different server a
different hosting platform not firebase
but you can surely check it out and
click on learn more if you want if you
are interested now we can register our
app over here now we need to add this
firebase sdk we don't need all of this
stuff over here so i can just you know
copy all of this stuff
i'll copy this api key don't
try to you know copy all of this because
i'm going to delete this project as soon
as this app gets over
then we need to pass in the app id this
is our app id
then we need to pass in messenger
messaging sender id
and we need to pass in a project id
and i want to format this document after
doing so
i'll again put a comma so that i can
format this okay now we have this but we
need to pass in an extra parameter
firebase options has a lot of parameters
but we need to pass in only one more
parameter which is storage bucket since
we're going to use firebase storage
uh else it will give you error in the
future
then we need to pass in this
storage bucket url over here
and we can paste it over here
and we need to pass in const for
firebase options and we can pass in now
we will try to run our app i'm going to
pass it put in control c and if you're
in windows command c and exit this
process i'm going to clear of this so
that we can see it well and again run
the command you can just click the up
arrow command
two times and you can see our command
showing up we can just press enter after
this
now it shows that our web version has
loaded we go over here and we can see
that our web version is loaded
right
now this is the setup for firebase now
the next thing we need to do is create
the login screen ui and the sign up
scene ui let's do that
so to do that first let me create a
screens folder where our login screens
and all the other screens are going to
rest so i'm going to create login screen
dot dot this is the naming convention i
typically follow uh the name of the
first thing then an underscore then
screen you can follow anything you want
like
then we'll just import material package
then we'll make it a stateful widget
right now only because you know
we know uh this is going to have text
editing controller we're going to call
and set state etc etc so yeah we'll just
create a login screen state right now
now we'll return a scaffold over here
and we'll return a body of let's say
text
and we'll return for now
from
login
screen
right
now
i'll save it
and we'll go in the main.dart file we'll
comment this out temporarily
and i'm going to uh
return a login screen so that you know
we can actually see what's going on
now we should be able to see from login
screen
now i'll remove this text from here for
now
and
i want to show you how our app is going
to be structured and how it should look
so first of all our app should not you
know start from uh here
it should start from here
and then we need to you know uh center
all our elements because we need them in
the centered position over here we are
going to have a logo
right
then we going to have our text input
field over here
which will be email
then we'll have a password field over
here and then a button
right this is our layout this is what
our layout is going to look like
so
what how can we make this type of layout
first of all we don't need to start from
here so we'll call a safe area over here
so that we can avoid this
then we are going to have a column
right now in the column we are going to
have uh an image an svg image actually
then we are going to have two you know
text field input and after that we are
going to have a text button seems very
uh easy right
let's do that so we are back in our
login screen again now i'm going to
take this body and i'm going to return a
safe area as we discussed previously
and our safe area is going to have a
child and a child is going to have a
container
buy a container because we need to add
some padding
and we need to
set the width of our app
so
what is the padding going to be
the padding is going to be from this
side and this side both
right so that our text field inputs can
be in this range and not
take the full width of the app
so we're going to have a padding of edge
inserts dot
symmetric actually because we want it
from horizontal side
so we can do symmetric and we're going
to pass in a horizontal value of 32 you
can try and test values on your own and
see which suits your preference
then after that we're going to have a
width and the width is going to be the
full width of this device so we are
going to take in double
dot
infinity
after that we need a child and the child
is going to have column as we discussed
now this column has the last children
and the children
will be a
text field
input for
email
text field input for password
and above that we are going to first
have an
svg image
and over here lastly we are going to
have a button for login
and the last thing
i forgot to add was
you know transitioning to sign up like
you know
having something like
do you remember your password or
something like that
right now we also said that we want all
of our contents to be centered so what
we can do over here is we can do
cross access alignment not mean access
because we don't want it to be centered
like this we want it to be centered like
this
in a row format
right so we can do cross axis alignment
cross axis alignment
dot
center
after that we need to return an svg
image
but uh we can't directly return an svg
image and before that we need to get the
svg image right i'm going to create an
assets folder over here and we're not
going to have any images as such so i'm
just going to keep it assets for now if
you had like fonts sorry
we don't have
we don't have fonts for now so i'm just
going to create an assets folder but if
you had fonts we're going to create an
images folder and a fonts folder and
then you know segregate both of them
which is a good way now you can go on
this link it will be mentioned in the
description and you can download this
you know
this image from your
you can just right click and you can
download the image
going there you can go in your finder
downloads
you will get this ic underscore
instagram.svg
you can drag it to your assets folder
you have that
now we need to display an svg image for
to display an svg image we are going to
use a package flutter package named as
flutter
underscore svg
i'll mention the readme of this package
in the description below make sure to
check it out and after that is done we
can do svg picture
dot asset
and make sure to import
flutter svg over here and not svg.dart
over here
right now our asset is going to be
assets
slash
ic underscore instagram
dot svg
and
our color is going to be a white color
which we have defined in colors.dart as
primary color
and a height of 64.
cool
now we'll get an error if we just save
this much because we haven't told
flutter that this assets folder stays
here so we can go in your spec dot yaml
file scroll down and you can find assets
tag over here you can uncomment all of
this
and paste this over here and save it
you should get that
now you can save this
stop all your app processes
and rebuild it
we should get a good looking
instagram svg file over here right
in the meantime
we should you know
have a text field input
but before that i need to do some
spacing so that it doesn't directly
stick with our app you know
so what i'm going to do is
create a sized box
with a height of 64.
there's no need to use media query over
here
then
actually you can but i don't feel any
use of using it
then the next thing you want to do is
create a text for your field input for
password
and an email right i'll move this
comment down
so since we are going to be using text
field input here here and in our sign up
screens
what we can do is
create
a widgets folder over here
and we are going to create a text
underscore field underscore input
dot dart
with this we can reuse the for this
widget everywhere in our app
so we will import material package
we are going to use a stateless widget
over here
and we're going to call it text
field
input
and we're going to return a text field
right now our text field
is going to have some properties and it
would need a controller which we look
after in a while
but we need a decoration as well and our
decoration is going to be of the type
input decoration
and we're going to add a hint text which
we these values we are going to accept
from the constructor so that user can
put in while using text field input
class over here
right for now it's going to be empty
then we need to pass in a border and a
border is going to be of the type
outline
input border
and it will have a border side so we're
going to do divider dot create border
side
and we'll pass in the context we need to
pass in focus border side over here
and it's going to be the same as this
border over here so what i'm going to do
is take this from here
i'm going to
create a final input border
and going to paste it over here so that
you know we can easily
put all of them over here and we don't
need to change each and every time we
need to change the settings basically
then we also need an enabled border and
it will be of input border
right now we are going to set filled to
true
and
a content padding
of
edge insets dot all and 8
now the keyboard is going to have some
type and an obscure text which is you
know a dot dot dot format
when basically whatever text that shows
up when you use passwords in your app
right now we'll accept all of these uh
missing values from the constructor so
what we have is
final
text editing controller
a final boolean value which is s pass
this is to check if uh the value that
you're going to pass is password or not
so that we can hide this obscure text on
then we are going to have a hint text
and then we are going to have a text
input type
you know text input type because well do
we need to show the
user
text input type because we need to show
uh the keyboard type as you know is it
going to be
username
or you know is it showing going to show
email addresses
or something like that
right now we're going to pass in the
controllers
but before that let me accept all of
these values real quick
right i have imported all of these over
here
right i've imported
all of
right i have expected
right i have accepted all of these
values in the constructor now i'm going
to pass in the controller text editing
controller
a hint text
a keyboard type of text input type
and obscure text of is password
and
usually our
obscure text is going to be uh for false
and only one time it's going to be true
when our text editing controller is
going to be a password so what i'm going
to do is
over here let me first format this
document
and over here i'm going to set a preset
value of false
so that if we don't uh and we're going
to remove this
now
even if the user doesn't enter his
password we will be able to you know
take this default value of false
now we can go over here and first of all
let's see our app
and you can see instagram is showing up
real good
now you can see it's still at the top so
to do that uh to fix that what we can do
is
we're going to create a
i'm going to take the flexible widget
i'm going to have the child as a
container which is basically nothing and
you know i just want
to
create some spacing
from the top so i can just mark flex as
one and format this document and see it
has gone down
i can do flex too right now
this will change you know as and when
our stuff keeps on coming like the text
field input password you know all of
that stuff
so let's add that and in the final if
you are not satisfied we can always
change the value
okay
now we can just have text field
input make sure to type in input or else
it will accept text field which flutter
provides us
then
we are going to add a hint text of enter
your email
we are going to add a text input type of
text input type dot email address
and a text editing controller
now we can create one so we can go on
the top final
text editing
controller
and we'll name it email
is equal to text
editing
[Music]
controller
and i'm going to copy this and paste it
and name it as password controller
and we have to create an image uh sorry
not an instance
so we have to create a dispose over here
and we need to clear off these
controllers as soon as the widgets gets
disposed right so we can do email
controller dot dispose
and
password controller dot dispos don't
forget to do that it's very important
cool now we can just pass an email
controller and we can restart our app
and see our email is showing up
right
now after this we need to create
something similar for password
enter your password over here i forgot
to put a comma that's why the error we
can format the document
and over here our text input type is
going to be of the text
and
we need to add in one more
property which is password but i want to
show you how
this looks without its password
right now if i type something you can
see something popping up and we have the
same values because our email uh our
text editing controllers are both email
we'll change that
and you can see the value over here is
shown up but we want it in a dot format
right this is what obscure text does
so what we can do is
take is pass and
change it to true over here we can pass
in password controller
now we have that and if we do that we
can see our format coming in
now these both are stuck together i
don't want that as well
so what i'm going to do is create a
sized box
of height let's say 24. you can always
play around with values as i mentioned
before
and you can see we're getting good space
i will take this value
and paste it over here as well
cool
now we need to create a
button basically
but we are not going to create a button
we are going to create a container you
can always use a material button or
elevated button text button anything but
i prefer this way for now because it
will be easier for me to create like
this
now our child is going to be of constant
text
and it will have the time
login
and after that we need to pass in
something to our
container
so
the width of our container is going to
be the maximum possible value then it's
going to be aligned in the center so
we'll do alignment dot center
then
we need to add some padding and where do
we need to add the padding you know our
button should be uh should have a little
spacing from the text
right
so we can do padding of const
edge
inserts i'm going to do symmetric
and we can do vertical
after that we're going to add some
decoration and we want our button to not
look like this we want it to look
slightly rounded from the edges
so we're going to add in a const shape
decoration
and the shape is going to be a rounded
rectangle
border
and
a border is going to be of the type
border radius border radius
dot all
radius dot circular
4.
and i'm going to format this document
over here
now let's see how our app looks
doesn't look that good
but
now let me just add a color and you'll
see the difference
not over here
we need to pass in a color over here
and the color is going to be a blue
color which is in our colors dot dot
file
now if we save this we can see the blue
color showing up critical
right
now i'll again have a sized box over
here
of
half the size of normal so we can do 5
12.
after that we'll again have our flexible
over here because i need to leave some
space
so i can take this
and paste it down
cool
after that we need a row
buy a row because we need to display
side by side right let me grab my marker
so suppose this is the bottom of our
widget so we need to display a text do
you have an account
and then we need to
pass in another text which is
login
so we need both of them in the same
alignment but we want them to have
different textiles that's why we're
creating a row and two different texts
so
let's go back
and
over here we're going to have
a row
and ro is going to have a children and
again it's going to be in the center so
we're going to have main access
alignment dot center
and our children uh is going to be
a container
of child
text
don't
you
don't have an account after that we're
going to add some padding and what is
our padding going to be
well
it's going to be
from vertical
format the document
right
now our text is going to be a constant
as well
now we can again grab this text from
here
and we can paste it
and we're going to say
sign
up now our text styles are going to be
different as i said mentioned as i
mentioned before
so we are going to have a text style
and we're going to have a font weight
and the font weight is going to be bold
now let's try to run our app
and see
it
fills up pretty well
these pieces are because of the
container flexible we are going we are
using
this thing over here looks pretty cool
now the problem is that uh first of all
this is not clickable over here
this is not clickable and this is not
clickable so what we can do is
wrap with
a widget called inkwell gesture detector
what we are going to use for this
container over here
gesture detector and this will have on
tap
again cool now we have a login sign a
login uil now let's create a signup ui
quickly
so we can do sign up screen
dot dot
right
now we can import material package from
here
and i'm basically going to copy this
whole thing from here
and paste it over here
we're going to import svg
flutter package
primary color
a text field input
and this is pretty much it
now
we even need to create
some more controllers and some more text
fields so we can just paste them over
here and what is their name going to be
well it's
bio controller
which will help us to add a bio
and a username controller
we can take this controller and dispose
them
and take the username controller and
dispose them
cool
now
we can go to the bottom over here
and
we are going to add some more
text fields
so
we can take this from your
entire sorry i'll take this enter your
email because it doesn't have you know
the text input you know is pass over
here sorry
then
we're going to actually have this above
this
which will be a text
field input for username
and we're going to paste it it's going
to be of the type
text and it will take in username
controller
and where we will ask enter your
username
after that you're going to again have
a const sized box
and it will be of the size 24 then you
can again copy this
and
go down
below the password
and paste it over here enter your bio
and we are going to have a bio
controller
cool now let's save it and to see the
output we'll replace login screen over
here with
okay wait let me first rename log sign
up screen from here
because we had copied it from the login
screen so we can do sign of screen
and
rename all of this stuff over here
cool now we can go over here and import
sign up
screen
and paste it
now we have all of this stuff but you
know sign up in sign up we also need a
circle avatar you know a widget that is
circular and we can
accept our file from our gallery
so what we can do is go on the top over
here somewhere
and over here we are going to create a
field input
not a field input so we are going to
have
a circular
widget
to accept
and show our
selected file
so what we can create is something known
as stack so that we can
place a button and a circle avatar on
top of each other
something like this
sorry for my pathetic drawing
right
so to do that we can use stack and we'll
understand we'll have children because
well
and we're going to have a circle avatar
and a circle avatar is going to have a
radius of 64
and a background image
we need to add some background image for
now
so we can just grab some random network
image
so we can just go over here and type
unsplash.com
take some random image
copy the image address and paste it over
here
this is just for now because
we're going to view something else while
accepting it from the user
and you can see it's showing
pretty good
now
we need to even add a sized box over
here
first
now let's see we have some spacing which
is pretty good now we need to add an
icon button
where do we want to add it somewhere
over here so that user can select it so
to do that we are going to use make use
of the positioned widget
and the position widget will have a
child of icon button
[Music]
and it will have on pressed
and for now let's keep it null
and empty bracket not null
and
we are going to have an icon
of
const icon
icons dot add a photo
right
now we can just format this document
we're getting this error because we're
missing a parenthesis
cool now we can keep this circle avatar
constant for some time so that doesn't
give warning we'll have to change it
later on
we can refresh our app and we'll see our
position our widget is showing up over
here but we don't want it there right so
we can just make use of the bottom tag
over here in the position we're going to
give it minus 10
and from left
we're going to give it a tag of 80. all
of these values are tried and tested you
know trial and error
that's why i've got it right
so you can just you know have this over
here
you can even change the color of the
icon if you want over here but i'm not
going to do that i'm satisfied with
white
now we have created signup ui now let's
enter the authentication part so the
next thing we want to do is whenever the
user clicks on the sign up button we
need to make sure that the user
is created in our firebase
authentication tab over here and the
user data gets stored in the firebase
database as well
so how can we do that
to do that let's let's just you know
create a folder called resources so that
our logic is separated from our ui
right over here we can create one file
named as auth underscore methods dot
dart
we can
close all the remaining files and over
here
let's just import
material
dot over here
and we'll create a class over here a
simple class
which will have multiple functions
and we are going to have
final
firebase auth this class is provided by
firebase auth dot dart the package that
we had over here
firebase or
so uh we need to create an instance of
this firebase auth basically so to do
that we need we can just do firebase
auth
dot instance
with this we get an instance of the
firebase auth class so we can use this
and call multiple functions on it we
will see it in some time
so the first function we want to create
is to sign up the user right so
let's just create a function sign up
user
so over here we are going to receive
multiple arguments from wherever we call
the signup user method
and what do we need from the user
we will require a string email
we'll require a password
we'll required
we will require a username
uh bio
and lastly we would require a file over
here
now
the file type will be
a uint8 list if you have known about
this it's
this a list
file that we'll have this type of file
we'll see in future why we're using this
and not a file file over here
right
which might be the usual way of carrying
out things but we'll see why we need to
use you in place
uh later on in the course
right now over here the return type of
this is going to be of the type future
string
bias is going to be future because all
the calls that we make to the firebase
are going to be asynchronous so we want
our function to be asynchronous so that
means that the whole function
functions return type changes to future
and uh it will be of type string so that
we tell the user of uh you know whether
our uh
signup has been successful to our
firebase auth or it has
some error right
now to do that what we're going to do is
we're going to create a variable called
res which is a result basically and
we're going to save it with a option of
say some error occurred
now we're going to
put a try catch block
and whenever we get any error what we're
going to do is we are going to put res
equal to
error dot to string
we will have to take this error whatever
error we get
right
and finally we will have to return this
res
now over here also we need to update the
value of rest but we'll do that in a
while
first of all we need to do something
over here we first need to make some
validations right
if we need to check that all of these
are not null or empty you know
if the user has entered
a blank field and then submitted sign up
we don't want to do anything we don't
want to register that user right so
we'll check that if email dot is
not empty
or or and i'm going to do the same for
everything so i'll just copy this from
here
and paste it
so we'll do password
username
bio
and for file it's not going to be is not
empty
it's we have to check
if the file is not equal to null
now it will never be equal to null
because well we have marked this as
required
but
it's a kind of good to make this
practice over here
now we need to register the user
how can we do that with firebase right
to do that uh we can just use this auth
instance that we have over here
and if we put full stop over here we can
see multiple methods that auth allows us
you know confirm password reset create
user with email and password is what we
want but you can just check out multiple
stuff that can be done sign in with
credential sign on with custom token
sign in with email and password is what
we're going to use for login
sign in with email link you know all
sorts of stuff can be done over here
create user with email and password
now if you go over here you can see that
it will return a future user credential
so naturally we need to await this so
that we get a user credential
and we can just save this user
credential over here
right
now we have cred over here
now
cred will give us a lot of details of
our a user like
you know
cred dot it will give us the user
and user will have multiple things like
uid
email
you know but we are only interested in
the uid of the person display name will
most likely be null if you're not using
you know
uh
google authentication because you're not
setting display name to anything over
here
right
with this
we can create a user uh
in our firebase authentication
but now that's not enough right we need
to even store it in a firebase database
because we need to store all the excess
stuff like username bio file
email and password gets stored in the
authentication tab
and we can only see email by the way the
password is not seen to us as well
so uh
email and password can be uh we can just
use them to do authentication
but what about the rest of the stuff
that we want to save
we do that in the firestore database and
we're going to do that now with this
we're going to add user to our database
again we can here we call final firebase
firestore
now firebase firestore is given to us by
cloud firestore this is the package that
we have
installed in our prospect.aml file
and over here we are going to do
firestore
and we can just call
firebase
firestore dot instance
not inspect
instance
now we have the firestore instance
so we can just use firestore and it has
multiple collections
so let me show you the structure of
firestore so you can have a collection
so my collections is suppose users
so with this users i can create a
collection
suppose uh it's a list of users that i
want
so it will be a list of users now every
user will have an auto generated id or a
custom id whatever we want to set in our
case we are going to set it to the uid
of the user that i showed it to you
right
if we do print
cred
dot user
dot uid
we'll get the user id
so we are going to
not generate a document auto id
but we're going to set the user id to
this document id over here and then we
will have multiple fields like username
to something
you know like rivan
then we'll have bio to
flutter developer let's say
then we'll have email to save and the
email will be
xyz at the gmail.com
and a uid that we'll generate over here
whatever uid we set over here
that will be generated over here
and we can just pass in over here as
well now let me save it to you and show
the structure of this
so we have our users
we have a document id over here note
that the document id for different users
will be different else it will override
the same collection over here and it
will cause a problem to us and then we
have a data over here like bio uid which
i misspelled then email then username
you can even have a sub collection in a
collection like you know again you can
just type
let's say
pets
and next
and now you can type pet
one
name can be dog
and you can save over here
and you can see we have another
collection in our users collection pet
one and we can save it over here
the this is the layout of our firebase
app
and we'll see how we can store this in
our database
so let me delete this collec collection
first
i'll delete this
cool
now we can just do firestore dot
collection this path over here that we
had
and
we want to save it to users
then we'll have a doc and as i mentioned
we can just do cred
dot user dot uid make sure to put an
exclamation mark over here because user
can be returned as null you can see over
here
user can be returned as null so we need
to pass an exclamation mark so that we
can access the uid over here
and then we can just put
set
so we nee so
what we're telling to firebase firestore
is we need to create a collection users
if it doesn't already exist
then we need to
make this document
if it's not already there and then set
this data suppose this collection exists
and this uid also exists so it will
basically overwrite the existing data
and will show it to us so what do we
want over here
well
username
and we can pass an username over here
uid
i'll have to
do this
and iuid will be this only
then an email
and that email is going to be email
a bio
bio
a followers and the followers is going
to be a list
let me just put in all of this in a
string
and followers is going to be a list of
uids of different people we'll see that
logic in future
and we'll have following which is also
going to be a list
cool
now uh again this set has a written type
of future void so we need to avoid this
and well after this is done we can just
turn res
to success
and well we are returning res over here
cool now
as this should work i want to show you
another way of doing this
so uh if you don't want suppose you
don't want this uid anywhere in your app
like you don't want to access it
anywhere
so you what you can do is
you can just put await
firestore dot collection
users and you can directly call
add method over here the set method is
only on the document over here and there
is add method on this collection over
here
so if you do add
it and pass in all of these details
we'll see both of them in action and
i'll show you the difference
right
now let me save the app over here
we're not saving the file yet i will
save that in a second over here but let
me show you the demo first
so we can go where and in the sign up on
the on tap
we are not doing any uh validation like
screen change or anything right now
let me just show this to you
so uh we'll have multiple stuff let me
uncomment this file over here
and i'll remove this for now
so
we have to pass in multiple stuff
over here we'll have we'll have to
import auth methods the class that we
had created over here
then
sign up the user and pass in the email
so our email is going to be the email
controller text editor that we had
dot text
the same for password password
controller dot text
the same for user name
usernamecontroller.txt
and the bio which will be
biocontroller.txt
i am converting this arrow function to a
normal function because we need to use
async over here so we can do async
and we can store the result and string
it as equals await
and well we can just put this over here
remove one bracket and format the
document
now we can also print the rest variable
over here so that we see what's coming
up and we have printed the user id over
here so that we see what the user id
will be
and if we create the user with email and
password so let me restart this
and well
let's try to enter a username
let me name it rivan
enter in email
rivan
gmail.com make sure to add this at the
gmail.com because firebase is the one
that will be performing all the
validations of email checking
and make sure your password is more than
six characters
because your firebase checks that as
well and you can have bio as flutter
devs well
now if we click on sign up
you're not seeing anything now we can
see
this is because it was a future it took
some time to do it store it in our
database
we don't see anything here but if we go
in the authentication tab right now
you can see rivagna gmail.com the
provider was email
created signed in and the user id
check this user id over here
now again we go to firebase database
and you can see over here our users
collection has been made
and our uid over here and the uid over
here are same this is because we had run
the dot
cred user dot id and the uid is same
over here both of them is same but what
if i comment this
and uncomment this
i have not set any document over here
i've just set the uid which is this part
over here
and
let's see what firebase does for us so
i can
refresh the app
i'll enter the username rrr
i'll have to use another email because
firebase will check that this email is
already there or not
then i can again
you know have another bio i'll sign up
it will take some time and now you can
see this is our uid and we've got a
success message and you can see we have
got another user over here
but see the document id over here
this is different and this is different
because this is because uh firebase has
generated a random uh id on its own
and don't worry this id is going to be
very random and all of the users if you
use this method all of the users are
going to have different uids
so don't worry about that but you can
see that the uid over here and this is
different
and if we go over here in the
authentication
you can see
our user being created over here so this
was the difference i wanted to show you
between collection and
add and set over here
but i won't use this uh
over here because i want my
uids to come in over us because i'll be
accessing my users based on this uid so
that we get the information pretty
quickly and don't take much time to get
it
you'll see it in future and realize why
this method would be better in this
scenario now uh let's again add some of
our
functionality like
having a
u in
it list file
and checking that our file is not equal
to null what do we do want to do next we
have to store this file somewhere right
and we need to pass in a file here as
well so we need to pick an image from
the user gallery so that we can upload
it to our firebase storage as i had
mentioned previously that we'll use this
to store any of our images
so
we need to first accept this from the
user
to do that
let me just remove again this i'm so
sorry but i'll have to remove this again
so that i can show you it in demo
i'll mark i'll comment this
and
i'll save this as well
now we need to pick an image from the
user so to pick the image from the user
what we need to do is we'll have to
install this uh dependency image
underscore picker which will help us
allow to you know
take image from user gallery or from
user camera
so
i'm going to use the pub spec assist
over here and paste it over here
this will add image picker in our
app
uh dependencies i can stop this app
because it won't work properly if i
don't stop all the processes and restart
but before restarting let me just
complete complete this over here so
whenever this add photo button is
clicked i want the to you know start
the select image process so i'm going to
create a function select image
and
i'll take this up
and i'll call void
select
image
over here
now what will this select image do
we need to
pick the image so what i'm going to do
is actually create a file over here
named
utils dot dot
and in the utils.dart file i'm going to
import material package and we are going
to create a function called pick image
we are not specifying any type of this
function
as you will see in the in a bit
why we are doing this
and we are going to have an image source
this is provided by image picker itself
and
in the image source we need to
initialize first image picker
and it will be image
quicker
which will be
much bigger we have instantiated and got
the instance of the image picker
class now what we want to do is
we want this image picker
to pick an image for us
you can find all of this information on
the image picker website i'll mention
this disc in the description below the
link now
if we see pic image will give us a
future of x file
which can be null
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create x file and
we are going to
await this now to get the await we need
to mark this function as async let me
remove one space first we'll check if
the file that we've received from the
user input is not equal to null that
means the user
clicked on this button
went into the gallery then without came
back without accepting any image that
means he press the back button or
something
so we want to check if the file is not
null if it's not null then we want to
return
file
dot read as bytes now you can see the
return type of read as bytes is future
and it will return you int 8 list
so we can just do this and
we can await this and if the file is
null
what we want to do well we can just type
no image selected
we don't want to do something special
uh we just don't want to do anything
so we'll just print it for you know just
for our sake so that we can see that
we've not selected anything
and uh we are doing this file dot read
as bytes and not we are not doing this
file
uh which will be from dot io
and
from file
dot path we are not applying this method
over here and over here we don't even
need a weight we're not doing this
method because this method is not very
accessible on internet anything that
includes dart i o package is not
accessible on flutter web as of now
so we can't follow this method and get
it working on uh the web version that's
why we are following the uint 8 list
method over here
now we need to await
first we'll have to create this async
now we'll have to avoid pick image
right why do we have to avoid pick image
because we used async over here which
made the whole uh function over here a
future
and well we need to do this
and we need to provide a source and i'm
not going to do something special you
can add some options and extra stuff but
i'm directly going to mention gallery
and this will return to us a dynamic
value over here because we have not
mentioned any type over here
so uh we can just consider it to be a u
in 8 list because that's what we are
going to return and we know that's not
an error we are going to receive so we
can just do u uint8 list image which is
equal to this
and we can use you and 8 list your
because our dynamic
can be uh you and 8 list but uintah list
cannot be a dynamic now we need to set
the state
and we need to state state to a global
image variable so that we can display
this uh image over your in the network
image we'll have to remove this network
image that's not accessible we'll see it
in a while
but we'll have to remove this from here
and we have to show the image file over
here so what we're going to do we're
going on the top
over here u and 8 list
which can be nullable
which will be null in the start
and we're going to take this image from
here
we're going to go down
over here set state to image
to m
so we're taking this global variable we
are setting image to this i am over here
pretty easy right
now we need to go down in the circle
avatar
and
we need to
make a ternary operator over here so we
need to check if the image here is not
equal to null
if the image is not equal to null then
what do we want to do i'll just copy
this circle avatar from here paste it
over here i'll have to remove this
network image from here because that's
not what we're getting we're getting a
uint8 list image so that can be
accessible from memory image
and we'll pass an image
and the image has to be
not null so that memory image can take
it
now if we format this document we should
see something like this
and over here instead of this background
image we need to show a default profile
screen so we can just type over here
default
profile
picture
we can grab any of this doesn't matter
we can copy the image address
go back and paste it over here
and make sure to add this and add the
code
format the document again
and we can save this over here now let's
try to rerun our app and see where we've
got it now as you can see our app is
loaded over here and we are getting a
network image when our image is null now
if we click over here our app should
crash
and this is exactly what happens
this is because well we haven't read the
docs pretty well
as you can see over here for the
installation of ios
uh we need to do some config for android
it's not needed and even for web it's
not needed but for uh ios we need to add
some permissions in our
inflow info.list file over here so let's
do that
go to our we'll have to go to our
info.list file over here
down here i'm going to copy this and
paste it
then the key is going to be
ns photo library usage description
and
we are going to have a string over here
if you don't know about this it's fine
just copy as it is
and over here we can just type
photo
library
usage
you can just take this key and print it
two more times because we need two more
permissions and this camera usage
description
and we can just type
camera
usage
and
a microphone usage now we will not need
this but in case you want to integrate
mic uh uh like videos in your apps
after this tutorial make sure to add
this as well
uh we can just type my q search and
after this is done we can close this
file no more config is needed we can run
without debugging now our app is loaded
if we click over here you can see that
it's
asking us to access our photos we can
just write allow access to all platforms
and it opens our gallery
so
we can create this over here and you can
see that we still when we select an
image it shows up the image over here
now if we go over here and as i said if
we cancel this
we should get over here no image
selected so this is pretty cool
now the next thing we want to do is in
our
auth methods over here we'll on uncommon
this
and we need to pass in this file over
here
correct
now where can we go over here
in a file we can just pass in
the image which is not null
cool
now
with that in place
we can save this file
we can save this file as well
and well the next thing we want to do is
store this image
file that we have over here that we've
selected over here in our firebase
storage now if we store it store it
directly over here that will be a
problem because it will get overridden
quickly
and that will not be a good way of
storing because suppose i want to add
posts in the future that will also come
up here and it will not be a good thing
right we want to segregate it into
various folders so as you can see we can
create a folder over here and
this is just you know
we can create this by clicking on wire
and typing in you know profile
pics
and we can click on add folder and this
will create a folder where we can store
our files
but that's not what we want to do right
now we can just click on delete and
delete our folder over here we are going
to do that programmatically so this is
uh so to do this
we are going to create another file
named storage
methods
dot dot
we're going to import the material
package we are again going to create
this class storage methods
and over here we are going to have
firebase storage
this is given by firebase storage
and we are going to have storage equal
to 5b storage
dot instance this is the good thing
about firebase air flutter sdk you know
everything is pretty similar as you can
see to create an instance we can just do
this they have pretty similar functions
as you can see
so
we're going to create a function to add
image to firebase storage
so again our return type is going to be
a string
and
we're going to upload image to storage
now this function can be used in you
know both
uh to uh store our profile pictures and
to store our posts
so we are going to have a string of
child name over here which i'll explain
in a short while
uh we'll have our file over here uint 8
list
file and boolean
is post
so we want to check if it's post or not
and if it's supposed we need to make
some extra functionality as well
now
we can do is
we have storage
now we have a ref method on it what is
this ref method so this ref method is a
pointer to the file in our storage
so
this can be a reference to a file that
already exists or does not exist but we
don't have any ref because we don't have
a file so what we want to do is create a
child over here now this child can be a
folder right now uh it can be a folder
that exists or a folder that does not
exist firebase doesn't care about that
if it exists then it will go in that
folder or it will create a new folder
for us
so
nothing for us to be concerned about
then what is our child goal to be our
child is going to have a child name that
we are going to accept from the function
that wherever we are going to call it
and
another child we are going to have is
the user id because we want our
structure to be like this suppose i have
profile picture
our i want my file to have you know
another folder over here which is of
some uid random
uid
and it will have another folder and in
this folder we are going to upload some
file
cool
so
i can delete this again
and we can go up over here
now over here our child is going to be
the user id to get the user id what we
can do is
again create firebase auth
that we had seen earlier
we can just do this
auth
dot instance
right this is what we are done
now we will take this instance over here
auth and we have the current user
we can put an exclamation mark over here
and dot u id with this we get the uid
and we saw that previously over here in
the auth methods so we have this
collection with us
now you can check the type over here the
type over here is reference
so what we can do is create a reference
over here which will be called ref
and
we are going to save this
now
uh we want to upload the task
so
we what we want to do is take this ref
so wherever this folder structure that
we have created we want to take that and
we have to put a file in that location
so to do that we can just do ref dot
put and over here we get multiple stuff
put block put data put file put string
what do we want to do we have to put
file
we have to put
a file if we were not doing web
right we could have directly taken this
file and it would be of a type file as
you can see and i've shown it to you
previously that a file would be
something like this
right
but that is not what we are doing over
here we are trying to put a uint 8 list
to put a unit 8 list we're going to do
put data you can see over here it
accepts a data of you and date list
so you can just take this
and pass in
a file
cool
now if you put this data you can get
upload task now what is this upload task
that we have
well this upload task is similar to you
know
a future but it is not a future
you can make it like a future like on
error
dot
when complete
you can see over here
and well you can see over here it can
you can make it a future but we are not
going to do that we have this upload
task over here so with this upload task
we have the ability to control how our
file is being uploaded to the you know
the firebase storage so uh another thing
we want to do is
this upload task we need to avoid this
upload task over here
now to await it first we need to
make this function async and we need to
upload this await this upload task
now you can see
if we do await upload task it will give
us a task snapshot and we'll take this
snap
and put it equal to this i want uh from
this snapshot over here what i can get
is snap
dot you can see ref over here we can
take this ref
and over here we'll get get download url
basically this will fetch us the
download url
to the file that is being uploaded over
here so with all of this we are
successfully able to upload our file in
the correct location that we mentioned
over here and with this snap dot ref.get
download url we'll be able to get a url
which we'll save in this firestore
database
over here
so that we can you know access it with
the network image
and display it or to all of our users so
with this we'll get a download url and
definitely a download url has to be of
the type string so we can just do string
download url equal to
this
since this is a future we need to avoid
this and now since we are returning a
string we can just return
a download
url
now we are not wrapping this in a try
catch block because well we are going to
take this upload image from here and put
it over here
so this is ultimately in a try catch
block so it wouldn't matter
right now uh the function of this is
post will be seen whenever we create a
post and you'll get to know that time
for now it has no use for us so we can
go over here
and we have added this
now
before adding a user to our database we
need to make sure that this method over
here runs so what we can do is
call the storage methods
and we need to upload image to storage
now what is our child name going to be
as i mentioned before profile pics
and the file and this post is false
basically we're not uploading a post
right now right we are uploading a
profile picture
and we know that this upload image to
storage is going to return a
string so we can just do string
photo
url equal to await this
we can format this document over here
and now we can pass in
a photo url
which is a photo url
cool
now
we will refresh our app and see all of
this in action
so
let's go back to our app
and over here let's try to
take this image we are getting this
output correctly rr
norman
test123
flutter
there
now you can see that i have formatted my
email um in uh i haven't formatted my
email correctly over here
and if i sign up we should see an error
over here firebase auth invalid email
the um email address is badly formatted
this is taken care of by firebase so i'm
going to format this one to either
gmail.com not noman at the gmail.com
because i've used it previously
and i'll sign up
and if we go to our storage over here
you can see a success popping game and
we have a profile pics
folder over here and our file over here
with the name of our uid
and you can see that this is there
now i can't see this but if i want i can
just click over here and it will
download this for me if i go over here
you can see the image showing up pretty
beautifully
right now this has gone there that means
this part is working the storage part is
working we can go to our firestore
database
we can see the new user
and the new user has this photo url as
well
if we take this
and go over here
with this we should be able to download
our url of our image and as you can see
it's downloaded
pretty cool right
with just a few lines of code we are
able to sign up our user and store the
image and we are able to do lots of
things but our task is not finished yet
we are still left with uh
some validation stuff in our ui part but
before that i wanted to show you this
so suppose you are in this try catch
block and well we've got this the email
is badly formatted
or we get another thing
right so
what we want to do is
you can just do if you're familiar with
try catch you know this that you can do
on
and you can have firebase auth exception
and we can catch any error related to
firebase auth exception
error
and we can cache that exception
and with that
we need to check if
the e dot
code
this is the sorry error dot code
so if the error dot code that we get
is equal equal to
this what are we getting invalid email
right
if that is equal to this we need to pass
in something new so what i can do is
rest equal to
the
email is badly formatted
right now
this is exactly what firebase has given
to us you can have multiple error codes
like you know
uh wrong password or user with that
email is not found when you're logging
in
please have a look at that in the login
section as well
but for now you can see that the email
invalid email is there
and
if you go over here
and try to sign up with three letters of
password you can see weak password over
here so you can catch
the weak password as well over here
error dot code equal equal to
weak password
your password
so basically all of this stuff we can
just copy and paste but firebase gives a
pretty good and explainable uh output so
we don't do this but you can definitely
do if you want to add some more you know
detailed description
cool now that we have that
we can save this
we can
close the storage method file we can go
over here
and
i'm going to
clear all of this let me copy this first
i'm going to clear all of this from here
and i'm going to type in sign up
user
now this sign up user is going to be
not returning anything
so what we can do is void sign up user
and i think i copied this um i'll have
to write the whole code again i'll see
you when i write the whole code again
welcome back i've typed all of this code
again now uh we got this res variable
over here so what we want to check if
the res
is equal equal to whenever we have a
success we are setting our rest to
success right so we can just do res
equals to success then
what we want to do is well
nothing
so whenever a res is not equal to
success over here what we want to do is
well you know
show a snack bar and we're going to use
uh snack bars a lot in this so what i'm
going to do is go to the utils
i'm going to create a function named
show snack bar
it will accept a build context over here
and a string
content
and over here what we are going to have
is
scaffold messenger dot of context dot
show snack bar
snack bar
and the content will be of text content
this is all the stuff required to show a
snack bar so basically we are going to
use show snack bar
this all of this lines a lot in our
application so i've created a function
over here so that i don't have to call
it again and again and type all of this
code again and again correct
now we can just do show snack bar
and
context we're going to pass in the
context
and dress
i think we have reversed it so what we
want to do is
pass in address and context
now we can format this document so if
res is not equal to success we need to
show the snag bar when there is an else
condition we don't want to do anything
so now if i restart my app we shouldn't
see any problems
so
we can accept a file
rrr
another gmail.com
test123
flutter
dev and if i sign up this will sign up
but i don't even get to know that you
know i've signed up that will be known
when we transition to another screen but
this takes a lot of time right you saw
that this uid popped in a lot later
so to do that we are going to create a
loading variable and this loading
variable will pop up
as long as it's signing up
correct so we're going to have bool is
loading
and i'm going to set it to false
i'm also going to mark this as private
i'm going to take this is loading
and over here we are going to
set the state
is loading to
we are going to set the loading to true
then we are going to take this
and we are going to set loading to false
i want to do it before we show the snack
bar it won't be much delay
but yeah still i want to show it before
it we need to show this is loading on
our screen
right now to do that what we're going to
do is go to our container over here
where we have a button and in that child
over here we are going to
check if it's loading
so if the loading process is still on we
are going to center
with a child of circular
progress indicator
and it's going to be a constant no
dynamic values used
and
we can refresh
now we should see the changes happening
in our app
so
if i take this file over here
we're going to pass in the username as
rivan
naman rivan other gmail.com
test123
bio flutter
dev
and i'm going to sign up
and you can see
our button size increased by a bit but
it's not very well so this is because we
need to change the color of our circular
progress indicator we'll change it to
our primary color now we should be able
to see
and you can see this is happening
now you can see this email is already in
use we can just do the one one two
and you can see this loading
and this has been done
so
our sign up process has been done we can
go in our authentication tab and see all
of the stuff happening
all our emails are here
that means we have done it successfully
now let's head on to login screen having
done this let's get to the login login
part so we can go to the login screen
actually in the main.dart file over here
and we'll replace the signup screen with
the login screen so that we see our
login screen on the main screen and what
do we need to
do to you know get our user logged in
so to do that we'll again migrate to our
auth methods class over here
and we can create a function for logging
in user similar to
uh signing up the user
so
we will again have a return type of user
string we're going to follow the same
pattern we did over here create a res
variable and pretty similar to this so
we'll create a function login user and
what do we require from the parameters
over here we required
email password username bio and a file
but over here
we just need
an email and a password so we can do
that we'll uh do required string email
and a required string password
having that we'll again create a res
variable over here
we'll pass in an initial value of
some error occurred
it's highly unlikely that this output
will come up because it's either going
to be a success or a error we are doing
this over here but just in case you know
uh something happens
we can print this out
so now we'll again wrap this in a try
catch block
and
we'll have to mark this function as
async
because the
like the similar to this create user
with email and password since this is a
future login user is also going to be a
future
so uh first uh we have to check if our
email is not empty
you can actually do that in the
ui part of the app over here as well
before
calling the auth methods part but i
prefer doing it over here because my
logic is separated from the ui
now we also check that password is not
empty
then we need to log in the user to log
in the user will again grab the auth
instance that we have and we have a
function called
sign
in with
credential is there even this works but
we're going to follow sign in with email
and password
and we're going to first stop it
now
as i told this is going to be a future
you can see it over here and it returns
user credentials again
so we what we can do is just await this
we are not in need of the credentials
over here naturally because we don't
have to do any other process since
you're logging in the user we don't have
to store any of our data in the
firestore database
so
only this much is fine we don't need to
store the user credential unless you
want user id and want to carry out some
other task after this
cool and now this is done we can just
mark rest to success
and
over your
wheel turn rest to
error dot to string
and if the email is not empty we need to
show
that
the user needs to enter
all the fields
please enter all the feeds
right
now we have this we can just return res
right now we can take this login user
similar to what we did in sign of screen
we can go over here in the login screen
and
you can replace this on tab with login
user and now we need to create this
function login user so we'll do that
it's not going to return anything so
it's going to be void
then
we need to
create a variable string res and we need
to await this from the auth methods this
is basically what we did in the sign up
screen as well nothing new and since
every it is over here we'll also use
async
now odd methods dot login user
and we have to pass an email so it will
be email
controller dot text
and over your a password controller dot
text
now i'll format this document
we'll
get a rest value over here now we need
to check where if res is equal to
success
what do we need to do
else what do we need to do
so if there is over here is success we
basically want to do nothing for now
but
over here
we'll have to show a snack bar right and
for the snack bar if you remember we had
created a
function over here show snack bar we can
just use this show snack bar function
over here
so snack bar will pass in the content
over here what is our content going to
be well
it's just going to be res
and we'll pass in the context
and we need to import show snack bar
which we can do
with the utils package we use folder
that we created over here
right now
let's see if
we are getting logged in uh so to see
the user uh so to see this output first
we will move to the authentication tab
and over here we have our various emails
you can see that we have a created tab
over here created uh section just tells
us when the user was created and the
signed in when the user last logged in
so you can see all the values being 20th
december which was yesterday for me and
today's date is 21st december
so
i can uh enter this email over here
naman ravana there is gmail.com
and i remember my password being
test
one two three and we log in
i think that was a success we'll refresh
our authentication tab
and you can come over here and you'll
see
that our value of created stills remains
the same but are signed in changes to
21st december that means we have logged
in successfully
now let's just show some output on our
screen
so
to do that first you know we'll have to
login the we'll have to show some
loading bars so that we even get to know
that we've completed the process
we can create an is loading variable
over here
similar to what we did in the sign of
screen
now after this login user we can
set the state to
and we can set the loading to true
we'll copy these values
and after this we can
paste it
we can set is loading to false and in
case you want to show the loading
indicator
uh before the snag bar what you can do
is
you can take this
put this over here and we also have to
mark it over here as well because you
know this is for the if condition and
this is for the else condition
but i'm not going to do that i'm going
to paste it over here because it would
be a difference of milliseconds that
wouldn't matter at all so now let's get
the loading indicator showing up on the
screen we want it to be replaced with
this login text so we can go to the
container over here
and we can replace this text
with
a ternary condition so if the loading is
on we need to show a constant
a centered
circular progress indicator
and
we can format this document
and we can save it
now if we try to see it
you can see
the size of this being big
and we can't see the indicator revolving
that is because we need to change the
color over here the color will be a
primary color which is white
now if we try to do this you can see
this happening successfully
but now the only problem is if we're
getting logged in we are not shifting to
another screen
that is what we are going to work on now
but before jumping into that i wanted to
show you something in the auth methods
class like we saw for sign up user that
we called over here and uh on function
over here where we can explicitly
mention the exception we are looking for
we can do the same thing over here so
what we can do is on
firebase auth exception
and we can catch the specific exception
we are waiting for
and then over here we can just check
with the code so if e dot code
this is similar to what we did uh in the
sign up screen so over here we can just
check for multiple things like you know
when we log in what are the multiple
errors that a user can get and what is
the code for the firebase exception that
we can receive
so first can be user not found that
means the user has not been registered
so well we cannot log in so we can like
other stuff you know output uh
our own custom message whatever we want
the other code i want to show you is
wrong password
you again uh want to show a different
error for the wrong password so you can
just put in this or you know what we saw
for uh the
minimum password size you can put that
as well all of it is
accepted but firebase just gives a
pretty good uh user readable output and
i'm going to go forward with that so
basically i'll be the one using the app
and i don't mind getting a bit different
you know notification like a snack bar
over here i'm fine with it but if you
want to customize this is how you can do
it
now let's jump into handling the screen
change in our application so what i'm
going to do is show you two approaches
which we could have followed and you
know shift it to another screen i'm
going to create a sample screen over
here to show you the demo we're calling
it home screen dot dot you need not make
this if you're following this tutorial
step by step so you can create a
an import material package
i'm going to call it as a stateless
widget because it's just for demo
and over here i'm going to display a
centered
text of
home screen
and i'm also going to wrap it with a
scaffold so
that we see a good output
all right we have this and for now let's
just put cons to avoid all the warnings
that we're getting
the first approach we could have taken
is if we got the success in the login
screen
we could have just used navigator
dot of context dot push
replacement
material page route
with the context
and we could have passed in home screen
right to avoid the warning vlog input
const i always forget this now i'll
refresh my app and see so whenever we
have the success variable coming in we
can change to the next screen so i'm
going to log in with my email and
password
and i'm going to click on login
and as you can see we went to the home
screen so what's the issue why
is this approach not appropriate with
firebase and any other stuff
now let me refresh our app
if i refresh my app you see we again go
to the login screen this is because in
our main.dart file we have told that a
home of our application is going to be
login screen and we are not making any
additional checks that you know if the
user is logged in we need to go to the
we need to display the home screen
anything like that so the user state has
not persisted
well we can obviously display the user
id and everything over here but we not
be able to see another screen right and
this is why this approach is not
appropriate so instead what we're going
to do is you know go to the main.dart
file over here we're going to implement
the concept of a persisting user state
the user state uh
can be persisted in firebase a very easy
method so we are going to implement the
concept of use uh persisting user
authentication state
so a fire with firebase doing this is
pretty easy and other database and if
you worked with node.js and everything
so what we need to do is store the
store the
uid or some unique identifier in the
app's memory then get that from the
app's memory and well you know uh
check if the
user with that uid is authenticated or
not we'll have to do a lot of juggling
but instead firebase just provides us
with multiple methods we can make use of
and we'll get our work done
so what i'm going to do over here is use
a stream builder because firebase
returns that
i'm going to show you another approach
for user authentication state as well so
don't worry
over here we'll have a stream obviously
because it's a stream builder and a
builder over here we are going to get a
context
and we are going to get
a snapshot
and over here in the stream what we are
going to pass in
as i said firebase provides us with
multiple methods that we can run to
check if the authentication state is
there or not
the three methods that uh
there are three methods that firebase
provides us
one uh the first one is the id token
changes
uh so how you can do this is firebase
auth
dot instance
what we did in the auth methods you can
just create a variable over here and
input it over here you import it over
here sorry
then over here we can just click id
token changes now you can see the return
type is stream of an available user it
can be a null
right
now id token changes and this is what it
takes to you know get the abuser uh
signed uh to listen to any changes in
the user but
uh when will this uh method be called
right
this will be called right after the uh
listener has been registered and when
the user is signed in or whenever the
user signs out
or there is a token change in the user
so every user has a unique identifier
token which firebase
gives
and whenever this id id token changes
this method this method can get run so
this is not the method we are going to
use right now as i said firebase
provides us with three methods this is
the first method and this is we are not
using this because this will uh run
whenever the id token changes so suppose
the user uh
restores this app on a new device well
this will run and we'll get our
authentication state back but we don't
want to do that instead
uh we are going to use some other
function but before that let me show you
a second function which is user changes
so this runs whenever uh the user has
been uh signed in signed out everything
that uh this uh the other function id
token changes does
but
what extra functionalities this provides
us is whenever we want to update our
password update our email whenever uh we
want to update that firebase does
provide some methods for that as well
and whenever those functions get called
this
gets called as well
but uh we don't want to make the this
function call when all of those changes
take place because those changes are
never going to take place
uh uh we are going to use the third
method which is
auth state changes
now this runs only when the user has
signed in or signed out that's it
so this is what we are going to use
because our purpose is very minimal we
don't want extra stuff to be happening
but if you want you can just use id
token changes
or
user changes anything you want
but i prefer this one
then what we need to do over here so if
this is a stream builder you might be
familiar that we need to first check if
our connection has been made with a
stream
so we can just check if
snapshot.connectionstate
equals to the connection state and it is
active or not
and if it is active we need to check
active means that the connection has
been made with our stream over here and
if it is active we need to check if the
snapshot that we have over here
has any data or not
right
we don't want it to be null and if it
has data what we want to do is well i'll
uncomment this
i'll take this responsive layout and
i'll remove it from here
and i'm going to return this
so
and we are going to
put a semicolon over here so whenever
the connection is active and our
snapshot starts to have any data we are
going to response uh we are going to
return a responsive layout
now let's move on to the else conditions
now
else if
you know
there is no data that means the snapshot
has error
that means the connection state has been
made but the snapshot has does not have
data it has an error what do we need to
do
we can just return
a centered widget with a text displaying
the error
now since
i don't want it to be very complicated
i'm just going to pass in snapshot dot
error
and i'm going to
use interpolation
and i'm going to use string
interpolation over here
but if you want you can just type you
know some internal error occurred
something like that
but i want to show this error
cool
now having that
we need to
check if the connection has not been
made so if the snapshot connection state
is equal to connection state
dot waiting that means the connection is
still happening what do we need to show
we need to show a circular progress
indicator
we're going to do that
child
and a center
sorry a circular progress indicator
and we will have to
change the color of this
circular progress indicator
which will be primary
and we will set this to a constant
widget and i'll put a semicolon as well
now we have implemented all of this so
that means the connection state has been
active
and connection
if it's not active then it's waiting
that means we need to show a circular
progress indicator but the key point
over here is snapshot dot has data
now if snapshot has data it means that
the user has been authenticated that's
why we are showing the responsive layout
over here
but what if the snapshot doesn't have
any data we have not checked any
condition for it so after checking all
of these conditions and if all of these
conditions are not fulfilled we are
going to return a login screen because
the snapshot does not have any data
ultimately and if it does not have any
data it means that the user has not been
authenticated
now if i refresh my app over here we
should see this is mobile because the
user has been authenticated
pretty simple right now we can just
remove this
and delete this
now even uh no i'll even have to remove
this from here
now even if i stop my app processes
i'll restart it i should see this is
mobile screen on the in the center text
let's wait for it and we'll see that all
right our app has been loaded and you
can see no difference this is mobile is
showing up over here because our user
has been authenticated now let's try the
same thing on our web version so what
we're going to do is flutter and dash
the
chrome
and
make sure to add dash dash web renderer
html because the default one is canvas
and canvas law causes a lot of issues in
flutter web so make sure to have the web
renderer as html don't worry if you
release this uh if we create the build
of the release version uh it will be in
the html format only and we'll get a
good output and it will be similar to
this we won't get any external
factors affecting our app so don't worry
alright our web version has been loaded
and you can see over here we're getting
the login screen because the snapshot
over here does not have any data even
though we logged in over here before i
think we did so now we will try to log
in and i'll enter my email naman rivaan
actually what i'm going to do is
sign up and i just realized that we
haven't configured anything for you know
clicking this button over here the sign
up button so what we can do is go to the
login screen over here
and go to the bottom
and in the sign up
we can create a function called
navigate
to
sign up
i'll copy this go on the top create a
function again
void login navigate to sign up and we
basically you're going to use navigator
navigator dot of context this context
don't worry this is like uh the state
over here provides us with the context
in that app so
yeah we can use that and we are going to
push
to the
material page route
and we are going to pass in the we are
going to receive a context and we are
going to pass in the sign of screen
this is going to work we know it for
sure so i'm not even going to test it
i'm going to format this document i'm
going to copy this function from here
and go to the sign up screen
paste this function over here and say
navigate
to login
and i'm going to pass in the login
screen
i'm going to copy this function go down
i'm going to replace this
sign up with login this is the issue we
had before
didn't notice it
and we'll save it so our web has been
loaded up and now if i click on the sign
up button over here it should work
now i'm going to select an image and
this should work we haven't tested this
on the web version
and this works because you know uh the
image picker dependency that we added to
pick images is configured for the web
i'm going to add in a user name over
here let's call it trivan i'll call the
email naman rivan
1234567 at the gmail.com
then we can add a password test one two
three and over here i'm going to write
content creator
and we can click on sign up and the
output should not be the home screen
that we get
this is because well we haven't told
what to do when the res variable is
success
so when our variable is success what do
we want to do we need to
basically show this responsive layout
that we have so i'm just going to copy
this and paste it over here oh sorry
first we need to navigate
so i'm going to copy this function from
here paste it over here then copy this
from here
and then
replace this with sign of screen
we don't need to add a return because
this is an arrow function
now we're going to employ import
some of the widgets
having that in place now we should
format the document
and we're going to do the same process
for login screen as well so i'm going to
copy this from here go to the login
screen
and we had created ifres equal to
success and this is why we had created
we need to navigate to the other screen
we're going to import all of this
also we don't want push over here we
want push replacement
push will uh well if we just click on
the back button we can go back to the
login screen but that's not what we want
we want to replace the current screen
with another screen
so we'll do the same over here as well
and
i'm going to refresh over here and over
here but we need to restart our app
entirely because well this was mobile
will show up because our authentication
state has been persisted
so if we run our flutter chrome version
again we should see a login screen
because that's how flutter web works it
creates a new chrome
instance every time unlike the ios
simulator over here
so let's wait for our chrome to run up
as you can see we get our login screen
back again i want to
sign i want to
sign up actually again to show you that
it works if it works so here then it
will work on the login screen as well
i'm going to create another user ivan
naman
one two three at the right gmail.com i'm
going to enter a password test one two
three and a bio off again content
creator
and i'm going to add extra
over here so that you can see extra
stuff and not the same stuff on every
user
now i'm going to create a user
and you can see we shifted to the mobile
screen
and our state has been
persisted as well if i do restart you
can see that this is the state of our
app
and this works as we had before but this
is not the cleanest way of writing the
code because if we go in the auth
methods file you can see that all of
this data we are adding over here and
suppose our app grows bigger so and we
need to add all of this data again then
we'll need to probably you know uh add
all of this we'll add all of this and
then probably we'll forget which is not
a good way and will cause bugs in our
app so what we can do to avoid these
type of issues is create a model
and
we are going to create multiple models
one for user one for post in the future
for now let's create a user model
and since it's a dot file we don't need
to you know create import material dart
where we'll have a user class
and over here in the user class we're
going to add in a lot of you know
properties of this user class what all
properties do we want so our properties
are going to be this
so we can type them out
okay so we have typed all the fields
that are required which are basically
this
so
i've copied them over here now we need
to require them from our constructor
which we'll create
and i'm going to use named constructors
because there are a lot of things to add
let's add them so we have our
constructor here as well now let's add
some functions we can use on user so
that you know it's very accessible for
us while using firebase so we are going
to create a two json method over here
basically this method will be used to
convert uh whatever user object we
require from here to an object
so we can do that by two json method and
we're going to return an object
and our object is going to have username
a uid
then an email
a photo url
bio
followers
and following
so whenever we call this two json method
on our user class it will convert uh
everything that we receive from the
arguments to a to an object file so that
we don't have to write this same code
wherever we use it all right now this is
done we have to create another function
for the user class but we'll create it
as and when we need it we need to json
function right now in our you know auth
methods class which we'll look at in
some time so let's go in the auth
methods class where what we can do is
create a user model
so we can call user now make sure to
import uh there are two types of user uh
we have seen this before
but
we want to import the user that
is this one
but since uh the user from firebase auth
the the user firebase auth provides us
and the user we have will clash we can
do this we can import this as model so
that we know that this is a model user
that we want and where we can do model
dot user and we can create a user
and to create a new user we can just do
model user now we have to pass some
past some arguments in the constructor
so i've copied all the values that were
present over here over here and now what
we can do is
take this set
and we can remove all of this and now we
want to set this user object over here
so we can just do this
user
now this has to accept a map
right and we have made the map function
basically over here to json file so we
what we can do is call dot to json and
this to json basically returns a map for
us for us as i said an object
so yeah we can just do that and we can
format this document
this should work as it worked before
now you can see the state of this app is
still the same because even if we
reinstall or uninstall the app nothing
affects the persistence of state in our
ios simulator
so we can just run the
chrome version
using the command we saw earlier
and let's wait for it now let's sign up
and our
file we are going to select
this file
i'm going to enter my username as rivan
ranavat
my email is going to be rewind rana 1.3
other gmail.com
password will be test123
and i can type your abc
and we're going to click on sign up
and we have gone to the next screen that
means our authentication has been
successful if we go in the firestore
database over here
we should see our data coming off
and
well there are a lot of users that we
have created and you can see our email
driven.123.gmail.com
and a user has been stored so this
modeling of data helps us a lot in our
apps as you can see you know whenever we
want to create a user model we can just
uh you know create this and we are
prompted of the
fields that we have to enter so that we
don't miss anything and we'll also see
this benefit when we use a state
management with provider okay so now i'm
in my mobile screen layout and what i
want to do is display my username that i
had entered in the sign up screen on my
mobile screen layout so what i want is
if i'm this user
i want the uid of this i want to display
the name of rivan ranavat right now
so how can i do that well
let's try to do that first we'll have to
convert our stateless widget to stateful
widget because we are changing the state
in our app right now
then we'll have to create a global
variable suppose i create the variable
string
username which is equal to empty now we
also called in its state because well it
should run in the start of the
application so that i get my username
and since init state cannot be turned to
async and we're going to make calls to
firebase it will become
a future so what i can do is create a
method over here
get username suppose
then
i can create a function get username
after that i'm going to turn my function
asynchronous i can make my function over
here asynchronous but over here i can't
make my function asynchronous i can make
like this but it will give errors you
can try it on your own
then
we'll
have to make calls to firebase firestore
dot instance
dot collection
users
so
uh so this is the method we use to get
the data from the firestore basically we
have made uh
give me a reference to our collection
over here which is users the next thing
i want to do is
get this part so i want to get through
this part and when the uids are known
what we can do is
put dot doc
and in the dock we can put our user id
if we know it so what is our user id
firebase
auth dot instance dot current user dot
uid we know about this
so whatever uh so we'll go in the user's
collection then we'll find our uid with
matching to this uid in the documents
these are the documents
and
what we want to do is get this
information from here
so what i can do is dot get
now you can see where get is a type of
future document snapshot this document
snapshot is given by firebase firestore
itself what is a document reference a
document snapshot
well you can see that we have gone to
the till the dock
and we are getting a one-time view of it
so we can read uh from this only one
time so it is called a document
and a snapshot like just like a camera
you take a picture which is called a
snapshot
the
similar to that so we can just do
document snapshot
snap which is equal to this and we can
await it
then we can format the document
now we have access to snap and what we
are going to do is print snap
dot
data
this is a function uh
basically
firebase provides us with to get the
data of the app there are a lot of more
functions like snap dot you know
a get request on another snap then snap
dot id then we can check if the snap
exists or not in this case you're pretty
sure that the snap will exist that's why
the user is on the mobile screen layout
so we are not doing uh making the
condition of a snap exists or not for
now and if we print snap like this we
will get in our console something like
instance of document snapshot
but we won't get any value so what we
can do is console.log snap.data
and
we can run our app
and our app is run and you can see we
are getting the data from the firebase
firestore so we've got our uid
following
bio
followers email
username now i want this username so
what i can do is i have my
obvious variable over here i can
set the state
to user name
equal to
snap
dot data
and to access snap dot data what we have
to do is well you know just type
username
and we'll have to put a semicolon as
soon as we put an exclamation mark over
here we get an error saying that this
bracket type is not supported for this
kind of uh
for this data so what we can do to fix
it is if we go over over here we can see
that it is object and well we can just
uh explicitly mentioned that this is map
of string
and dynamic
and we can put this in
over here in parenthesis and we don't
even need to do this
so basically we are since this is an
object
we and map is a subtype of object
so we can just dynamically say that you
know
our
object over here is a map and then we
can access this uh
username property on this
cool now if i run my app and first of
all i'll need to print my username over
here which i will do dollar username
and i'll print i'll refresh my app and
you can see rrr printing over here so
this is how we can do one time read and
get our data
but in case our username changes somehow
so suppose i go over here and find rrr
username
and over here i'm going to change my
username to
rivan ranavat right now
i can come over here and see no changes
being made in my app
the if i refresh
it will change to rewind run but this is
because uh get user name will only run
in the init state function and this uh
with the get function we can only get
the uh
get a one-time view of the data that is
present in the reference we have made
over here the username doesn't change
but what if we want to keep the track of
the username that is coming and you know
changing every time it changes i want to
display the change we look at it in some
time but now i want to focus on another
issue over here so suppose i have
another screen like web screen and i
want to do the same thing print my name
over here
should i just copy all of this function
and put it there again
like this i'll have to copy this
function then go over here
then convert this to stateful widget
again then paste it over here
does this seem you know a good way to do
things
it doesn't to me
so uh i'm going to follow a shorter way
of doing it basically we are going to
use state management where we are going
to get a get data from the database one
time
so it will reduce our calls to the
database and then we are going to use
the values that we have gotten every
time we are
uh using our app we are going together
suppose i want the username i can get
the username one time
cool
so let's do that i am going to change
this to this is mobile again so for the
state management what we're going to use
is called a provider package i'll
mention this link in the description
below
so what you can do is copy this you can
read this
it is a pretty good documentation
and uh but if you want to know like the
basics of it what we're going to cover
in this tutorial i'll be explaining it
but if you want to know in detail you
can just go through their docs
now i'm going to add this in the popspec
assist
and
i'm going to click enter we'll have to
stop our app processes
and
we're going to create another folder
called providers
i'm going to create a file user
underscore provider
dot dot
now where i'm going to
create a class of user provider
and we have to extend this class with
something known as
change notifier
so this change notifier provides us with
some functionality in our app so
basically uh we are inheriting from this
chain notifier some of our functions so
now if we uh create a global variable
user
let me import that
from my own models user i told to you
that you're going to make use of a user
right now we can just do user which is
nullable
and we're going to call it user make
sure to make this user a private field
because we don't want to because it will
cause bugs in our app if we don't use
this and in future we'll be able to
access user provider
suppose we have this class user provider
then we'll able we'll be able to access
this user on it which we don't want to
it will cost strange bugs in our app
so we can just put a private field over
here so i told you how uh we have to
make this private field so how will we
access the user field right suppose i
want to get this data of the user
provider
what can i do i can just create a user i
can create a get
method basically
and we'll name it get user and you're
going to return this user and to return
it we're going to call it that it's not
going to be null
cool now having that we are going to
create a function which is
future
void
and we are going to refresh the user
every time
so basically this function is there so
that we can update the values of our
user
so
what can we do
so we want to go to the auth methods
class over here and we are going to find
the user uh so where we are going to
create a function which will help us you
know uh get the user details whatever we
did in the mobile mobile screen layout
first we are going to implement that in
uh
this uh
class over here
let's do that we'll have to create a
future and we'll have to pass in the
model dot user
type
so
we're going to get the user details
and our uh
and how do we get that information well
first of all we'll get our current user
so we can just do user
current user
which is equal to auth
we have initialized this over here
dot current user
and we're going to put an exclamation
mark over here
and make sure to replace this model user
with just user that is provided by the
firebase
this will not give an error because
current user just gives this user and
this is provided by firebase auth
then we need to create a document
snapshot as we saw
so we'll get a snap
we are going to avoid this
try this on your own and see if you
remember this
firestore
dot collection
users
dot document and what document do i want
current user
dot uid
dot
get
then
we need to return this user so we're
going to return model dot user and we're
going to pass this snapshot basically
but we can't do that right because well
it doesn't accept a snapshot so we need
to pass in something like this well you
know
uh
we are going to pass in followers for
followers we are going to do snap dot
data
as
map
string
dynamic
and
we are going to
pack this with a parent thesis
then we can do
and we can call this over here then use
follow us
is that what we're going to do for every
a property
i think it's a lot of time wasted so
instead what we're going to do is create
a function in our user model
not this
user
but you know this user model
and over here we're going to create a
function uh which will be named of which
will basically convert our document
snaps which will basically take in a
document snapshot and return a user
model
right that will make our lives much
easier and it will be a one-time job for
us
so
we can just do static user
from snap it will take in a document
snapshot
then we are going to
first get the snapshot so as we did over
here we basically need to you know
take the snapshot
dot data
and
we are going to mark it as
map
string
dynamic
we'll try using this as snap and we can
do snap dot data
right because you have called snapshot
over here which basically we are
referencing while we are initializing it
doesn't make sense
then we are going to return the user as
we did over here
now we didn't do that over here and
instead we are doing this over here
because well it will be a much more uh
useful thing to do
does uh we'll be separating you know all
this stuff that is you know related to
user model we won't do that in the auth
methods we'll be using that in the user
user model
seems like a clean way to do stuff
then we can call the snap short over
here
and we can pass in username
and we are going to do that for all the
properties that we have yeah this is
pretty much it now uh with this function
we are taking in a document snapshot and
returning a user model so that's exactly
what we need over here so what we can do
is return
user which is the model user one
dot from snap and we're going to pass in
the snap
and this is how easy our job uh gets
done we did this in the uh user model
because well we'll have to use it
differently in different places so this
will be a good way and we don't have to
pass in snapshot username everywhere we
use it
cool
now
in our user provider what we can do
is and uh we are going to get a user
and
we are going to await
auth methods
so let's create a refer
let's initialize our odd methods class
which is equal to auth methods
then we can take this auth methods we
are going to
call that dot get user details the
function that we created right now and
we returned a user model from it
cool now we can just do user which is
our global variable aware we're going to
set user to this user
and
what we're going to call now is notify
listeners basically
it will notify all the
listeners to this user provider that the
data of our global variable user has
changed so you need to update your value
now uh to add some listeners what we can
do is go in the main.dart file
and uh there are multiple ways you can
do
the same thing like using a consumer or
provider
so what i'm going to do is wrap this
material app which is our
most parent widget to so to say
and we are going to wrap this material
app with multi provider
which is provided by flutter and over
here it will take in a list of providers
and i've chosen this method because as
our app gets bigger and bigger we'll
have to use a lot of providers so we can
just wrap it with multi-provider and it
will be a one-time setup for us as else
we'll have to use consumer and provider
everywhere
and then
we're going to use something known as
change notifier provider over here we
use change notifier
but where we are going to use change
notifier provider which is provided by
the provider package and you're going to
pass in create and this will take in a
user provider class that we create
cool
i'm going to format this document now
having that in place we are going to
save our file
now
we shouldn't expect our app to you know
directly have a state management system
because well if we go in our user
provider class again
we need to call refresh user somewhere
this function has to be called somewhere
so that this user variable gets updated
or else if we print the value right now
of user provider uh well we'll get a
null value and we don't want that so we
have to call this refresh user somewhere
where can we do that
after our login is done we don't want to
call this refresh user on login but so i
want to call it somewhere in the
responsive layout
because it consists of web screen layout
and mobile screen layout both else you
could have done it in web screen and
mobile screen both but since this is the
parent element and consists of both of
them i'm going to do it here we can
convert this responsive layout widget to
a stateful widget
and we'll have to call init state aware
now the init state will have add
data over here
then
we'll have to create add data because
it's an asynchronous function
then we need to call in something known
as user provider
underscore user provider
which is equal to
provider
so this is provided by the provider
class
dot of context this context will be from
the state so don't worry about it
and
we need to just do this much but if we
do this much it will constantly listen
to the
values given by the user provider we
don't want that we just need to call
refresh user once on it so what we're
going to do is turn listen to false
basically with this we can
get a one time view or one time we can
do stuff one time with the user provider
class we have
then we can await this
user provider dot
refresh user
this is all it takes to store value in
our user provider basically the user
class that we have in the
user provider this class we have stored
value in it now
and now what we can do is
go to our mobile screen layout
and we can just do
provider
again we'll call actually what i'm going
to do is create a user class itself
then we're going to do user user which
is equal to provider
dot of context
dot now we don't get any functions to do
over here because we haven't mentioned
the type of the provider we can do that
over here and what value are we
expecting a user
provider
dot
get user
so this isn't a function
it will get the user from here
and
we have the same issue like before we
have our firebase auth and our
user model
so
what we need to do is first of all
import the
user model
and we have to import it as model
now we can do model dot the user
cool now our error is gone so we are
going to call the get function over here
and it will get us the user so we can
just do this we can take this user
variable
print this over here user dot
username all right our app is ready and
you can see my username printing over
here you'll get this error but don't
worry about it this is just a sample
what we're doing uh so when we do the
final version we won't be seeing any
error like this
now we have a state management uh with
us where we can call anything like i
want to call user dot i want to get my
email so i can just do this refresh my
app and i'll see namandrawan at the
gmail.com showing up
pretty cool right now let's work on the
ui of our app so in the mobile screen
layout what we want to do is create a
tab bar basically and this tab bar
should be present somewhere over here
and we should have uh some icons like a
home icon
then a search icon
then an
add post icon
then uh notifications page icon and then
the profile screen icon and based on the
user interaction on these buttons we
have to show the pages uh that follow so
how are we going to do that let's dive
into it so we are in the mobile screen
layout let's remove our provider stuff
from here we don't need that in this
case it's just for demo
i'll remove all the
imports as well
now in our body uh let's just keep
this is mobile which is going to change
in the future we'll have to wrap it with
some parent widgets so that we can show
the user interaction based you know
uh screen
now let's add a bottom navigation bar
the stuff that is present over here
and
to do that we'll use a cooper t no tab
bar because i want it uh in a style
which is ios based
you can even use bottom navigation bar
widget
now in this we need to mention the items
and our items are going to be of the
type bottom navigation bar item
it is going to have an icon and our icon
is going to be icons dot home
cool and we need to pass in some stuff
where like label else it will give you
an error
and a background color what is the
background color going to be well it's
just going to be primary color
the white color basically
cool
we are not uh
we are not making this a constant
because we'll have to change it in the
future like the
value over here
is going to be dynamic the colors and uh
so we are not making it uh constant
we can just copy this bottom navigation
bar items and paste it
five times i guess
so the second is going to be a search
one
then the third is going to be to add a
post so it will be add circle
then a notifications page we can just
use you know
favorite
and we need to paste one more time
and
this is going to be icons dot
person to show the profile screen now if
we save this and re-run our app we
should see something like this
the only problem i have with this is the
color so we can change the color
by going over here and changing
background color to
mobile background color which is this
color as well now if we save this we
should see it coming in sync now i don't
want the colors over here to be you know
blue i want the selected tab bar to be
the color of
white or gray
so we can make use of conditional
rendering
and
first we have a global variable
end page which is equal to zero i'm
marking it private
then uh we can take this page variable
from here and we can go down and uh
change the color of the icon based on
these so if color so the color over here
is going to be
based on the page so if the page is
equal to 0
then we need to show a primary color or
a secondary color
our primary color is the white color uh
and the second color is gray color
basically what we telling is the page
when it is zero will change to primary
and secondary we'll handle the updating
value of this page uh in the future in
some time
so
yeah let's see if we are getting white
and we are getting white now let's add
this logic for each and every icon
i'm going to copy this and paste it over
here
over here the page is equal to one else
this will also also show primary color
over here we'll set it to two
here it will be three
you're a four
and
your uh five
then we can format the document
and all our warnings are gone because
this is based on the conditional
rendering it is not a constant value
now if we see we are getting it as we
wanted now this home icon we don't want
so we can take this home icon and remove
it from here
and we'll have to change these values
again i'll do that
now we can refresh and see our app
coming
so now the next thing you want to do is
based on the so whenever the user clicks
on one of these icons we need to make
sure that the page value has updated
and based on this page value we are also
going to show the screens now we need to
conditionally render the icon color so
we uh so cupertino tabber provides us
with an ontap function so whenever any
uh bottom navigation bar item is clicked
over here we can change the value so we
can create a function called navigation
tab
we can take this function and paste it
over here
void navigation tab
and
page
we are going to make some use of
something known as a page controller so
let's create a page controller we'll do
late
page controller and we're going to name
it page controller itself we're going to
create an init
state and in the united states we are
going to
set page controller equal to the page
controller
and we are also going to create a
dispose method and right now itself
we'll call the page controller.dispose
method else we'll forget that
cool having that
in the navigation tab uh what we want to
do is
we want the page controller
to jump to that page so we can just do
jump to page and we can pass in the end
of page
so basically we are telling the page
controller that we have over here to
jump to that page we won't see any
difference as such because we haven't
given passed in the page controller
anywhere basically this will act as a
link between uh the tab bar and the
widget that we are going to add in the
body and that widget is a page view
and this page view will accept a
parameter of children
then
after that it's going to accept a
parameter of controller which is which
we're going to pass in as page
controller and then an on page changed
function
where we'll pass in on page change
function we'll create that in a while
but basically this children is a list of
widgets that we need and in the list of
widgets it will uh conditionally render
based on the
bottom navigation bar item
so
uh suppose our
bottom our page index is zero right now
and we click on the search icon over
here we click we need to show a search
screen so if we put text as
feed over here and i'll copy this to
show you the demo
we'll have search over here
and order add post screen
then notif
and profile
and we save this and we have to create
this on page change function but we'll
do that in a while
so whenever this gets tapped over here
we see the search coming up
then an add post
then
the
notification
and then profile
that's how we wanted we also want to
change the color of this
which will be done uh with this on page
changed function over here we can
uncomment this and we can create a
non-page changed function which will be
of the type void so void on page change
it will receive a page
page
argument then we can set the state to
from page
to this page
cool now we can refresh our app and now
you can see this color changing and our
screen over here changing as well
uh the next thing we want to do is
basically if we do this we are able to
change the screen right we don't want
that because the real instagram doesn't
have that feature
we are able to uh change the screen
based from navigation items only and not
from here
so
what we can do is
add something known as physics over here
and the physics will take in scroll
physics we want the physics of never
scrollable physics
which will allow us to not you know have
this cool effect
i'll put it as a constant and now if i
try to change you can see we are not
able to change it
cool now we have a working tab bar so
the next thing we want to do is create
the add post screen ui basically
whenever we click this button we should
see the add post
screen ui so
first let's decide how our ad post
screen is going to look like
so i have my marker over here basically
we want a center button over here which
will basically tell us to upload a file
from our image
right or from our camera we're going to
add that options over here and whenever
we click that button and we select a
file this button should erase off we
don't want to see this button
and we need to see other ui like we want
to show
a profile over here profile image of the
user and app bar which says post to then
an image
that we have selected and
an option to well display our
description
like whatever bio we want to put right
so let's try to make that kind of stuff
so
over here in our application we're going
to create a screen named as
add
post
screen dot dot
and we are going to import the material
package as usual
then we are going to create a stateful
widget over here because we are going to
make use of description controller and
everything so we need the nh state and
dispose method
then we are going to create the add post
screen class
over here i am going to return a
container because a centered button is
what i want so actually i'll just
replace this container with center
widget
then we are going to return a child of
icon button as we mentioned previously
then in the icon button we are going to
add an icon of
ikins
dot upload
and this is obviously going to have an
on pressed function because it is an
icon button
so let's try to see this on a screen uh
we'll have to take this ad post screen
and we'll have to uh
replace this with this over here but
actually what i like to do is
i'm going to rename this dimensions to
a file named as global variables
so where we can add most of the global
variables that can change over time so
that we are not in use of it right
so
we can add this
uh
what we are going to call it we are
going to call it constant
home screen
items let's say
and this is going to be a list of
widgets
so
we can copy this from here we'll replace
this as and when you know we get another
widget we create another widget for now
we have the add post screen we can add
that
cool now let me format the document
now we can replace this children
with
home screen items
having that in place let's rerun our app
and see if we're getting the output and
we are getting a centered widget of
uploading now let's try to create the
description or you know the ad post ui
we had this we have discussed so what
i'm going to do is
for now i'm going to uh comment this
and we're going to return a scaffold
because
this widget will be only visible when
our file is not selected from the
gallery we haven't added anything
with related to functionalities yet so
i'm just going to comment this and we
are going to work on the plain ui of our
app
so we are in our app bar we are going to
have an app bar
uh we're going to have a background
color of mobile background color else it
will give us another background color
then we need a an icon over here which
basically tells us to go back so that
you know we can clear off the image if
we have any so we're going to create an
icon button for that
and we're going to have an icon
our icon is going to be
icons dot arrow back
then we are going to have an on pressed
and our onpress is going to be null for
now i mean an empty bracket for now not
null
then we are going to have a title
our title is going to say
well it will be a text and it will say
post
then if we keep it like this our title
will be center aligned let's see it in
action
if we go where we can see post 2 it is
in center but i don't want that
so what i'm going to do is put center
title to false
then we need
we can save this and we can see the
title going there so over here i want to
create a post button from which we can
you know click and we can get post so
we're going to add an actions
and actions is going to be a text button
on pressed is going to be nothing for
now
and our child is going to be a constant
text
which says post now we will have some
styling over here because we wanted blue
so we can just do text style
then our color can be
colors dot blue accent
you can just use the blue color that is
mentioned in the colors dot dot file we
can then have a font weight of
font weight dot bold and a font size of
16.
let me format the document
i'll even put a comma ir so that we get
the formatting correct
now let's see our app
and it looks pretty cool
now uh we need to work on the
next section which is the body section
so we can get out of the app bar widget
and have a body
and a body now we need to work on the
post form kind of thing so
we
want a description controller then our
circle avatar with the profile photo and
the image we have selected
so
the
we'll add column
and
then in the column we're going to have
children we have added a column because
uh below the app bar we need to show you
know a
linear indicator while this is being
posted for now we are not going to add
the linear indicator we will add when
the loading process has to be shown but
we can have a column right now
then we'll have a row
and then the row will have main access
alignment to main access alignment dot
space around
and cross access alignment to start from
the start
then it will have children and the
children will have circle avatar
we will have to provide a background
image and it will be a network image and
we'll have to find a
good uh background image for our file so
we can just go on unsplash.com
and find a good
profile picture for now copy
we can just open the image in new tab
and
copy this from here
that should work
so we can pass this over here
now
uh
our circle avatar should show up
and you can see it's showing up in the
center now but we'll add some stuff
using which it will go in the left side
so the next thing you want to add is a
size
box and within the size box we can have
a text field so
the width is going to be medium we want
it responsive so we are going to make
use of media query and
it's going to be the total width of the
screen size and we're going to multiply
it with the 0 0.3 constant value
you can play around with these values
and find whatever is suitable for you
then we're going to add a text field
note that you know we are only adding a
width so we are using size box over here
if you wanted to add extra features you
know like padding and everything you can
just use a container instead
then over here we need to passion pass
in a decoration
and it will be an input decoration
then we need to pass in a hint text
which will be right
write a caption
not a comma first
then we need to pass in a border of
input
border dot none
and
we are going to
mag we are going to have a max lines
property using with the length of the
controller can increase and will have a
max length lines capacity so we are
going to pass in as 8 the default is 1 i
guess
then
having that in place we need to create a
rectangle image on the side
let's see if we're getting that write a
caption we're getting that
now we can
create another sized box
and we're going to have a height of
and a width of
45 then we're going to have a child of
aspect ratio basically this helps to
keep
your the children and the child in the
aspect ratio consistent uh with the
width and the height so we're going to
add a value of 487 by 451. all of these
values are just you know trial and error
i just formulated this like them only
then a child
will pass in a container
and we have passed in a container
because we want to add decorations
like an image so we'll have box
decoration
and we're going to have image property
and image will take in a decoration
image
and decoration will image will have a
image of whatever we pass in
and it will be a uintate list but you
know uh
we can just take this uh
image that we had
copy image address and we can paste that
only we'll change as and when we want
we want it to be of type of box fit dot
fill
alignment in the top right top center so
we'll do fractional
offset dot
top
center we're going to save this
we're getting these warnings because uh
for now the network image and all are
you know a constant but this will change
over time so i'm not making any changes
now if we save and go to our right we
can see that it's looking pretty cool
but this description controller looks a
bit off so what i'm going to do is
increase the width and change it to 0.4
now we should see all of them coming in
place looks pretty cool
still we can give it some width you know
0.45 let's try with that
and yeah looks pretty cool and after
that we after this size box what we can
do is
add a divider
so that you know separation is seen
it will be a line you know like a
grayish line
now this is done now let's work on the
functionality of selecting a file first
so what do we need to do so whenever we
get the centered icon of icons upload we
need to click on that then we'll get a
set of dialogues let me draw it out
so we'll get a set of dialogues like
this
and it will have three options you know
select from it will be select from
gallery
select from a
camera
and cancel option
so we want that to show up and whenever
cancel is click we need to pop up this
if gallery then we need to pick image
from gallery or from camera and then
after the image is selected we need to
show the screen over here let's work on
that so what i'm going to do is create a
function
which will be
select called select image
and basically what this function will do
is return a simple dialog box
and over there we can just have a set of
options that we discussed
so it will be select of image
now
over here we are going to take in a
build context
i'm going to call it context then it
will be asynchronous
and we need to return a show dialog box
this is how you can you know create the
show dialog box then the builder
and the builder will take in a context
then
over here we need to return a simple
dialog box
there are various type of dialog boxes
like you know alert dialog simple dialog
you can check it out
i'm going to add simple dialog then
we're going to have a text that says
create a post
then we need have children
and the children will consist of simple
dialogue option
and where we're going to add some
padding so we're going to add an edge
and says dot all 20 if we don't then all
of the options will get squeezed and it
won't look good
then we need to have a child of constant
text
which says
take a photo
then we'll have an on pressed function
which will be asynchronous
and uh whenever we take a photo what do
we want well first of all what we want
is when the dialog box shows up we need
to uh
dismiss that dialog box first
and then uh go to the gallery and then
uh to take up the camera so what we'll
do is
navigator
dot of context
dot pop you know just to remove the
widget from our screen the simple dialog
box
then
we will have a uint 8 list file that
will be coming up
uh when we
use the function that we created called
pic image
you can see it in our utils file the
pick image file that we had created we
accepted a source
then we
used the image picker dependency then we
picked the image from the source we
mentioned and we returned the file if
it's not null
that's what we're going to do and since
this is a take a photo option we're
going to mention the image source as
camera
now
what we're going to do is we need to
make these changes in our you know the
ui part as well so we need to call the
set state so for that we even need a
global variable so we can do uint8
list
and we're going to call it file this can
be nullable because in the start it is
going to be null
and we are going to set the state to
you know file equal to file
not doing that we should be able to see
the camera but this won't be visible you
know in the
ios simulator because there is no camera
in the is simulator i'll show the same
to you in the android version after all
of our options have been created
so let's work on the gallery function
which will work in the ios simulator we
can copy this
and paste it down
and over here we can type choose
from gallery
and we're going to mention the image
source as image source dot gallery
then we can just save this as well
now let's try to work over here so if we
go over here
we have we are getting the screen
because this is the screen we are trying
to
render we have commented this
now uh let's uncomment this
widget that we are returning
and let's add some conditions over here
so
when is our image not selected whenever
the uh file over here is null in the
start it is null right so what we can do
is
put a condition that if the file that we
have
is
equal equal to null
then we need to return this so that the
user can select the image or we need to
return the scaffold
now we can format this document and we
should see a centered widget
cool
now if we if i click over here i should
get the show dialog option box
so i need to
take the select image from here
and
put this in the icons upload place so we
can do
select a match and we need to pass in an
argument over here which accepts a build
context so we can pass in the context
now let's try to run our app and see if
it works
so i click over here and i get the
option of take a photo or choose from
gallery i'm going to choose from the
gallery and our gallery shows up now if
i click over here
i even get redirected to the other page
because my file has not been null now it
has some value
so now uh let's uh display whatever you
know the
image that we have and the user
uh profile
so first let's uh display the user
profile that should be fairly easy
because we have
we have a state management ready
so we can do that
we'll have a final
user
and we're going to have provider
and order of context it will have a type
and that type will be user
provider
and the user provider has a function as
a get method basically which is get user
we have seen all of this i'm not
repeating all of this stuff again
now what we can do is
instead of having this background image
over here we can remove this stuff from
here
and instead put user
dot
photo url
and we can format this document and
let's see if we're getting that
i'll go over here i'll select an image
choose from gallery
and over here we can see our profile
picture that we had selected coming over
here now let's try to display the image
that we had selected over here so
our image is in the form of you and 8
list
and it is in the global variable file
so we can go down
and we had seen earlier that
to display a uint8 list we don't use a
network image that is for the
uh you know the web stuff the url that
we have
and
to display a uintah list we use
something known as memory image we have
seen that
so we are going to pass in file
but we are going to pass in file
with an exclamation mark
because we don't want it to be null and
it will never be null
because we are adding the conditions
over here
in the top right
now if we try to upload an image we can
choose from gallery
and
we're going to select the waterfall we
can see the waterfall showing up
and we have all of this it works pretty
well now let's try to you know have this
description
that we can have the value of so we need
to have a text editing controller
so let's go at the top
create a text editing controller
which is named as
a description controller
which is going to be a text editing
controller
we can take this description controller
from here
and pass it in the text field
controller
cool we have that
now uh the next thing you want to do is
well
whenever we click over here
and choose from gallery oh we also have
to add a
simple dialog option of cancel first
let's do that and jump on to other stuff
so
we can go on the top we can copy this
from here
and paste it again
and this is going to have the option of
cancel
and we don't want any of this stuff
happening we just want don't want to see
the
simple dialog box option to show up
again
so we're going to remove the async as
well from the con over here now let's
try to run our app and see you're
getting the cancel option if i click
over here the simple dialog option gets
removed
now let's try to choose from gallery and
if i select this image
i'm seeing that over here now whenever
we click on the post button first of all
we should see a loading indicator linear
loading indicator over here
that shows up like this
and then we need to post it to our
firestore which is over here
in the post section over here which is
another collection that we can make
and uh it will get stored in the storage
we have had a look at both of them and
how we can do both of them let's revise
them if you want you can pause the video
right now and try to do it on your own
you can structure it uh
however you want
it's uh there's no need to follow the
same thing that i do but you should get
the output and the same
you know stuff happening over here so
what do we want to do whenever we click
on the post button we should be able to
you know save all of this stuff so we
can create a
function over here on press and we can
call it
post
image
we're going to create that function
so let's do it at the top
over here void
post
image
and it will require a set of arguments
that we need but even before that i just
realized that we've used the description
controller but we have not set a dispose
method to it let's do that
i can go down at the bottom and we'll
have a dispose over here
and our dispose is going to be
description controller dot dispose
now in the post image we will accept a
set of you know arguments one is uid
then a username
and a profile
image
we are accepting all of the arguments
from here because we have a provider
over here and uh it's in the build con
build for build method so we can just
pass a pass post image uh
over here and we can pass in the from
the function here as well
so now
what we can do is
put a try catch block
because you're going to make some
asynchronous calls here
and
it's going to be asynchronous
then uh we're going to create an upload
post function but we're not going to do
that over here as we have seen multiple
times that we have done for auth methods
and storage methods we're going to
create another file which will be called
firestore methods dot dot
and in the firestore methods we are
going to create a class like we did
before
firebase
not firebase fire
store methods
and we're going to create an instance of
the firebase firestore class
which will be this
we are going to have firebase
firestore dot instance
then we need to create a function called
upload post which will help us in
uploading the post so what we can do is
future of type string because we will
create a rest variable as we have done
before then we'll upload the post
and to upload a post what all stuff do
we need
well first we will have an asynchronous
function we will have a try catch block
aware all of this stuff you have done
multiple times and i think you should be
doing it by your own
then uh what do we need to do first
first we can create a res variable which
is
some error
occurred
then over here we first need to uh
upload our image to our firebase storage
and then we need to uh get the download
url of whatever we store in the storage
and store it in our firestore database
so let's try to do that so what we can
do is well we will receive a photo url
whenever we do
storage methods
dot
upload image to storage if you don't
remember what upload image to storage
was
it was this function where we are
basically
asking for the child name and we are
going to create a folder at that child
name and we are going to
upload our image basically and get the
download url of this image
cool
now
we can go there and we can have a child
name what is our child name going to be
posts this was profile pics now we want
posts
then our file is going to be a file
we're going to access this from the user
so what you can do is
string description
then a uint 8 list
file
and a string of uid and our
is post is going to be true
and we need to await this because it
will return a future string
cool now having that in place let's uh
create a post and as we did for you know
user like in the auth methods we created
a class of user we're going to do the
same for the post
so
we can go over here and create post dot
dart file
then
we can basically copy all of this and
paste it in the post dot dot file and it
will have a set of different
properties like description
you know the uid of the user
then the
username of the user
then the post id
each post will have their own unique
identifier
then the date
published
a post url
a profile
image
and we also need a likes property we are
not adding the comments property because
that is going to be a sub collection
cool now let's require all of this
so i've added all of these values i've
required all of them
uh all of these construct from the
constructor then i'm
uh
making the two json function and then
from snap function i've replaced all of
these values it should be fairly easy
for you to do so
then the next thing you want to do is
well create a post
so to do that we need to create a post
so let's do post
and we need to require the post well we
haven't renamed this
so i'll rename that
we'll call it post
we'll have to remove all of this
now let's try to use post we have our
model class ready
and do post and the post is going to be
post
and we are going to have a set of you
know again
uh
construct arguments so we can pass in
the description
so
let's
pass in the description we have from the
argument that we have here from the
parameter
then a uintatelist file so we can call
it
after description we need to add uid
we'll add uid
then username we have to get that from
the user so we'll do string username
then username
the next thing you want to add is
a post id
for the post id we won't be able to add
any uh you know the user id because uh
there will be uh
a two to three post by
uh the same user so that will get
overridden and we will see one type of
files for all the posts that a user
makes so we'll have to generate
different post ids which we'll have a
look at in a while
then we'll have a date published
then the date published will be the date
that is right now
so we can do it by datetime.now
then
we'll have
post url and the post url is going to be
the photo url that we're getting over
here
then we need to have a profile image and
a profile image we have to accept it
from the user so we can do that string
profile image
and we can pass in profile
image
now let's see what error we are getting
now it's written that the post
is written that the post url has to be a
list so we didn't edit it this well
so let me edit it out
so our profile url is going to be a
string and a profile image is going to
be a string
and we should not be getting this error
and the date published
is going to be
final date published
cool
now what we want to do is work on the
post id how can we get the post id
to get the post id we need unique
identifier every time firebase used to
take care of that but you know now we
need to do something else
so
we're going to do
we're going to make use of a package
called uuid
and this will help us generate a unique
identifiers how it will uh give us if
you read through the docs it will tell
you that it provides you with two
functions uh when we initialize it which
is something called v1
and a v4
v1 uh creates a unique identifier based
on the time so it will give us a unique
id every time so we need not worry about
having the same id
so what we can do is
create a post id we'll do string post id
and we can do
u
u id
and we'll call dot v one
and now with this post id we can pass in
this post id over here
and let's see what error we are getting
over here
we have not passed in likes and our
likes for now is going to be an empty
container cool now we can take this post
and upload it to firebase because over
here we have uploaded to our storage now
upload it to our
firebase so what you can do is firestore
dot collection
post
dot
doc and our document i will have post id
because well it will be a collection of
posts then like we had for user a
different
you know a different id uid of the user
it will have a post id for every user as
you can see
then uh we'll have dot set again and we
saw earlier that we need to pass in this
post and we can't pass in this post
directly we need to convert it into a
map so we can do dot to json
and we can
you know
format the document
after this is done we can turn res to
success
don't forget to do that
and we're going to have res equal to
error dot to string
and we can return res now you
this will work you can try it on your
own but before doing that what i want to
show you is
if you go to the upload image dot to
store upload image to storage function
you can see we are asking for a boolean
that is a post or not so why are we
asking that
so suppose uh
we have this we are creating a reference
and we are creating a child of let's say
you know
a profile pic suppose
so this works for the user when the user
is adding image so we can save it with
the file name of their uid because we
know that the user is going to have only
one profile pic but in the post section
we know that the user can have multiple
uh
files that have been stored because the
user can post multiple times so we don't
want this reference over here we want to
create another reference so what we can
do is
we will check over here if
is post so that means if we are
uploading image to storage and if you
are uploading a post to the storage what
we can do is create a unique id
that we did like before uuid
we can then have dot
v1
and we can then have the existing
reference
which is this one
to
ref dot
child and then an id
so what we're basically doing is
we will have a child of posts then we'll
have a child of uh then a folder of you
know uh the uid of the user and then
over here we if it is a post we can just
uh generate a unique id for the post and
then the name of the post is going to be
that unique id
i hope that's clear to you if not we'll
see that in action in some time like
whenever we store it and we will see the
folder structure that's happening and
then you can relate
so now over here let's try to avoid the
error that we're getting so what we can
do is string res
which is equal to away
and we need to call in the firestore
methods
and we can upload the post and the post
will have a description controller
dot text
we have to pass in a file so it is going
to be underscore file and it is not
going to be null so we have to add an
exclamation mark and rest everything is
the same name
and we can format this document
then uh the next thing you want to do is
if the rest is equal equal to success
we want to let user know that the image
has been posted
so we can just show a snack bar which is
provided over here that we are using
again in the utils uh
dot dot file
and the content is going to be
posted that's it and we can put a
semicolon
then
what we can do is put an else condition
and we can show a snack bar
and over here we are going to pass and
dress whatever error we are getting
over here as well we can just do
show snack bar
and the content is going to be a
error that we get dot to string
and we're going to format this document
whatever are we getting if we go down
you can see the post image we have to
pass in some constructors over here uh
some arguments over here so we can do
post image and we have to first pass in
user id so we can do user dot uid
then user dot username
and then user dot photo url
we can format this document
and we can restart our app
and let's see if our setup is working
correctly or not
so if we click over here on the files
we can select from gallery i'm going to
select this image
this is showing up pretty good now let's
say
hello
world
and we can click on post
we have to configure the loading bar
first of all we will do that after we
see that it has been posted and yeah it
has been posted so we can go in our
firebase storage we can reload this
to see if we are getting the correct
output and you can see in the post that
we are getting this uid over here this
is because we have made an error in our
application
we have done ref dot child id and we
have not saved ref to ref so we have to
do ref is equal to ref dot child id so
that when we put the data we have ref as
the child name
then the child the the user id and then
the
unique post identifier we forgot to do
that now let's try to run our app again
but before that i'm going to delete this
posts that we have from over here
and let's delete it and let's try to see
it in action again
so we can refresh our app and let's try
again
we're going to choose from gallery i'm
going to select this image
hello second
time
and let's post
it says posted now let's refresh and see
in the posts
we are getting the user id
and if we go in the user id we should
get a randomly generated
user you know a randomly generated post
id
and this is how we wanted it
and this is very different from profile
pics because over here we are just
having the user id as a
file
name but we don't want to do that over
here we want the user id to have post
differently so that one user can have
different posts
cool now if we go to the firestore
database we should see two posts uh
because one was the failed one and then
the other was a success one
and you can see hello second time
and the same goes for hello first time
hello fold
cool
now let's try to you know remove this
one because this one was the one causing
an error
now
let's try to add a linear indicator so
what we can do is go to the add post
screen
and we're going to create a global
variable called
boolean
is loading and we can set it to false
initially
let me
put it as a camel case
then we can take this is loading and we
can go so whenever the user clicks on
the post image let me select one image
to show you the demonstration
so whenever the user clicks over here we
need to show the progress indicator as
long as the process is happening so what
we can do
in the post image
before the try block we can put set
state and set is loading to true
and then we can grab the search state
from here
and if it's success before showing the
snag bar i want to show that the loading
has
i want the loading to stop
and over here as well we're going to set
it to false and i'm going to format the
document and now let's try to display
the linear indicator on the screen so
the reason we had used a column over
here
in the body was because we wanted to
show
uh
our linear indicator before
uh just below the app bar so we can do
that so if it is loading
we can just show a linear
progress indicator
and if it's not loading we basically
need to show nothing so we can add a
container over here
and we can format the document
and
let's try to see it in action so we can
choose from the gallery
now let's try
typing some other description for the
example
rivan
i'll just type this i don't know why
then we can post and you can see the
linear progress indicator showing
but it's overlapping somewhere so i'm
going to make some small changes
and also after this is posted we don't
want to show this screen so we need to
go to the backspace
so what we can do now is well
first of all remove this container from
here
we'll add some padding
which will be nothing padding but it
will have an effect so what you can do
is edge and sets dot only
from the top zero
and after that we can format this
document add a const over here
and after that we also need to show a
divider so we can add divider
we can format the document and the other
change we needed was whenever we click
the post
we should not see this uh screen the
reason we are seeing this screen is
because we have used the condition that
file is equal to null
so what we can do is set the file to
null
so what i'm going to do is create a
function over here which will say
void clear
image
and we're going to set the state of file
to
null
having that in place what i can do is
you know after the success
which is over here
we can call the
clear image
part
i'll do that after the snack bar has
been seen
cool and uh
yeah let's try to do that
let's refresh our app
and
let's select an image from gallery
yo
and we can post and you can see this is
showing a pretty good
and that's how we wanted it
and after it has posted our image is not
showing up because we have set the state
to of the file variable to null
and
the last thing we would like to do over
here is you know whenever we click over
here we should be able to see the back
screen again
what i can do over here is
wherever we are having this in the arrow
back what i can do is have a clear
image passed in
and now if i select an image
and if i click over here we are going
back to the screen that's pretty cool
so now let's try to display the post
that we have stored in our database over
here in the post section
on the feed to work on the feed screen
we need to create the feed screen layout
uh so we'll create a feed screen screen
in the screens folder
let's create that
i'll give this small
and
we'll import material dot first
like we have done previously
then we need to create a stateless
widget
we will call it feed screen for now
and we need to return a scaffold
we can take this
feed screen from here and put it in our
global variables home screen items list
we can replace
text feed with feed screen
cool
now we should be skiing nothing on the
screen and that is exactly what we see
now the first thing we want is an app
bar so let me draw the layout of the
feed screen that we are going to have so
first things we are going to have
is over here
we are going to have a
app bar
over here we are going to have our you
know
our logo and over here we are going to
have our chat icon
then we are going to have our posts
coming down and our posts layout is
going to be something like having a
circle avatar over here having the
username then the three dots over here
if
the user is you know if we are the user
then we should see the three dots so
that we can delete the post
then uh we should be able to see our
image
and then we should see a heart icon over
here
then a comment icon then a share icon
then uh
save icon sorry for my terrible drawing
but this is the basic layout of our app
and then we are going to have multiple
posts so now first things first let's
work on our app bar
so over here in our scaffold we can have
an app bar
and our app bar will have
a background color
of
mobile background color
we don't want to center the title
whatever title we'll have
and the title we're going to have is
well as i mentioned previously over here
we are going to have the
image and what is our image going to be
we have all added it already i see
underscore instagram.svg and since it's
an svg file we are going to use the svg
uh picture
uh the flutter svg package that we have
and we are going to call asset make sure
to import flutter
svg.dart
and the asset is going to be assets
slash ic underscore instagram dot svg
then we need to give it a color of white
and then we'll give it a height of 32.
cool now let me format the document
i'll put a comma here again so that it's
coming pretty good
now the next thing we need is over here
we need to add a icon button where we
can you know click over here and be
redirected to the messages screen
so we're going to create actions
and in the actions we're going to add an
icon button
and there is not going to be any
function that's happening
so we'll give it an empty function and
we're going to pass in icons dot
messenger
outline
you can use icon packages to get it
get the icon similar to the instagram
package but i don't think we're
doing that
so now let me remove this and see if
we've gotten what we wanted and it looks
exactly like what we wanted
so now
let's uh
work on the postcard uh post that we
want over here
so
we're going to get out of the app bar
widget and we're going to have a body
and for now let's work on the ui not on
the functionality of you know getting it
from the firestore database and
everything
for now we'll just work on the ui so
what i'm going to do is create a widget
over here which will be called
post underscore card dot dot
and
i'm going to be importing material dot
package from here
then then we are going to make it a
stateless widget and call it post card
then we are going to return a container
with a color of
mobile background color
first let's
put this as a body
then we are going to return this
it will be a constant
and then
let's see if we have
yeah
we should save this now
the next thing you want to do is add a
padding
so we'll add a padding or from both the
like the horizontal sides so that it
doesn't stick over here
so we'll do edge
inserts dot symmetric
and in the vertical direction from 10
so that it leaves spacing from here and
the next postcard that appears from here
then the container will have a child of
column because
we can see in our diagram
we want a widget
draw a widget over here then up
uh then our image then a row of widgets
over here as well
so in our column we'll have children and
in the children first of all we'll have
the header function
we can create another widget for that
but i'm going to do it in the same uh
postcard widget
then we want this to happen so the first
thing we want to do is make a container
for this let's do that container
and in the container we'll have padding
and
it will be edge inserts
dot symmetric
in the vertical direction from 4 and
horizontal direction
then
we need to copy this
padding that we have
because you want to add an extra padding
from the right so we do copy with
and we'll put write
then we'll have child of
row
as you can see we want a circle avatar
our username and then the three dots
so what we can do is put a children
then we can have circle avatar
and we'll have a radius of 16
a background image and the background
image is going to be a network image
and let's get the background image
basically
so
i'm going to go on unsplash.com and find
a random image
copy image address and
paste it over here
then
this is it for the circle avatar we
should see something popping up
all right now i'll remove this
then the next thing we want is
an expanded let me refresh our app
and let's see this we are getting our
circle avatar at the top over here
let's see if it's comparable to our you
know
the layout we wanted
beside it we want a username so we can
create a username
we'll again ignore the warnings that
we're getting because it will be a
dynamic value
then the next thing we need is an
expanded widget because i wanted to take
all the space remaining space
and
over here we are going to cover we will
have padding
and the padding will be
const
edge and sets dot only and only from the
left side do i want a padding of 8
because i don't want to stick it with
the profile image
so i'm going to give a padding of 8
then i'm going to have a child which
will be column
and i'm going to have a main access size
of main access size dot minimum
and a cross axis alignment which starts
from the from the start
then we have children and in the
children we are going to have a text
and the text should say
our username so i'll just type username
for you for now
and
we want some styling which is basically
i just want my username to be bolded
so i can type
font
weight
as font weight dot
bold
and for another document now
we are facing missing a parent thesis
and format the document having that
let's see and
we are getting our username typed out
over here pretty cool
that's how we wanted it now the next
thing we want to do is work on the icon
button so we can get out of the expanded
widget
and create an icon button over here
we are not focusing on the
functionalities once again
so we are just going to have this
and
we have an icon of
icons dot more underscore vertical
and we're going to put a const over here
format the document
and now let's see we are getting that
actually what we're going to do now is
when we click over here we should get a
dialogue simple dialog box of you know
uh
deleting the post but will not work on
the delete functionality now
we'll just work on you know clicking
over here and getting the dialog box to
show over here
let's do that
so
to do that
in our on pressed what we're going to do
is show dialog
and it will be a context and the builder
is going to have
receive a context
then it is going to return a dialog
and the dialog will have a child of
list
view
let me get out of here so that i can
just use the autocomplete
and the list to you will have a padding
of
edge in sets dot symmetric and we are
going to have it from vertical 16
then we want the shrink wrap to be true
we want our children to have just delete
you can add more functionalities like
report you know all that sorts of stuff
we're just going to have delete for now
and then we're going to map all of these
uh
children like whatever list is there
we're going to map them we're going to
receive e and we're going to wrap them
with an ink well
and the ink will have a child container
and it will have a padding of const
edge
inserts dot
symmetric
from vertical 12
horizontal 16.
and it will have a child of text
e
and since this is an ink well we need to
add an ontap feature over here which
will be empty for now and at the end of
the inkwell what we want to do is first
format the document
and at the end of the
inkwell over here we are going to have
dot 2 list
so basically what we did over here is
gave it a children pro list of children
then we had a delete over here we mapped
through all the children for now it was
just delete and then uh we returned an
inquil widget with a container and
padding so that we can click on it and
whenever there is on tap we will do
something about it
so
yeah this is pretty much it now let's
see if it works
if i go over here and click over here
you can see the delete option coming up
pretty cool
now
the next thing i want to do is you know
show the
uh
the next thing i want to do is show the
image over here so i can get out of this
row
i'll name this image section
and on the top i can name it
header section
and where we're going to have a sized
box
of
height
let's say media query dot of context dot
size dot height into zero point
0.35
not 0.035
then a width of maximum available width
then
we'll have a child and here we'll pass
an image dot network and the image dot
network
will have
some image which we'll grab from here
let's grab one
image
let's grab this one
we'll copy the image address and paste
it over here
then uh in the image.network itself we
are going to have fit
in
there and the fit is going to be
box fit
dot cover
after this is done let's see why we're
getting this error so we need to take
this size box from here and put it after
the container not inside the container
that was my mistake and we need to
format this document now we should see
our image showing up
pretty cool
now
we need to show the you know
the heart emoji the heart button the
comments button and all of that stuff
so
we can go down over here
and
we
can just say like comment
section
and where we are going to have a row
as we know because we have to be
you have to put all of this in a
horizontal direction then we are going
to have an icon button
which is not going to have
an on press
and
it will have const icon of icons dot
favorite
so
it is either going to be icons favorite
which will be color
colors dot red
you know when it's light and when it's
not liked it is going to have a border
of only white and this will be favorite
border but for now let's just keep it
this way
then we'll have another icon button we
can just copy this and paste it down
and our icon is going to be comment
underscore outlined
and the color
we don't want anything so that it's the
default comment icon that we get
and we'll have another icon button
which we can paste
and this is going to be icons dot
send
so that we get the share button
now let's see what we're getting and
yeah this is exactly what we wanted
now the next thing we want is at the end
we want to have a bookmark icon
so that people can save it
and with your knowledge you'll be able
to complete that task i'm not going to
complete that task
so we'll have an expanded icon
and we'll have child
which will be aligned
and the alignment will be at the bottom
right corner so we can do
alignment
bottom alignment
dot bottom right
then we're going to have a child and our
child is going to be an icon button
it will have an icon which will be const
i can
icons
dot bookmark
underscore border
and it will also have an on press
function
which will return nothing
and we can format this document and
let's see if you're getting that and yep
this is exactly what we wanted
so the ui of our this is done this part
is done the next thing we want to add is
a bit of description over here and then
the number of comments that we have
received
let's work on that so over here after
this
row where we can type
description
and
number of comments
and we'll have a container we'll have
some padding
all the usual stuff
don't get scared about you know the
padding stuff it's just trial and error
you'll have to try some values if this
doesn't fit you'll have to change it by
some pixels and then try it again
it's it's not that big of stuff
then we
after this padding has been done we want
a column
and it will have a main axis size of
main access size dot minimum
across access alignment of cross access
alignment dot start
we'll have children over here and the
first child over here is going to be
a text
and the text will say suppose
1231 likes
and it will have a style of
theme
dot of context
dot
text theme
dot body text two
so this is the usual uh you know theme
that we have in the you know the dark
over here in the main dot dart file if
we go
you can see it in the theme data dot dot
all of this
so we're just copying that text theme
that is provided to us by the dark
function
and you can see we are getting the
number of likes
we also need to add a bit of you know
font weight so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to wrap this with a
widget called
default
sorry default
text style
and the default text style will have a
style of
theme
dot of context
dot text theme
dot subtitle
to
dot copy with
and we are going to add some font weight
let's say we'll add a font weight of 800
and we can format this document and go
over here we'll see it is a bit bolded
now the next thing we want to add is a
bit of spacing and then we need to add
you know the
username of the user and then a bit of
description
so what we can do is
after this default text
time we can have a container
and the container with b of the width
double dot infinity
will have a padding of
const edge inserts dot
only
top
it
it will have a child of
rich text rich text basically allows us
to have multiple texts in it
expands if i have to be more precise and
then we can arrange them in a
row wise order
so that we don't have to create a row
and then do some configurations this is
like a one in uh
this is like a row widget for
text there are multiple moon features
that rich text provides us like having a
text style for each and every text you
can see it over here
basically we can set
the text to
text pan
and the text pane
will have a style of
const text style
color and the color is going to be white
then we'll have children and in that
children we're going to have more text
bands
so the first expand is going to show the
username so we can write text plan
and the text will be
user name
and the style will be
text
style
of font weight
dot bold
now what we can do is put a const in the
text style
after this expand what we can do is copy
this text ban and put it up again
and the
description is going to be let's say
hey this is some description
to be replaced
then we can remove this textile
and format the document
let's see we are getting this which is a
pretty cool output that and is similar
to what we wanted
we can even leave some space over here
so that there is some spacing pretty
cool
so
after this container over here we want
to show the number of comments
so
we are going to add a container
which says
child
which has a child you know which says
text
view
all
let's say 200 comments
and we'll have a style of
text style
we'll have font size of 16
and a secondary color
then we'll have a bit of padding as well
so we can do it at the top
padding
edge inserts dot symmetric
and from vertical
so that we leave a bit of space from the
description
and down
so we can format this document and let's
see our output view all 200 comments
looks pretty good
now i can
format this
and i'm going to replace i'm going to
wrap this with an inkwell widget
so that i get the ontap feature and if i
click on it i'll be redirected to the
comment
i'll save this
all right now the last thing we want to
show is the date over here
so what i can show is after this inkwell
we can probably just you know copy this
container from here
and paste it down
then our date is going to be let's say
20 21
and
we are going to have a padding of yeah
this is what our padding will be let's
try to run our app and see how it looks
looks like
the way we wanted it
yep now uh we'll try to uh get the
values from firestore
cool now we have the ui of our post and
the feed so the next thing we want to do
is get the data from our firebase
firestore and display all of these posts
on our
feed over here so to display uh the
user post from the firebase firestore on
our uh screen is what we have not looked
at before we have looked at you know
calling the get method on the document
so we have a collection and we have a
document and over there we've got the
get function but over here we don't have
a specific uh
you know uh you are a document on which
we have to call we have to call it on
all the documents that are present in
the posts collection
so
we are going to do that and also we want
all of them in real time as we saw
before get on the
get on collection on the document was a
one-time read we don't want that over
here whenever we click over here on the
hard button the like counter should
increase in the database and should
reflect over here whenever we comment it
should reflect over here and
this is what we want and all of this
whenever a new post gets posted it
should show up directly on the screen
and we don't need to refresh so that's
what we are going to work on everything
is going to be real time so let's work
on it
so in the body we are going to replace
this post card right now with something
called a stream builder because
to real uh to listen to the real time uh
stuff we need to use streams so uh we'll
pass in a stream over here and what is
our stream going to be well
we're going to call in the firebase
firestore
and its instance
dot collection and which collection do
we want users collection a post
collection sorry
so we'll get posts
and over here we can't get
we won't do get because it will return
to other future and this is not a future
builder this is a stream builder and we
want to do a real time listening so what
we can call is snapshots
you can call snapshots on a document id
as well if you want but uh we want to do
it for all the post ids that are present
over here we want to display all of them
so we're going to use snapshot
and
we'll get a builder
now the builder will get two functions a
context and a snapshot and make sure to
explicitly mention the type of the
snapshot which will be
a sync snapshot
which will be of the type query snapshot
and this query snapshot will be of the
type map and this map will be string
comma dynamic and if you don't want to
write so much of code for the snapshot
type what you can do is follow a cheap
trick which i'll show you in a while
using which you won't get any error
so if we do if snapshot
dot connection state is equal to
connection state
dot waiting
this is similar to you know uh our
main.dart file we use stream builder
over here and we check the connection
state and everything similar to that we
are going to do so if our connection
state is waiting what we are going to
return is a center
centered circular progress indicator
so we can do child
circular progress indicator
and after this we can return a list view
builder
because we want a list of posts
so we can do list view builder and in
the item
builder we can have
a context
and an index
and over here we'll
get a container
and in the container
we'll have a child of
post card put a semicolon and actually
we can even remove the container there's
no need of the container as of now
and we can remove this semicolon
and this is not going to be a constant
as of now because we're going to pass in
some arguments to the postcard so that
we can display stuff over here
cool
now
we have to mention the item counter
where and our item count is going to be
the snapshot that we have where
snapshot
dot data whatever data
this snapshot has because it's not going
to be null
and uh we're going to have dot docs
dot length it can be null so it can be
considered the item count as length as
zero but over here what we're doing is
snapshot.data
so we're getting the data and uh we're
calling the docs method on which which
which will give us a list of the
document ids that we have where
basically the all of these
and then we can call the link function
on this list and it will get the length
of the postcards so now if we run this
we should get three postcards with the
static data
and that is exactly what we get
because we have three documents over
here now let's try to render the data
that is present in the postcard over
here so to do that first we need to pass
in an argument to postcard that these
are the data of our
posts
so we can do snapshot
dot data
dot docs as i mentioned it covers all of
these uh three dogs that we have and
we're going to
grab one dock from here at a time
because
we are calling list view builder on it
it will uh run three times the and the
first time the index will be zero then
one then two so we'll call the docs and
we'll grab the first uh document from
here so that will be index
and then we'll call dot data on it
now if we go in the postcard we can
accept a value of snap over here
and we always want the snap so we can do
it
as
required
this dot snap
we can format this document now we've
got the power of snapshot over here so
we just need to display the snapshot
so how can we do that
well
first of all we want to display a
network image
our so this network image is basically
our profile picture
not our profile picture whatever the
whoever user posted this so his profile
picture so what we can do is
snap
at and we want to grab the
profile image so we can do prof image
prof image and if we save it we should
see the profile image showing up all of
these you all of the three users are the
same users so we are not getting any
difference over here
but
it will get the profile image over here
basically
then we need to show the username so we
can do snap
and we can pass in username if that's
what the field over here is yep
we can see this and we should get our
username as well
you can see all of them rivan ranavat
now i want to show a different image so
what i can do over here
go down
i'll replace this image.network with
snap
and it will be post url
we can format the document and let's see
the different images that we have
and this is a confirmation that
we are getting three different different
images but it's posted by the same user
as well
now
let's
get the likes thing
so
if we go down
the like should be replaced with
snap
likes
but as you notice over here the likes
over here is an array
so we need to do snap dot lie snap at
likes dot link
and
we'll do string interpolation over here
dollar
and we'll pass in like somewhere so that
we see 0 likes right now pretty cool
after that we again need to display our
username so we can do snap
username
then snap
and we'll we'll pass in
description
so that will be
description aware
and lastly we'll have comments over here
which we'll uh fetch
using future builder
because our
comment over here is going to be
you know uh
in a sub collection so it won't keep
track of
the sub collection it only keeps track
of the current collection and its
documents not the sub collection for the
sub collection you can either again use
stream builder or you can uh
do use future builder and we're going to
use futures for this
so we can just keep this stationary and
for the date published this one is the
key over here so if you want if you want
to get the
date we can't do snap date
published because
if we go where the date published is not
a string it's of a type time stamp
so uh we can't do that so instead what
we're going to do is use a package named
as
will go on pub.dev you can grab the
intel package it will be mentioned in
the description below
you can grab this package
you can add it to your dependency
you have to stop all the
app processes that are running in the
background so over here we are going to
use date format
dot
y
mmd
basically your month month and date
and then we are going to format this
with snap date published but over here
format takes in a date time so what
we're going to do is pass this and
convert it
to
date
and we're going to
format the document we're going to save
it now let's rerun our app and wait for
it to show up so our app is loaded up
and let's see the
thing that is coming and we can see that
the date is coming up properly december
22 2021 you can read the intel uh
documentation to know more about it like
if you want to show in some other format
there are lots of varieties from which
you can
check and will format your apple uh from
at your date and you can even see that
we are seeing the description but the
username and the description are you
know attached together i want to do some
spacing so what i can do is
over here in the snap description i'll
do snap
string interpolation
i'm going to
cover this and i'm going to leave one
space
so with this i'm able to leave some
space after the username so the next
thing we need to do is whenever we
double tap this image or we click over
here we should see some animation
and then the data should get uh updated
in our firebase firestore let's do that
so for the like animation we need to
create another widget and we'll call it
like animation
let's create that
and over here we are going to import
material dart
and we are going to create a stateful
widget and we'll call it like animation
now to create this animation we are
going to
use something known as uh twin
animations
let's do that so to access you know the
between animations and some controllers
we
will have to inherit from
a single take
provider state mix in
so
yeah
then we need to create an animation
controller
animation
controller now we have to call in in its
state and in the init state
we'll have to
set controller to
animation controller
and the vsync will be this
and we'll start a duration
and the duration will be in milliseconds
and the duration we can give is
what we can accept from the
constructor over here so we're going to
have multiple uh constructor arguments
the first one will be
a child
what we need to you know display
what li what should the like animation
like what should be the child of this
like animation parent widget
then we'll have
a boolean which is is it animating or
not
then a duration
which will be how long the duration of
our
this should be like animation should be
then a final void callback
which can be null
which will be on end and then
a boolean value which will be small like
we know the purpose of all of this while
we are doing this
now
let's require all of this seven so i've
required all of these fields you can
check that this your duration has a
duration or if no duration is mentioned
it can be of
duration of 150 milliseconds and then if
the small like is not mentioned it will
be false that is it's the original value
then
over here we can we have created an init
state and
the milliseconds can be
widget
dot duration
dot in milliseconds and then we're going
to use this syntax over here which
basically uh divides it
divides some
duration in milliseconds by two and then
converts it into end
then the next thing we want to do is
we need to create a scale so let's
create a scale late animation
double
scale
and the scale will be scale which is
equal to
between
double
and the animation should begin from
and end at 1.2
and we need to animate this and to
animate this we need to pass in the
controller using which we need to
animate so we can pass in the controller
enemy
now the next thing we want is did update
widget over here
so this uh which it will be called
whenever
our current widget is replaced by
another widget and so if we if the
current widget is replaced by another
widget what we want to do is
we want to check if the widget dot is
animating is not equal
to the old widget that we get from the
parameter layer
is
animating what we need to do is
start
animation
now this will be a function which we are
going to create now
so the start animation will be an
asynchronous process
and
we'll check if the widget that we have
is animating
or
if the widget
is small like
so
if the widget is still animating what we
need to do is
take the controller forward
then we need to reverse the controller
then we need to add some delay
so that
the
heart animation i can you know stays
there for a bit of while
then we can do
const duration
of milliseconds
and then we need to check if the widget
dot on end is not equal to null
then we just need to end the widget so
we'll call the call voidcallback
function that we have received from the
argument
and
we'll call the exclamation mark since it
can be null
and we also need to dispose our method
from here
like the controller from here so we can
dispose it
controller dot dispose now
in our widget build function we need to
return something known as scale
transition and this scale transition
requires a scale which will pass in a
scale which we created
and a child which will be widget dot
child
now a like animation widget is completed
so uh basically this duration tells us
that how long the like animation should
continue the child is basically to have
the
to make like animation the parent widget
then we have a
on end which will be called to end the
you know the like animation
then a small like to check if this like
button was clicked or not because there
will be a bit of you know a bit
different animation
for it
so small like is for this so that if
this is clicked we can still animate
and uh
yeah this is all of the
parameters that we have and this is the
way we have animated them
so we can go in the postcard
and over here we can check our favorite
so where in the i can button we can wrap
our icon button with
a widget
which will be
like animation our custom widget
and we'll pass in is animating over here
now how do we know that the like
animation is animating or not
so to do that we need to basically check
if
so we need to basically check if the
snap
we have
and the likes over there basically the
array of snap likes
contains the user id or not so we can
check that if it contains
the user id to get the user id what we
can use is provider so we can call this
final
user
let's import the user
user is equal to provider
dot of context
and it will be of the type user provider
dot get user
and then with that user we can go down
where our like animation was
and we'll check if it contains user dot
uid
then we'll make sure that the small like
over here is
true because this is a small like button
and we won't see any difference over
here because well
uh the use snap likes uh won't update
because we haven't set the update method
over here but we'll do that and after
that we'll see the animation as well
but uh we can go on the picture so
whenever we double click we should see a
heart icon coming up
we can do that so we have to move to our
network image so we have our uh sized
box over here so we are going to wrap
the size box with a stack so we have
wrapped the size walk with the stack
this is because we need to show a
heart icon on the top of the image
whenever the user double clicks
so yeah we have done this
now uh
we'll have a size work and after that
we're going to use
like animation widget that we have
and it will receive a child of const
icon
icons dot favorite and we need to show
up icon of color colors dot white
and
the size of this is going to be a big so
let's just say it will be
now we can format the document and where
we have to pass in the is animating
value and is animating value will be
something known as we'll have to create
is like animating value and we also have
to pass in the duration the duration
will be const duration
and i want to show it for some time
more so it can be 400 second
milliseconds then we also provide the on
end callback
and in the on end callback we'll
basically have to set the state of is
like animating boolean value that we'll
have to false so let's create is like
animating uh
over there
so let's go on the top
and create a value
first of all we'll have to convert this
postcard to a stateful widget
and we'll have to use
boolean
is like animating
and we'll have to set it to false
and then we'll have to take this value
go to the bottom of the screen basically
wherever we add the stack
and over here
end we'll have to set the state
and we'll change is like animating to
true
and also we'll have to cover this stack
with the gesture detector
because we need to detect if the user
double clicked on this image or not so
we'll have to cover this with a stack
itself
so we'll do on tab
and on
tab
not on tap actually it will be on
double tap
and this is a difference between inkwell
and gesture detector
gesture detector provides us with a
ton of various uh you know uh functions
uh and inkwell provides us with basic
features and on double tap what we can
do is
set the state of is like animating to
true
now let's save our app and run it now
let's see how it looks
now you can see this is showing up and
it is in the send it's not in the center
so
i'll change the alignment of the stack
to
alignment
dot
center
now let's run our app and you can see
that it's showing up in the center
i
want to
maybe increase the size of this you can
increase it by
going over here and increasing the size
to let's say 120
and yeah looks good
now
we'll have to cover this like animation
with something known as
opacity
and this is because we don't want the
like button to show up all the time we
only needed to show
when r is like animating boolean is true
so we can just do this and actually
the opacity it doesn't provide us with
any animation i want the animations to
show up
when you know it's fading and when it's
showing up so i can cover this
with animated opacity a widget provided
by flutter and we'll pass in a duration
of
const duration
milliseconds will be 200
and opacity will be
based on the is like animating so if the
it is animating we need to completely
show it
right and if it's not then we don't have
to show it so we can turn it to zero the
opacity has to be a built-in a value of
one and zero
now we can run our app
and see if it's working or not
so if we do that you can see this
showing up but it doesn't fade away
because in our on end function we have
set it to true we have to set it to
false and now let's try it try to see so
if i do this
it shows up and disappears it shows up
and it disappears and this is the like
animation we wanted to see the animation
over here we'll have to configure uh and
update our values in the firebase file
store because this value is linked over
there so to do that we'll go to our
firestore methods class over here and
we'll create a function named as like
post we're going to have a return type
of void over here because we're not
suspecting any you know error that can
happen and if that happens we don't want
to show it to the user
we won't show any output only so that's
what i'm going to do if you want to show
the error to the user if some error
occurs you can uh you know display it in
the rest of the variable that we created
with res and that format
but where i'm just going to do this
so basically i'm taking in from the
parameters post id uid of the user and
the
likes
list
and we're going to create an async
function
we are taking list of likes from a
parameter only because we don't want to
make another call to our database to
read the number of likes when we get the
number of likes in our
feed screen itself using the
stream builder
so what we can do over here is have a
try catch block
and whenever any exception comes in what
we're going to do is print the exception
in string format
and in the tribe block what we're going
to do is
whenever we like the post
if i suppose like the post i want to
make sure that if the list of likes
already contains my uid that is
uh the list over here will contain uids
of the user so i want to check if the
likes over here
contains the uid then we need to dislike
the post right suppose this post is
already liked i'll click over here so i
want to dislike the post so to dislike
it i have to remove from the likes ira
miuid and if the likes contains does not
contain my uid then i need to make sure
that i add my uid in the array so what
can we do
we can
first check if the likes
contains
uid
that means uh we have already liked the
post in the past so what we're going to
do is take the firestore
collection
posts
and we'll go to the post id document
so suppose this is our post so we'll
take the posts then go to our post id
and then we are going to uh
call update aware not set not you know
add or anything for any other function
that we saw
update because you need to change only
one value if you do set over here then
you need to pass in all the values and
well uh this will be a lot harder
and uh we just have to do update aware
so that we can update only one uh
data over here which is the likes array
so in the likes array
what do we need to update so well we
just need to add our uid over here so if
there is an already existing like over
here we need to add our uid as well
so to do that what we're going to do is
take field value
dot add a union
array remove sorry and then we're going
to add our uid
so with this basically we've told uh
firebase to uh go to the likes field and
then we need to take in all the uh take
in all the array members
and remove only the current uid of our
user which is this uid that we are
receiving from the parameter so we need
to remove our uid from here
and else what we can do is
take this file store again and where
we'll call array union
and as you might have expected
if the likes does not contain our uid
then we need to uh take in the all the
already existing array members and add
our uid in it
cool
after that is done
we can
first of all await all of this function
and save
then in our feed screen uh in our
post card actually in our postcard file
uh we'll have to go to our uh two like
options first we'll go to the double tap
animation heart icon one and over here
uh
in our own double tap what we're going
to do is
set firestore methods
dot like post
and in the like post let's see it's a
future void so we can avoid this
and call async over here
and we can do like post and in the like
post what we need to add is post id we
can get that using
now we have to do widget dot snap
because it has become a stateful widget
and we'll have to do widget dot snap
and the name will be
post id
then the next thing we want is uid so we
can do
user dot uid
and the last thing we need is likes to
get the likes we can again do widget dot
snap
likes
and now if i save and try to do it again
we should see that on double tap we
should get our likes in the post id
so suppose i do this
so as you can see we are getting some
error over here we are getting some
requested document not found and over
here the error we have made is we have
spelt misspelled posts
so do that and after that we should
again rerun our app and let's see it in
action
so i'm over here on the first post
i'll
do this and you can see the like counter
incremented because we are done post at
likes
and you can see that our likes uh id now
consists of our uid
and now if i again do this
it turns 0 that means it removed the uid
from the ira and you can see this
updated as well
so now uh we also need to do that for
other type so if we click over here we
should be able to like the post so what
we can do is just copy this from here
and in the like animation over here what
you can do is
convert this to an arrow function
actually we want this function because
it's an async process
so we can do async
and then put our like post over here
then we'll format the document and let's
try to run our app
so if i click over here
you can see a little bit of animation
that i have previously mentioned and
we're getting one like now this is all
always showing red we need to change
that what we can do is over here in the
favorite icon itself we need to make
card we need to do conditional rendering
so we need to check
if the widget dot snap dot likes
contains user id basically this line
that we wrote if the snap contains the
user id what we need to show is
well
the heart icon basically
this means that the user has liked the
post so we need to show a filled
favorite icon and
if it's not then what we need to show is
a const
icon
icons dot
favorite border
and we'll put a comma wire let's format
a document and see if it's showing up
you can see this happening
i'll reload my app and we have already
liked the post so it's showing up a
heart now if i remove this post it will
be zero likes and if i again restart my
app we shouldn't see our
heart over here
now i can like it again
i can remove the light you can see the
slight animation that's taking place
this is because of the like animation uh
widget that we created over here
and now if we go over here
we can see this showing up all of this
is possible with streams that we used in
our app the snapshot and everything
now let's work on the comment screen so
to create the comments uh first we'll
have to display it on a new screen and
in the bottom we'll and after we do that
we have we will decide
how our layout of the comment screen
should look like so let's create our
comment screen and where we're going to
import the material
package
and
we will have to create a state full
widget
comments
screen then we'll have to return a
scaffold
because it's a new page that we're
drawing
then we need an app bar
and the app bar will say
basically it will have a background
color that is mobile background color
and then the title will be const text
comments
and we'll have to turn center title to
false so that it comes in the left align
position
and after doing that let's
try to see our app so in the feed screen
whenever the in the post card screen
sorry whenever the user clicks on the
comment outlined uh icon what we need to
do is transition the user to another
page so we can use navigator can do
navigator
dot of context dot push
and we'll have material
page route
we'll have context
and then we're going to pass in the
comments
screen
you're not making it a constant because
after some time we'll have to pass in
you know
a list of uh some pop some parameter
so
let it be this way
then if we click over here we can see
the comments that are happening now
let's decide how our app is going to
look basically there will be a lots of
comments so we'll have a comment over
here a comment over here
and in the bottom we're going to have a
text field
and this text field will be for
commenting so we can write c over here
and then uh in the comment section what
we want to do is show the profile
picture of the user
then we want the usernames username of
the user then whatever text the user
wrote
and over here we're also going to have a
like button but you're not going to
implement the features of the like
button i'll leave it up to you and you
have enough knowledge to create the like
feature on the comment screen
cool and over here we are going to have
some more features like comment as
and the username of the user then the
profile picture of the user so small
functionalities but yeah we're going to
make use of our state management and
output all of them
so this is how the app is going to look
like first let's work on the text input
field
in our comment screen class we will have
a bottom bar navigation bar
and in the bottom navigation bar it
accepts a widget so we can safely type
in any widget we want and i want to have
a safe area widget which will be
apparent
and in that we want a child
of container
which has a height of
k tool bar height
this is basically you know the toolbar
height of the app bar
and then we'll have margin
and the margin will be
agencies dot only
from the bottom we leave
dot of context
dot view inserts this is something new
that you're seeing dot bottom
and the padding will be
from the left and right
agent says dot only
from the left
16 and from the right
eight
after that this will have a row and the
row will have
lots of children we have a row over here
because we want to show the text input
field and beside that a comment or post
button over here
that's why
and also a circle avatar as you can see
over here so in our row we first need to
have a circle avatar
you know first we'll have to pass in
children and the children will have
circle avatar
and there is going to be a background
image and we can use network image
again we can go to our friend
unsplash.com can grab the first image
address
and paste it over here
then we'll have a radius then we'll have
a property of
radius and the radius i want to be 18.
now we can format the document save it
and we should be able to see some output
over here
and you can see we are seeing a profile
picture
this profile picture is going to be our
profile picture by the way
cool now the next thing you need to do
is have a text input field over here
so what we can do is create a text field
and we'll add a controller first
and for now let's not pass in the
controller
so we want to have a decoration and the
decoration will be input decoration then
the
hint text can be
comment as
username whatever username we get like
whatever our username is
and we'll have a border of input border
dot none
let's save it and we are getting some
errors over here this is because the
text field and the size issues that we
have
so what we can do is wrap this and
expand it so that it takes the maximum
possible space available
and we can save it
now if we run our app we should be able
to see the comment screen and we can see
it over here but i want to leave some
padding over here because it's kind of
looking gross
so
we can wrap text field with the padding
and the padding has to be
only
and from the left it will be
and from the right it will be eight
having that in place we'll save
and you can see it's looking much better
the last thing we want to add is
an ink well widget over here
which will be used to click on over here
and then we can post it so we'll have
inkwell and it will receive an ontap
function which will be
not empty for now
and we'll have a child which will be a
container
we'll again add some padding
from the vertical we'll have eight and
from the horizontal we'll have eight
then we need to have a child of constant
text which just says
post
and the style can be
text style
of color
colors dot blue accent
and we can format the document
and if we see we are getting the post
over here
pretty cool
and if we change it to
blue color that we have from the colors
or dot file let's see how it looks
i don't see much major difference
yeah we can just keep this blue color
over here
now the ui of the username part is done
we can go to the top and build a comment
card basically
so every comment will have a comment
card just like the post so we had a post
cards over here
we want to do the same for the comments
so we can go over here and create create
comment cards so
in our body
what we can do
is show a comment
card
so
in our widgets we'll create comment
underscore card dot dot
where we'll again import the material
package
then we'll have
a state
full widget of comment
card and obviously we'll have to get a
snapshot from the user but will not take
that now we are just building the ui of
our app
then the container will return a padding
of const
edge inserts
dot symmetric and from the vertical
we'll have
18 padding and horizontal
then we'll have a child of row by row
because we need to show the
username the user profile
the username the text that the user has
entered and the like uh
feature that we have
so
in nro we'll again have a circle avatar
again we need to pass in children
then circle avatar
background image
and the background image can be
network image
we can copy another image from here
let's say
this run
and after that we'll have a radius of 18
we can form at the document
and after this circle avatar the next
thing you want to show is you know
first of all let's import this comment
card
so that we see some of the stuff showing
up so yeah
this circle avatar shows up
and the next thing you want to do is
show the text of username and the
description and the text that the user
enters as a comment so what you can do
is create a padding
padding will be
from the left only
16.
in our child we'll have a column
and the column will be
cross axis alignment cross access
alignment dot start which means it will
start from the start
then the main access alignment will be
main access alignment dot center
then it will have a bunch of children
and in the children we need to have
something known as rich text that we
have looked at earlier
and the text will be a text span
and the text fan can have children
and in the children it will be text
then the text band will have a text of
let's say
username over here which will be bolded
and after that we can again copy this
text span from here
paste it over here and we can write
some description
to insert
what we need to do is remove this
bracket from here
and go up here we don't want any styling
for our description
now let's try to see it and you can see
it's showing up in the center
very cool after this rich text
we need to show padding
after this rich text we actually need to
show
you know the date of the user so after
this we need to have a padding again
which will show and this padding will be
for the date so we can do edge and sets
dot only
top
four
then it will have a child and the child
will be text and it will show the
current date so what is our date let's
say
23 12 21
and
we'll have a style of
text style
and it will be pretty small so we'll
just set 12 and a font weight will be a
font weight dot w 400
not very bolded and not very
uh you know not very thin as well
so we can
save this
and let's see we are getting 23 12. cool
the last thing we need to add is outside
this column and outside of this padding
in our row we need to add a container
and you might have guessed it why we
need this container for the like button
so you can do const
edge and search dot all eight
and it will have a child of icon
icons dot favorite
and the size will be 16
we can set it to const over here
for the document now let's see if you're
getting that
icon where
but as you can see it's looking pretty
shabby over here
it's all coming together which i don't
like so what i'm going to do is wrap
this padding with an expanded widget so
that it takes all the available space
and we can save it and see
all of this comes into place so the next
thing you want to do now is you know
display and you know store all the data
that we comment in our firestore
database it will be fairly easy to do so
i'll just give you one hint what we need
to do so in our posts over here we have
a post id and over here all the data but
we don't want a comment as one of the
fields aware we want comment as a sub
collection so that you know we can have
a look at what sub collections are and
how can we get some data from there
so yeah you have to do that pause the
video and try it on your own if you fail
you can always see it and learn from it
so the first thing we need to do is
change all of this the user profile
image the username so over here what we
can do is again use our provider i'm
going to copy paste it
i'm going to import this user
provider
then the user class
and then the provider package
you can just press command and full stop
to get all of this no you know
correction suggestions
and with this user we can
go over here replace the network image
with
user dot photo url
and over here comment as this will
become
user dot
username
and we can save it now let's see we are
getting our username rawandanath and our
profile picture which is pretty cool so
now the next thing we want to work is
whenever we click on the post icon we
should save our data in the database
so let's do that in our firestore
methods we will create a function which
will be
future
string
of post comment
and it will generally take in a post id
so that you know we can go to the post
id and in that collection we can create
one collection
and it will have a text that will
require whatever we type in over here
the uid of the user to store it
the name of the user and the profile of
the user
the reason you're storing the user id
over your
along with you know profile pic and
username is because
uh when i'm not adding this
functionality but for you all if you
click on this
username over here you can wrap the
username text with an inquil widget and
when you click over here it will show
you the profile screen that we'll create
in some while
and yeah this is why we are storing the
uid and name and profile pic so here
we'll have a try catch block
so you can do try
catch in case of any exception we can
just print it e dot
to string
we can format this
document then uh the
then we need to check that if the text
is not empty whatever the user has
entered is not empty then what we can do
so if the text is not
empty what we can do is
first of all
get the firestore dot collection and our
collection is going to be posts
collection
and then we'll go to the document of
post id
and over here make sure to add another
collection because we need a sub
collection in that so we'll add
collection
of comments
and we are going to pass in another
document id so we have our comments
collection over here
then we'll add a post a comment id that
will generate using uuid package
and it will have you know the comment
will have some other things like profile
pic name of the user uid of the user
the text that we have all of those stuff
so we can just do that
so in the comments dot collection and
we'll create a comment id so what we can
do over here is string
comment id and we'll do constant uuid
dot version one
and we can take this
and
pass it in the dock comment id
and dot set it and after this uh we need
to pass in the profile pic and
everything for this we are not going to
model our data because comment isn't
necessary right now because we won't be
using comments anywhere like post and
user
but if you want you can surely make a
model that will be a better choice i'm
not going to do that
and we can have profile pic as profile
pic
then the name of the user as the name of
the user
then
uuid
and then we'll have lastly we'll have
date published and the date published
will be date
time dot
now
and
yeah this is pretty much it we'll await
this because this will be an
asynchronous function
and this is pretty much it
if
the text is not empty
then
we don't want to do anything
so
we can just type for us that you know
text is empty
or you can follow the rest format that
we have and where our post comment will
be future void
you can always follow the rest format
i'm not going to do that
and we can see this
post com we'll grab the post comment
from here go to our comment screen
and beside the on tap we're going to
have this
and this will be an async
because we need to await it
so we can do firestore methods
dot
post comment
and the post id will be
well we'll have the snap that we get so
it will be final snap
and we will require this so required
this dot snap
basically the snap will be the snapshot
we will be using stream builder again
and you're familiar with stream builder
so we'll get the snap again similar to
the post screen that we did and we can
get the snap and over here we have
widget
dot snap and we'll have a post id
then a widget dot snap
text give the uid will do user
dot uid
then the name will be user dot
username and lastly the profile pic will
be user dot photo url
we can format the document first of all
let's
and over here we are going to await this
post comment the future we have
and then we can save it
last thing over here is
in the comment screen we can't directly
you know show this to give the snap
required what we'll have to do is
pass in the post id
and the post id will be widget dot snap
until we post id
dot to string
let's see why we are getting this error
we have to pass in the snap argument so
we can do snap this
yeah
and we can format the document let's
save and re-run our app
so if we click on the comment screen we
should see this and now i'm going to
comment over here we can see that we
have no sub collections on any of this
so
i can type over our
first
comment
and we can hit on post and where we can
see that we are getting an error type
string is not a type sub type of type of
index where the error we had is we are
passing
widget dot snap post id we want to send
the widget dot snap
only and not the post id
and again if we go over here we should
post something like hello
world
and we can post
we are again getting this error and over
here we are getting this error because
we made a very silly mistake uh first of
all we need to add a controller over
here so what we can do is
final
text editing controller
and we'll call it
let's say
comment
controller
which will be equal to text editing
then we need to set the state
so we can have oh sorry we'll have to
call the dispose method over here and in
the dispose method we are going to
dispose of the comment controller right
now itself
and after this uh we have to take this
controller go to the error part that
we're getting
and we'll have to do comment controller
dot text and we also need to add a
controller to our text field
comment controller
so we were getting this error because we
were calling widget dot snap text which
didn't even exist because the post
doesn't have a field called text
it only has a post id which we are
passing in and the comment controller
dot text that we have now
pretty stupid error that we had
we forgot to do that
so now if i go over your
commentat hello
world
and we're not getting any error that
means we should get a sub collection
somewhere we'll have to refresh our
database
and if we go we get a sub collection
comments over here and if you go in the
comments we see another id of the
comment and we it has a comment id that
is similar to this date published name
profile pic text and uid that means we
can store our comments successfully in
our database now let's try to output the
comments on our screen to show the
screens what we can do is use a make use
of the stream builder again so that we
can listen to it real time
and
what we can do is in the comment screen
instead of
having the body as comment card we can
have stream builder
and in this stream
uh we'll have to
pass in this sub collection of
comments so what we can do is
go to the firebase firestore
dot instance dot collection of posts
then the
post id and we can get the post id by
snap dot snap add no sorry
widget dot snap
and we'll pass in the post id
and after that we can have again another
collection of comments where we are
going to listen
then
snapshots
and if we format the document we should
be able to see
this error going away the next thing you
want is builder
and our builder is going to have a
context
and a snapshot and as i mentioned
previously you will have to
tie um
you'll have to explicitly tell the type
of the snapshot but we have a cheap
trick that we can follow you want to
check first like if snapshot dot
connection state is equal to the
connection state
dot waiting that means we need to show a
circular progress indicator
so we can do return constant
center
with a child
circular
progress indicator we are going to
return that
then after that we need to return
a list of comments so we'll use return
list view dot builder
and we'll have item builder again we'll
have context and index over here
then we'll be able to return
after uh this list is done we need to
return comment card
and the comment card has to give in
something
which we'll fill in in some while
so
yeah and we also need to pass in the
item count now this is where the problem
comes in if we don't explicitly mention
the type of the snapshot so if we do
snapshot
dot data
and we mark it as non-nullable then we
can't call doc's property over here you
see
we want to do this
snapshot.data.docs but docs is not
provided to us because this doesn't know
that we'll have uh
you know uh us async snapshot which will
be a query snapshot and then a map
inside of it you know it doesn't know
this so we can either again type
uh the async snapshot query snapshot map
string dynamic that we did earlier or we
can just
bracket this out
and say as dynamic
so this means that the snapshot.data can
be dynamic so we can call docs over here
but the only downside of using this is
we won't get the autocomplete so if
you're wrong over here you won't even
get to know
so this is a cheap trick if you want to
follow you can go with this or you need
to explicitly mention the async snapshot
thing over here
cool i'll keep this for now and now
let's try to you know see this
so if i go you can see the username over
here and everything which shows up only
one comment because we have only one
comment then we can type another comment
hey second comment
and we can post over here and you can
see our second comment showing up but
the text is a bit different because we
need to pass in some text
also over here uh we need to make some
spacing and after this is done we need
to remove the comment uh text from here
so
in our post what we can do is
after this post comment is done we can
set the state of text
editing no sorry we had comment
controller comment controller dot text
dot
which is equal to this we'll set it to
empty and if we try to send in another
one let's say
we'll have to refresh our app because
the state of this app changed and you
can see they're showing up
now if we type
hey
third
and post it over here you can see this
comment disappearing after this has been
posted and all of this is real time
showing up because we have used stream
builder
now let's go to the comment card and
edit some of this function now let's see
what error we're getting
and this was the keyboard error that
we've gotten that's not much of a big
deal you'll not get this on a real
device ios simulator sometimes causes
these issues
then uh the next thing you want to do is
in the comment card that we pass over
here we also need to pass in the
snapshot
of this uh
stream builder so what we can do is
snap short dot
data
dot docs dot length and again we'll have
to do
snapshot dot data as dynamic that's why
i would recommend following the other
method of async snapshot because every
time you'll have to do this
and even no autocomplete that's a
frustrating thing and now in the comment
card
what we can do is have a final snap over
here then we need to require this
snap so we can do required this dot snap
at no cost this can be null
and the network image can be let's say
remove all of this and we can have snap
dot
sorry widget dot snap
and the
we'll have to pass in widget dot snap
dot data actually over here uh we don't
have to pass in
snapshot.docs.linked actually we have to
pass in
the
snapshot.docs at that index so
in our comments uh suppose we have this
post and comment over here so what we
need to do is snapshot.data
so we'll get that and the docs
these three documents and we have to
grab them by their indexes so zero one
two so we'll get the first zero one then
the second then the third and over here
we'll also call dot data
so that you know
uh we don't have to do that again and
again over there
so we can remove
widget.snap.data from here and instead
just write widget dot snap and then we
can pass in
profile
pic i think that's what we named this
profile pic correct
now i'll copy this and we just have to
change this part from here but let's see
if we are getting the
change description
changed and our username has changed
which is pretty good
now we can go to the username have a
username as
username and remove the single inverted
comma from the side
save this
and
you're not seeing any username
so what you can do is refresh and go to
where
and we are not seeing any username
because we saved it as name over here
let's fix that
and we can see right run it
now i want to
do string interpolation over here again
because we need to leave some space from
here so what we can do is leave some
space
and we can do
widget
as copied
widget dot snap and we'll pass in the
text over here
hey hello world hello hey second comment
hey third and the final thing we need to
do is
this date formatting so what we can do
is date format which is from the intel
package
dot
and we have to follow ymmd
format
and we need to pass in the date over
here so what we can do is widget dot
snap
and we have named it date published over
here
and
we know that this accepts a date so we
can do dot to date
and pass anywhere
after this dot ymd we also need to call
the format
and we also need to pass in this as a
function
so we are calling date format.ymmd and
we need to format in this document
widget dot snap
date published
and we're converting the date publish to
date because it is a time stamp that
we're receiving from the firebase file
store
we can also put const over here so that
we don't get the error anymore
and we should see december 23 showing up
which is pretty good
and this is all that we need to make
change of and if you want you can have a
heart icon over here which basically
helps you to like
and i think you have enough knowledge to
go ahead and do this because basically
this is another comment class that we
have you can create a like list over
here so you can have a likes
list over here
addy basically and then it will be empty
for the first one and whenever the user
likes we can use rf
value uh field value dot array union or
array remove similar to what we did for
this like option over here and you can
even add the you know the animation part
you just have to cover it with the like
animation widget and pass in the
duration and everything
i think you'll be able to do it so now
if i type again over here let's say
hello
how are y'all
and post it over here
we should see hello how are you all
showing up over here
the only problem now i have over here is
this is coming up in a random format
so what i want to do is not have this in
a
random format but have this in the
sorted manner like the according to the
date published so what we can do is in
the comment screen
in the snapshot what we can do is after
this collection we can make use of dot
order by
and with this we can sort the comments
that we have by some particular field
which in our case will be date published
and uh by default it's descending to
false and we need to make sure
that the descending is
true
yes let's try descending to true
and you can see hello how are you all
hey third a second so whatever the
newest comments are that will be on the
top
and if you want to do the opposite or
you can do descending
false
and if we do that you can see the
old ones coming up at the top and the
new ones coming at the bottom but we
don't want to do that so i'll keep this
and
you can see the newest comments
coming at the top
so this is the order by property which
uh
firebase provides us you can even use
some other field like you know profile
pack uh sorry the likes that we created
right now and if you want to add that
but we are not going to add that so uh
you can add based on the likes and you
can descending it with the number of
likes one user has
and according to the text according to
the uid if you want like anything
basically but you would anyways prefer
date published because that's how most
of the apps are
so we have our working comment screen as
well the last thing we want to do for
the post is
uh over your view all 200 comments we
need to make sure that we have zero
comments over here or three comments
right now over here so what you can do
to
do this is go to the post screen post
card actually
and over here we are going to call the
init state from where we are going to
get the data of our app
so in init state and we are going to
have a future over here which will get
us the comments so we can type get
comments
we can create this function
void
get comments
it will be an asynchronous function so
it will basically be a future and it
will get us the comment length so we can
type end comment length equal to zero
and the comment length will be this so
what we want to do is get the data so we
can do
the get function we can use so what we
are going to do is await this and call
firebase firestore dot instance dot
collection
in our posts
then we can go to the dock and we can
pass in the post id which we will get
from the snap that we have
gotten from the constructor
we can do post id
and after that we are again going to go
in the collection of comments
and then
get from there
and if you do hover over here you can
see query snapshot we have seen document
snapshot this query snapshot is similar
to document snapshot only that the
document snapshot is received when we
call a get on this dot doc
and query snapshot is received after we
get the uh after we put get after the
collection
so you can give it a type of query
snapshot and snap
and await this so the difference between
query snapshot will be that we will get
a list of comments if we do get so what
we can do is
comment length which will be equal to
snap dot docs as we saw it will get us
the list of all the documents and then
we can do dot length
and we can say this
and after that we can even
wrap this and try catch so that you know
if we get an error we can see it in our
log or we can display it to the user
so we'll have our catch
and in this
cache we will have show snack bar and
the content will be whatever error we
get e dot to string
and we'll pass in a context
then after that we are going to set the
state of our app
so that we can see the comment link and
we're going to format this document and
c after this
we can take the comment link that we
have and
go down to the bottom where we say view
all 200 comments and instead of that we
can say
view all comment length comments
and if we say that we should be able to
see view all four comments and we have
four comments
pretty cool right now this since this is
a future if we type a comment over here
like hi
and post it
will not see any update only after we go
over here and come back
we will see that this has changed to be
all one comments so that's why i would
recommend you to
start using stream instead but i wanted
to show you query collection over here
basically the query snapshot and that's
why i've used a few uh the
future over here as i would have gone
with the stream
option now having that the last thing is
we have to delete this post now let's
see how we can delete a document from
our app so the next thing we need to
work on is whenever we click over this
delete function delete uh dialog
we need to delete this post
so to do that we'll go to the firestore
methods we have
and where we can create a comment of
deleting the post
and it will have a type of future void
and we can delete the post
it will accept one string of post id and
it will be as asynchronous process
and again we have to wrap it with a try
catch block
i think you are familiar with the drill
now so you can just follow this same
thing
again and again again
you can just follow the rest format if
you want you can refer to my github
repository below it has the rest format
if you're not very familiar with it
still
but try to do it on your own you'll
learn it
and after this the next thing you want
to do is take the fire store
you have to go to the collection
which will be the post collection
then we need to document it
we go to the document of post id
and then we call the delete function on
it
this is how easy it gets to delete a
document from a collection and if you
call delete on this collection over here
you won't be able to delete the
collection to in order to delete the
collection you need to
delete all the documents that it has
if you delete all the documents and the
collection is empty it will
automatically get removed from our
database and now if we await this
we should see
that
we have our delete post happening
so we can take this delete post from
here go to our postcard
and over here find delete
and in the on tab what we can do is
mark this as an asynchronous process
and call
firestore
methods
dot
delete post and the post id we have to
pass in which will be widget
dot snap
and it will be post id
and after this ontap is done
and we click over here it will delete
the post for us but we also want to
remove this dialog box that shows up
after that so we can do navigator
dot of context dot pop
so after this is done let's try to
delete one post of us so let's go over
here
delete
and you can see one of our posts got
deleted if i want to delete this post
let's try to delete that and you can see
only one post is remaining and we can
click away or see the like animation
which is pretty cool
right our delete post has been working
so the next thing we need to work on is
the search screen over here let's do
that so the next thing we need to work
on is the search screen so whenever we
go on the search screen we should see
two things
first is a list of uh you know uh an app
bar where we can get a form field and
here we can search for a user
and uh if the user types something and
presses enter we need to show the list
of users that are there
right
we need to do that
else if nothing is typed we need to show
a search bar
and a list view that looks something
like this we have a big image over here
then we have a small image over here a
small image over here
then a small image over here something
like this so
first
let's not complicate ourselves and work
on the search screen so to do that uh
we'll go to our uh
our app over here and create a
screen called search underscore screen
dot dot
after that we are going to import the
material package
and we are going to create a stateful
widget called search screen
then we can take the search screen from
here and go to our global variables
where we had saved this and
we're going to replace
this with search screen
now having that we are going to have a
scaffold as well
and we can save this to see an empty
screen then if we go on the search
screen we see nothing that is exactly
what we wanted now at the top we need an
app bar so we can do app bar
and the app bar will have a background
color of mobile background color
then in the title we are going to have
a text form field
and the text form field will have
decoration of
input decoration where we will just have
to give a hint to the user
so
actually instead of hint let's give a
label
and the label
text will say
search
for a
user we'll have to put it in a string
after that we'll
have to pass in a controller we'll
create a controller now itself we'll
call it final text editing controller
search controller which is equal to text
editing controller
now having that we can dispose of this
as well
so
we can take this and put search
controller dot dispose
then the next thing you want to do is
whenever the field is submitted because
you're not going to give an option of
you know
a post or you know search or anything
like that
uh we are just going to uh
check if the field is submitted or not
so on field submitted we'll get a string
value which we don't care about
and uh
what we're going to do is basically
let's just print this value to see what
we're getting
if it's a value or not but since we have
our controller over here which we
haven't put in let's put that
uh both of these values are going to be
the same thing at the end
so yeah
now we can just print this and if we go
over here
and search for a user with name rivan
you can see i'm getting ribbon over here
and if i print
let's say search controller dot
text and if i come over here
i should see riven on both the ends
i would
if i search for one and press enter
i should get driven twice
show the users so in the body
we are going to have
a
future builder because well we need to
get the data
so over here in the users you are going
to get all the data of the users so we
are going to call future builder because
well it's future
and then uh you can use firebase
firestore
dot instance dot collection
and what do we need a collection of
users
dot get
now if we do this much we'll get uh so
whenever we type something we will get
the collection of the users and uh we'll
get all the data of the users
right but that's not what we want we
want uh information related the user
that we're searching for so uh
firebase provides us with an extra
you know a method which is called where
and with this where we can pass in a
field that we want to check for example
username you can even check for you know
a bio email uid or if you had a display
name you can add that as well so over
here i'm going to check for the username
so wherever username is
you can have multiple methods over here
is equal to which will return to us you
know
a username is greater than it will check
the ascii value of the username that it
passes through every time and we'll
check if the
if the any name is greater than the
username that we'll provide over here
and
basically it will check ascii values for
each and every uh function
so what we want is called is greater
than or equal to if we put is equal to
it will exactly check for the username
that we give it but we don't want that
we want it to be either
equal to or you know less or
somewhere equal to that name
so we're going to put this name and
what does it have to be equal to our
search controller dot text
and we format the document so with this
we are getting the username which is
similar to this text over here
cool now if we have a builder over here
we can have context
and a snapshot
and
we can again check if the snapshot has
any data or not
if the snapshot has no data it will
return a constant
center
child
circular progress indicator
and if there is data what we need to
show is a list view builder so we can
return a list
view builder
and this list view builder will have
item count and the item count is going
to have snapshot dot data
and as we have discussed before we need
to pass in the value for the snapshot
but i haven't done that so i'm just
going to type this as dynamic
and then we are going to call
dot docs dot link
and in the item builder we are going to
have a context
and an index
and we are going to return
our list style
now this list style will basically this
list style will uh how will it look it
will have a circle avatar then the
username and that's it that's all we
want so we can create that stuff with
the list style pretty easy right
so
we will have a leading element as
a circle avatar
and the circle avatar will have a
background image of network image and
the network image will be
this
snapshot
we have to remove this two string from
here it will have snapshot dot data
dot docs
and we'll grab that docs by index
so what we're doing is we got a selected
user so in the firebase console if you
go you click over here you can filter it
by this and you can have a preview of
what's happening so we have uh filtered
by a field name username then we are
adding a condition where it's greater
than or equal to and let's say
we are going to type rr and now if we
apply you can see
there are two rrr user names over here
and we can grab them now it will go over
the indexes so this is the zeroth
element then the second elem of first
element it will grab this
then it will uh get the data of this
element over here and then we need to
access
the photo url
property on it
cool now
after this we need to have
a title element and the title will be
having text
which will be snapshot.data as dynamic
dot docs
at index
username
and if we format this document put a
semicolon over here so we need to do
some conditional rendering so we'll
create a
boolean value of
do we need to show user or not so we are
going to call it is show users
and if the issue user the show users is
going to be true only when the field is
submitted so we can do set state is show
users is equal to true
and where we can conditionally render if
show users is true then we need to show
this else we can show a text that says
posts which we'll work on in some time
all right now that we run our app we
should see the search screen so we're
getting the posts written over here that
is a good thing because our is
our
show users is false currently and only
when we submit the form should we see
the thing happening so if i type rrr
over here i should see my user and its
image there were two rrr users i had to
delete one because uh one was the
one rrr user was the one where we hadn't
put the profile image we were just
checking if our user is generated and
stored in the firebase or not
so i had to delete that one this is
showing a pretty good so the next thing
you want to do is when there is no user
searching happening uh we need to show
the posts
and we'll do that so now to display it
over here what we need to do is first
think of the layout we need to create so
what layout i have in mind is we need to
have one post like this over here
then another post that shows up like
this
another post that shows up like this and
all of these posts will be uh from the
database like the post collection of our
firestore database then again we'll have
a small picture over here then a small
picture over here then a big picture
over here something like this
so let's try to create that this kind of
layout to make this kind of layout we're
going to use a flutter package called
flutter staggered grid view it's a
pretty uh great
dependency in my opinion you should
check it out i'll mention the link of
this in the description below
and now since we have added a new
package we'll have to stop our app
processes and when do we need to show
this when posts is showing so basically
we'll have to replace our text over here
with
this
so first of all we'll have a future
builder because we need to get data of
the
because we need to get the post
collection from here so we'll create a
future builder over here and in the
future builder we'll have a context
and a
snapshot
and then we'll over here check if
snapshot dot has data all the stuff that
we did before basically and only our
future will change over here
our future will become firebase
firestore
dot instance dot collection
of posts
dot
get
there are no
sub collections in this we just want the
collections uh stuff over here we just
want to output the images over here
that's why we are doing dot get on the
collection
now if snapshot dot
has data actually if the snapshot
doesn't have any data what do we need to
show
we just need to show
a
constant
circular
progress indicator
or you can even put if snapshot dot
connection state is equal to connection
state dot waiting even that works then
after this is done we also need to wrap
it with a center widget because we need
to show it in the center
and we can put it over here and it will
be a constant widget
let's format the document
remove that so if snapshot has data what
do we need to show we need to show
something known as
staggered
grid view dot builder
and it's not builder it's we are going
to use staggered view dot
count builder it has a lot of uh
methods like this you can check it out
but we are going to use the staggered
grid view dot count builder and it will
take in a across access count first
which will be three
then it will have an item
count
which we'll pass in as
snapshot
dot data as dynamic
dot dot docs dot length
and after this is done we'll have a grid
we'll have to remove this and we'll have
an item builder and our item builder is
basically going to return an image
so we can have
context over here index
and it is going to return image dot
network
and the image dot network is going to
have snapshot
dot data
as dynamic
and it will have dot docs at index
and we'll get the property of post url i
hope this line is clear to you we have
used this multiple times so i think you
should be clear with it
then we will have staggered tile builder
which will give us an index and with
this index we are going to return a
widget called staggered
tile
dot count
and over here the cross axis cell count
is going to be
if the index
is completely divisible by seven
then
we will show
uh two is to one count
else what we are going to show and in
the main access count we are going to do
the same thing
right and now we're going to return this
and we can format the document
so basically if the index that we have
over here like the image index that
we'll receive is completely divisible by
7 we want a count of 2 or else we want a
count of 1 and same for the main access
alignment as well so like the main
access count
now if we save this
and
run our app we should be seeing that
so as you can see our app is loaded and
if we go to the search we are seeing one
post over here because we have only one
post right now but it's showing up like
this exactly the way we wanted we can
add another post let's choose from
gallery and add another post over here
and we can write hey
all the other posts
were deleted
and we can post
and now if you go to the search bar
we should see another post that pops up
and it pops up over here but you know
this doesn't like
look as cool as it should because
there's no spacing all of these elements
both of these elements are stuck
together so we'll
create some spacing so in the main axis
spacing we're going to add a spacing of
8 and we'll do the same for
cross axis spacing and we'll put 8 as
well now let's try to see our app and we
see this is showing up very cool and you
can see that there is a bit of you know
spacing over here which looks much
cooler now the next thing we need to do
is whenever we search for a user suppose
i search for a user with rrr and go
where we need this to be clickable and
show the user profile where we can you
know follow the user see the users
following see the description and
everything so let's do that so to do
that the first thing we need to do is
create a new screen called
profile screen
and this is going to be a reusable
profile screen so that we can show this
over here in our profile
tab as well and whenever we click on
drivan
suppose i search for a user by the way
i've cleared my database because you
know i wanted to make it
some sort of clean
so i've just added these
and whenever we click over here so
whenever we click over here
we need to show the profile screen that
shows up and it will be the same thing
for the search users and the profile
screen over here so let's do that
the first thing we will need is
importing the material dot
and after that we'll need a stateful
widget because this is a profile
screen because we need to have an init
state function and everything we'll see
that
and the first thing we need to do is
create the ui of our profile screen so
let's create a scaffold
and what i'm going to do is take this
profile screen go in our global
variables
and replace this with
screen
so that we can see
our output over here
and now if we save this we should see an
empty screen
cool now
how is our uh profile screen going to
look like so over here the first thing
we would need is an app bar
and in the app bar we'll have our
username over here
then we'll need a
profile picture over here
and then we will need number of follower
a number of posts number of followers
number of following and their subtitles
then we will need our description or bio
over here then we'll over here we'll
need a button that will say follow
unfollow or edit profile since it's
going to be reusable we'll configure to
work all the three ways and then we need
to show the posts of the user whatever
user has posted we need to show those
posts over here
right so now let's work on it so we have
a scaffold in the start
and the next thing we need is an app bar
so we can have an app bar
and our app bar is going to be of the
color background color
mobile background color
and the title is going to be of text
and we'll have to pass in some username
for now let's keep it username
and
we won't add any other styling we'll
set the center title to false
then we need to we need to add a body
but before adding a body let's see how
our app bar is looking now
i if i come over here so that you know
we can see it and rerun our app
and over here we can see our username
showing up pretty cool
now we need to have our body
and the body we are going to wrap it
with a list view because it's going to
be multiple things that are coming up
so
it will accept the children
and the first thing we need to work on
is having a profile picture over here
and beside that we want the stats that
show up like the followers following and
everything
so let's create that
so we'll first of all have
a column
because we need
so why do we need a column over here is
basically below this profile picture we
are going to have
a description and beside this profile
picture we are going to have our you
know followers following and stats
basically
so we need a column
and
what i'm going to do is wrap this with
the padding because i feel we need some
padding
we can add padding and padding can be
const
edge inserts dot
all
then we can go to our column and we'll
have children now in the children we'll
have a row
as we discussed we need the profile
picture and the stats like this
so we'll have a circle avatar first of
all we'll have to pass in children and
the first thing we need is a circle
avatar
and
it will have a background color of
colors dot gray so whenever the you know
the picture is loading we'll see a gray
color
and we need a background image
and we'll again go to our good friend
unsplash
grab one photo from here
and
paste it over here
actually we need to pass in a
network
image
and in the network image we need to pass
in this url
we will format this document
cool now we have that and if we save
this we should see our profile screen
showing up now this image is very small
so i can increase the radius of this
image which will be 40.
now if we save and go back you can see
this image is quite big now
cool
now
after this circle avatar we need to
build a stats uh
star kind of thing so uh we are going to
have the number of like the number of
posts in digits then the posts aware
number of followers then the followers
number of following and then the
following text written below it
so to do that we are going to have
another row
and in that row
we are going to have
a main axis
size of main axis size dot
minimum
[Music]
then we are going to have a main access
alignment of main access alignment dot
space evenly
because we need them to space out
properly
and then we'll have children
and with the children we're going to
have the post and you know this column
that we have over here basically this
kind of column so since you're going to
have three columns like this i'm going
to build a separate widget for it so to
do that i'm going to create a function
and i'll call it
over here we are going to create that
over here
and we're going to call it column which
is the return type of this widget
build stat
column
and it will take in a
hint of number
and a string of label
and then it will return
a column
and the column will have main access
size of main access size dot minimum
main access alignment of main access
alignment dot center
we'll have children in it and the
children will be text
which will be the first thing so this
part over here
so it has to be a number so it will be
text number
dot to string
then a style and the style is going to
be
a text style of font size
font weight
of font weight dot
bold
and we're going to mark it as a constant
after that we can save this
then uh we'll have a
another text so we're going to copy this
and paste it over here
we're going to make some changes first
of all the text is going to be label
then the text style
will have a font size of 15 and this is
not going to be bold this is going to
have a weight of 400
and the color is going to be
colors dot gray
now having that let's see
it in output
so we can go over here and in the
children we can have
we can have build start column
and we'll pass in
first thing as posts
no the second thing has to be post
the first thing will be a number for now
let's just type in 20
and we can
pass in multiple things
so
our next is going to be followers
and a followers are let's say 150
and
our following is
10.
and we save this
and let's try to see the output on our
screen
so if we do go over here
we can see this is showing up and this
is not the best output we could have
gotten so let's try to improve it
so
the first thing i want to do is i want
this to take the maximum possible width
over here
so i can just wrap this row
with a widget known as
expanded we have to use this and we'll
pro provide it with the property of flex
one
now let's see the improvement and you
can see this is spaced out pretty well
now the next thing we want is where are
we going to leave some spacing between
the posts that we have
and this over here so what we can do is
wrap this text with a container
we're going to get a margin and the
margin is going to be edge in sets
dot only and from the top we're going to
leave four
if we save this
we should get a different output and you
can see we have left some space
now we can change the font size over
here to let's say
18 and we'll save it
can again go back and you can see it's
looking much decent and i'm going to
continue with that this looks pretty
good
you can change it according to your
preferences again having that in place
we will scroll up again and so after
this row what we're going to do is
create the buttons that we need over
here this buttons the follow edit
profile and unfollow buttons so we'll
create another row
and we'll call them
main access alignment
and we'll call it main access alignment
dot space evenly
then we need children in that so we get
we are getting this error because we
have put in the row inside the expanded
we need to put this outside of the
expanded
cool
now in the children what we're going to
do is create a widget called as follow
button
and this follow button will require you
know text and background color and the
text color if all sorts of stuff
so let's create that widget over here in
our widgets folder we'll call it
follow
underscore button dot dot so that you
know we don't have to reuse our code
again so that we can reuse our code
again and again and we don't have to
make changes
uh again and again basically so now we
can import material dot
and we are going to have a stateless
widget which will be a follow button
and i can change the constructor over
here again now we're going to require
multiple things and we'll require them
as and when we need them so first of all
we need a container and we'll have some
padding and we'll have it from the top
so we can just do only top 28 so that
will leave some spacing from here this
part over here
then
we need to have a child and a child is
going to be a text button
and the text button will have an on
pressed so we require a function of ir
so we can call
final
function which can be null
and we're going to call it function we
require that
then we can do on
function
actually just function
then we have to make this final
then it requires a child and a child is
going to be a container
and the container has properties like
box decoration
and in the box decoration we are going
to add the background color and what is
the the background color of the follow
button is going to keep on changing so
when the background color
so if it's a follow button we need to
show a blue background and if it's a
unfollow button we have to make the
background white
so that kind of stuff so we are going to
import a background color as well
so
let's get the color final color
background
color
then we need to pass in a border
and the border will also keep on
changing as per our colors so we will
need that from the constructor as well
so we can just call this
final
color
border
after this we need to put a border
radius and a border radius is going to
remain constant so it will be border
radius
dot circular
and after that we need our button to be
aligned in the center so we'll do
alignment dot center
and it will have a child finally and the
child is going to be a text
and we required this text so we're going
to do final string
text
so you're going to have this text
and we're going to have a style and our
style is going to be of the type text
style
color
text color it will be because you know
if our background changes our text color
will also change
so
we need to import the text color as well
after that is done
we need to have a font weight and the
font weight over here is going to be
bold
after that we can format this document
and we need to give it a fixed width and
a fixed height so what we can do is you
know after this container we'll specify
a width of let's say 250
and a height of 2
27 you can use media query over here but
what i want to do is when my screen
which gets bigger and bigger i want this
follow button to remain of the same size
you can change according to your
preference again
then we need to require all of this i'll
require so we have taken in from the
constructor make sure to uh put this dot
function are not required because our
function can be a nullable value
now we can go on the top and create and
import the follow button
and with the follow button let's add
some stuff
now let's add an edit profile button
then our background color is going to be
mobile background color we want the
background to be
you know black and the
border to have something of a gray color
so
since our background color is
black we wanted this to be a primary
color which is white
and over here we want a border color to
be colors.gray
then we need to pass in a function and
for now let's let our function be you
know uh an empty screen an empty
function
and we're not going to have an edit
profile over here we're going to have a
sign out which will change later so
now if we see our output we are getting
this output the reason over here is
because we've forgotten to add you know
a parent widget of column after the row
and so we are
overlapping the text over here with our
prof edit profile button so if we do
that and if we wrap this with a column
and put this row inside of the column we
will see that our error disappears
and our edit profile comes below all of
this so let me save my file and you can
see this over here that we have got this
and the next thing you want to do is
take make the main access size max
and yeah we have got a good looking
output so now if we see our app and we
can see that this is working pretty well
now we need to remove this gap and
probably this is because in the follow
button we give a lot of margin we can
make
28 to 2 and let's see the output
and we are getting a decent output
that's what we require now the next
thing we want to do is display a
username over here and the description
that we are the user provided so what we
can do is close this follow button
and and after this uh row we need to
pass in you know a container
which will be
aligned to the left so alignment
dot
center left
then a padding of
const edge insets dot only and from the
top we leave a gap of 15
and we'll have a child of text which
says username
and we need to add some styling to this
so we'll add a style
and what is our style going to be well
we want the font to be bolded because
it's the username and we're going to
have the
we are going to ignore the warnings for
now because
all of these values are going to change
to dynamic
and
having that let's see the output we get
over here we're getting the username as
we want now we can take this container
and
post it down and we're going to
change the padding to from the top we
just need a padding of one
and we're going to add some bios so some
description and we can see this
and we can remove the style over here
because we don't want the description to
be bolded now if you go you can see some
description showing up which is pretty
cool now we need some divider over here
and then we need to display a list of
posts
so what we can do is after this
container and after this padding as well
we are going to add a divider so after
this is done we need to display the user
posts and that is what we are going to
work with so this was basically the ui
of our app
and now let's uh replace all of these
values with the dynamic value so to get
in the dynamic values what we need to do
is first of all accept the
uid from the
profile screen since this is going to be
a reusable widget we need to make sure
that we require this uid from the
constructor and not use the state
management uid else it will only serve
this screen over here but not the
screen when we search for the user
correct
now let's go over here so the first
thing we need to do is create a new
state function where we can get a when
where we can put a get
basically a get request to our firebase
firestore to get the data of the user
that we have over here so what you can
do is type your get data
and
for now let's just keep our get data in
our
class over here we are going to call it
an asynchronous function
then we are going to wrap it with a try
catch block
and we are going to
show a snag bar in case of any error
so we can just type
e dot
tostring
and after that in the get data what we
can do is we can get the user data from
the users i've deleted all my users as
well only kept three of them over here
and in the firebase authentication
now we are in uh we are going to do
await firebase firestore
dot instance dot
collection and collection is going to be
of users
dot dot and what is the document going
to be the widget dot uid that we have
and we're going to get it
now
you it's your task to job what type of
value that we will get after this get
if you've guessed document snapshot
you're entirely correct
so you can just do document snapshot
which is equal to snap
and after that
we need to create a global variable uh
we'll call this
you know user data
user data and we'll
call it an empty object
and user so what we're going to do is
get the snap and uh we're going to set
our user data equal to
user
we're going to set a user to user data
to snap dot data and it's not going to
be null and we have to change this to
wire over here and not document snapshot
else you know we can't explicitly
set our map over here to the snap dot
data
then
we basically need to set the state so we
can set the state and over here we can
use the user data
so what we can do is user data
and we're going to
take user data
and we're going to use a property
username
and we can format a document and now
global variable now we need to pass in a
uid and this is going to be our home
screen item so this over here where we
need to show our
current uid uh so our current profile so
what we can do is firebase auth
dot instance dot current user dot uid
and after that is done let's format a
document and see if we are getting the
output
let's refresh our app
and over here we are getting riwanna
which is our username
cool
now let's try to output some more values
over here we're going to set user data
and we're going to go down
and we're going to replace this network
image with user data add the date and we
are going to use the property of photo
url and now we have saved it now let's
refresh our app and see if we are
getting that
so if we go over here
then we can see that this is my profile
picture and that's exactly what we've
got so the next thing we want to work on
is the username over here so we can take
the user data and put in the user name
and over your
user data and pass in the description
let's save our app and see if we are
getting that output
you can see we are getting
a null type over here
that is probably because we don't have a
description we have a bio so we'll have
to put in bio
now let's go over here and see we are
getting on earth and now you can see we
are getting some errors over here for
slighter moment this is because our uh
our data over here is still null and we
are calling some value and properties on
it so we are going to create is loading
variable and set a circular progress
indicator as long as these values are
not being fetched but we need to fetch
more values for example this post number
of posts
the followers we have the following we
have all of that stuff
so let's go to the top again and get
some more data
where we can rename this to user snap
and not just snap because we have more
snapshots coming in
the next we want to get is the post
linked so i can call it over here only
getting the post link
get post
link
and
the last
post we have we will have now post snap
which will be equal to await
firebase firestore.instance.collection
and
we are going to pass in posts now what
post do we want the post that is of the
user with this uid so we have seen dot
where property we will call that
and we are going to use the uid property
like the view id field
and we're going to check if it's equal
to not less than or greater than because
we know user i you user id is going to
be different for every user so we're
going to use is equal to and now we're
going to check if that is equal to
if that is equal to firebase
auth dot
instance
let's import that instance dot current
user dot uid
cool let's format the document
now
uh our we are going to create a global
variable called its int post link and
our post length is going to be 0 for the
initial value
then we are going to set post length
equal to post snap
dot we actually haven't called the get
function over here let's call that
and after that we're going to use post
snap dot
docs dot length
and we're going to put a semicolon over
here and we've called set state aware so
we don't need to worry about the widget
build rebuild function over here like
the rebuilding of this build function
and we need to take this post link go
down and replace this post link with
post link now since it accepts integer
we can just pass in post link
and refresh our app
go over here and we should see zero
posts right now this user doesn't have
any post
it's made by naman ranavat and rivan
ranavat
so we'll see that for them
now
uh we need the followers and the
following now how are our followers
going to come the followers are just
going to be a list over here you can see
followers and following so we're going
to do that for them just like we did for
likes and post we're going to do for
followers
we're going to store the uids over here
so
we can go at the top and we can create
and follow us variable which will be
follow us equal to 0 then we can take
followers
sorry we can take
followers equal to
user snap
dot data and
we'll access and we're going to take in
followers
which is this property over here the
followers property and and since this is
a list we are going to have dot link
property on it
and this following over here you can see
that's just you know my testing over
here so i've just added this for some
reason
now you can we have to take this
followers and put it down over here
follow us
and we can go over here and see zero
followers right now
then we need to do the same for
following so we can do
and following
equal to zero
and we can take the following
and our following will be equal to
this whole thing over here
and we're going to replace this uh of
property of followers to following
now
let's see
now we can take this following and put
it down over here
we should be getting 0 everywhere
and that's what we get so after that
we need to check if you know
uh
if we are following the user so if the
if this is our profile this it should
show edit profile but if it's some other
profile we're going to have follow
button over here unfollow button over
here so for that we need to check if we
are following this user
so
we can create a boolean value of
is following over here and we set it to
false we can take this as following and
put it over here and we'll check if it
is following
if
user snap user snap at
followers will have to do user snap dot
data at followers and we'll have to pass
in this exclamation mark over here at
follow us
contains our uid over here since this is
going to be a list return we can put
contains over here and we are going to
check if it contains firebase or dot
instance dot current user
and our uid over here
so you can save this
and if this is following we can make
conditional rendering in our application
down below with the follow button widget
that we had created over here so what we
can do is
create a first check over here if our
user
so
if
firebase
auth dot
instance dot current
user dot uid
is equal equal to widget.uid
that means uh
that means that whatever uid we are
enter we are entering from the parameter
is from the constructor is equal to the
firebase auth current user
id
then we know that this is our account
and thus we need to show the edit
profile
and if it's not then we need to check
if we are following that person
so if we are following that person we
need to give the person
a
an unfollow button
so we can
copy this follow button from here paste
it and make this
unfollow
and also we want this to be
out of the text color colors dot black
and since this is black this the
background color will change to colors
dot white
and
we will have a border color be
let's say colors.gray only
and yeah this is it
now we need to add another uh else
condition basically which is the last
one and we'll again have a follow button
which will actually say a follow
and
the follow will have a background color
of colors dot blue which is our primary
color
sorry yeah
which is our blue color in our
colors.file
our color text color is going to be
colors dot white
and our border color is also going to be
blue
now let's save and see what we're
getting we should be seeing edit profile
the way it was
and we have that to see a bit different
output what we can do is
take this profile screen
from here
and go to our
search screen
and in the search screen where we
have a list style we can wrap this with
an ink well widget and the inkwell will
have ontap function and with the on tab
we are going to navigate to the
profile screen page so we can do
navigator
dot of context dot
push
material page route
builder context
and we can
pass in the profile screen
now this profile screen requires a uid
of the user so what we can do is copy
this from here
and we're going to paste it
and our the property we are going to
pass in is uid and we can format this
now let's say try to see the output if
we refresh if we go to rivagna ranavat
we should again see edit profile this
because this is our account and for
rivan ranath as well we will get a
follow button
this means that our work is happening
pretty good
so what do we need to do next
first of all
we'll add loading indicators
so in our profile screen we can do
bool
is loading
and we can set it to false then we can
take this is loading value from here
and set the state to is loading equal to
true
then we can take this value over here
and after all of this stuff is done we
can set is loading to false again
and
over here
we are going to return
if is loading
is true then we need to show a constant
center
circular progress indicator
and we're going to have a scaffold we'll
have to format the document
and
let's see we are getting a loading bar
and all of our errors disappear from
here
you can go where and you can see none of
the errors we get which is pretty cool
now let's try to show our posts and then
we'll work on the followers and
following functionality
so to do the post function we can go to
the bottom after this divider we need to
use a future builder to display the
posts
we're not using stream builders because
we don't need to keep track of every you
know
uh
every part of the app like we are not
liking anything we're not commenting
anything so we don't need to use stream
builder we just need to display a list
of images and that's not a and even if
it's not real time nobody would care
so we can have that
future builder
now we'll have a future and in the
future we'll have firebase firestore
dot instance dot collection and we want
the post and whose post do we want
our own are like the user id mentioned
over here so we can do where
the uid
is equal to
the widget dot uid
that is passed in and we can dot
get
then we can do dot
after that we will get a builder and the
builder will have context and a snapshot
now we'll check if the snapshot
dot connection state
is equal equal to connection state
dot
weighting
and that's happening we need to return a
constant center
circular progress indicator
you have to go there
and we'll format the document
now if that's not the case what do we
want to show well we want to show a kind
of a grid thing over here right we want
three posts to show up like this
all right
and we want it like this now to make
such kind of layout flutter already
provides us with a widget which is known
as grid view builder we can use that so
we can do return
grid view dot builder
and it will take in a grid delicate and
an item builder
so what we can do is put them on
separate lines
and we'll return the grid view builder
now uh over here first we'll set shrink
wrap to true
then we'll have an item count and our
item count is going to be snapshot
dot data
and we'll treat it as dynamic our old
cheap trick that we used to follow
then this docs dot length
cool now the grid delegate will have a
constant of sliver
grid
delegate
with fixed cross access count
and the cross axis count is going to be
three then we are going to have a cross
axis spacing of 5
then a main axis spacing of 1.5
and a child aspect ratio of 1.
all of these values are again tried and
tested i just took values and kept on
changing them except the cross axis
count which means that i want this to be
3 and then the spacing part you need to
figure it out on your own like with the
trial and testing part then with the
item builder we need to pass in a
context and an index
and over here we're going to have
a document
snapshot and it will be again
snapshot.data as dynamic
dot docs
and we're going to have an index
and we're going to do document snapshot
snap
now we are going to return a container
and this container
will have a child of image
and the image will have image property
and will pass in the network image
now the network image is going to be
our snap
and we'll also
[Music]
put in snap
dot data and we'll do it as
dynamic
and we have to cover this with parent
thesis
and we can use
post url property that is mentioned in
the posts class post over your post url
cool now
to have some more fit what we can do is
have a property of fit and you can
experiment with these values but i'm
going to use boxfit.cover
and the names are pretty uh are
suggesting what this app will do
so if we go over here and let's remove
all of this stuff and we've made an
error over here we have already called
snapshot.data.docs
index over here so we just need to call
snap post url over here so we can
refresh our app now let's see over here
and we're not getting any post because
we haven't made any post
so let's try to
make a post
let's post it
choose from gallery
the text editing controller in your case
would look a bit different over here
i've decreased the size
and you can you have 0.45
the media query with into 0.45 i have
taken 0.3
and i'm going to have high aware just
for testing and we're going to post
and we have posted so if we come over
here we see one post so a post counter
is working and we can see our image
coming over here which is pretty cool if
you go in the search we will see our
image coming here as well which is very
cool
so that means our profile screen is
working and is ready
so if we go over here
search tab and call naman over here so
basically we can see the post
coming up which is pretty cool so in our
search over here if i type private
we will get driven rana which is our
profile and
if i do revamped on earth i can see my
post over here which is very cool
so that works now we need to work on the
follow functionality which we'll do now
so to do that we'll go in a firestore
methods class and over here we're going
to create a function
future void and we're going to create it
name it follow user it is going to be an
asynchronous process and we need to
get two things from here the user id
our current user id and the person whom
we are following that person's uid so we
do string follow id and over here we are
going to have a try catch block
in case of exception we are going to
print that exception and in that type
block what we are going to do is
await underscore firestore dot
collection of users
and over there we are going to go in our
document uid
and get the data
first let me type in document snapshot
so what we're doing over here is
basically going to our collection of
users and in our document id so in this
part suppose this is my user id
i'm going over here and getting all of
the data from here
and why are we doing that so that we can
check if we are already following that
user or not so what we can do is
list of following so if we do list
if we do snap
dot data
as dynamic
and we need to pass in this
and we'll have to put an exclamation
mark over here and we'll get the
following from here so we'll get a list
of following and in this list of
following we'll check
if the list of following
contains the user id
i mean the follow id
so
i'll explain this to you
so we got the follow following list of
the user over here and we are checking
if the following list contains the
follow id that is the second person's id
over here
then we
know that the person is following that
so it means that we are following that
person so we need to remove the follow
so what we can do is
await
underscore firestore dot collection
and our users
dot document follow id
and we'll update the value of followers
in the
follow id
basically we'll go in the users and
whichever person that we want to follow
we'll go in their document and update
the followers value over there because
we are well removing
because we are removing followers from
their uh
profile
so we can do that and we can do field
value
dot array union
id remove
and we'll pass in the uid cool that
means we have removed the follower from
the users uh
from the follower id
now we need to remove the
follow id that we have over here from
our user id
so we can pass in doc uid over here
we can have
following over here and we'll have a
remove
here as well
now
if the following does not contain the
follow id we need to
well
have the same thing but over here we'll
have array union and over here we will
have array union
and if this isn't clear to you
don't worry i'm going to explain it
again when we uh see this uh in the
action like in our app then in our
profile screen uh wherever we have you
know this
follow unfollow we can just
call this so we can use asynchronous
and over here we can have
await
firestore methods dot follow user and we
have to pass in the user id so what we
can do is firebase auth
dot
instance
dot current user dot uid
and we need to pass in the follow id as
well which will be user data
at
uid
that means whatever user profile we are
on right now we can format this document
and now we can
take this
and paste the same over here
and we can have asynchronous over here
cool now if we save this
and go over here if you go in the search
and search for a user ivan
and we have vivandranavat over here we
can click on rundown
and as you can see we are getting over
here now if i click on follow we don't
see any changes over here but if we go
in our fire store you can see a
followers got added
and the user id
and the user name was rivan ranavat
now if i go over here in my user id
you can see a following coming over here
so what we basically did was we checked
if the list already contains the
follower if it already contains a
follower then we're going to remove a
follower and if it doesn't then we are
going to add a follower and in this case
if the following already contains it we
are going to remove this following
and if it doesn't then we are going to
add it this will make much more sense uh
when you know we update these values
over here now why are these values not
getting updated over here because this
is a future and not a stream builder
right
uh in stream we constantly keep track of
our values and you know keep changing it
as and when they change in the database
but over here it's a one-time read as
i've mentioned previously
so
now we can put a set state over here
to update the value so to update the
value what we need to do is
increase the follower count by 1 and set
is following to true and we are in the
follow button so we can do that set
state
and we are going to pass in this over
here and we don't need to do this over
here we need to do it outside of the
follow user we have set state and we are
going to set is following
to
true
and we are going to increase the
followers count so we can do followers
plus plus
and we can take this value from here and
paste it over here as well in our
unfollow button and where we'll set is
following to false and we are going to
do followers
minus minus
so if i type in driven over here
we can see riwanda not showing up now if
i go over here we can see that we had
followed him earlier
so we got an unfollow button right now
but if we click unfollow right now you
can see the followers change it change
to zero and we get a follow button again
and over here we are not uh we are not
able to remove these followers because
in the firestore methods we created a
bug over here we need to
array uh when we are having followers
over here we need to remove the array of
uid and over here we need to remove
follow id
makes sense right because we are
following that follow id
and uh the same we are going to do over
here we're going to remove the follow id
from here
now i went fast uh in this section
because you know we are already familiar
with all the values that we're using
it's just a logic and it's very simple
logic i've cleared off my database now i
like our following list now and if i
search the one we should get zero
followers and if i click on follow
we get one follower and if we go to our
database you can see we are getting one
follower but if we unfollow
you can see zero followers and our
followers from here was removed which
means that our function is working
properly now
so yeah this was it for the follower
now if i
go over here on our screen we should see
one following and that's what we see
now the next thing we need to work on is
you know instead of showing edit profile
we need to show sign out so that we can
sign out
so
in our profile screen instead of edit
profile what we can do is sign
out
and in our auth methods we are going to
create a sign out function so what we
can do is
future
void and we'll call it sine
out we don't require any arguments as
such we just need to make this process a
function asynchronous and what we can do
is we can take the auth instantiation
and we can do auth dot sign out
and that's all it takes and since this
is going to be a future we need to await
it
and that's all it takes to well sign out
from the
uh our app
so what we can do over here is
call
async over here
and call await
auth methods
dot sign out
and we're going to call navigator
dot of context
dot push replacement
material page route
a builder context
and we are going to pass in the builder
as
the
responsive uh sorry the login screen
and
we need to put a semicolon lastly
and we can do const over here
so now if we refresh our app and see
we'll get sign out aware and if we sign
out we go to the screen over here now if
i refresh my app we should still be on
the login screen and that's where we are
so we have completed this app over here
of that is for the mobile app now let's
work a bit on the responsive design so
i've run the app on our chrome version
as well and we are i've run with the
command flutter run dash d chrome and
i've put in the web renderer as html as
i've told you that canvas causes viewed
issues
and if it looks good over here but if we
resize it you can see that this extends
till the end of over here because we
have used media query
and uh how can we fix this uh
over here so what do w
what kind of layout
layout i want for the web is
i want the
text input to be this long from here
till you're somewhere here i don't want
it to extend beyond this region over
here
right so to do that uh let's go and make
some conditional rendering so in our
login screen
we can go
and in the login screen
we have a container over here where the
padding is given as you know uh 32 so
what we can do is
over here
check if the media query dot of context
dot size dot width is greater than the
web screen size the
global variable that we had created over
here if it's this then we need to show
the
another padding because that's the web
screen layout that's showing up
else i want to show
this layout over here so over here the
edge inserts is going to be constant
edge in sets dot symmetric
and we're going to have third of this
size over here and we have to remove
this constant from here since we are
using media query now if i save my app
we should see a different output let's
run our app over here
and you can see that this size has
increased and that's exactly how i
wanted it
and if i increase the size you can see
it's showing up pretty cool and that's
the way i wanted it now let's go to the
let's enter our email over here let's
type in another gmail.com test123
and login so we have signed in and we
can see that we are getting a web year
layout of ir so we need to change that
so uh what do we want to show well uh
the layout of our app is going to be
something like
an app bar over here at the top
and with the app bar over here we need
to have an instagram logo over here
then at the end some icons where
in the app we had
at the bottom
so uh instead of bottom we want to have
these icons you know at the top right
corner that's how it is on instagram web
then uh we need to render the screen
basically
right let's do that so in our web screen
layout we're going to have an app bar
first
and our app bar is going to be app bar
and what i'm going to do is basically go
to the feed screen and i'm going to copy
the
app bar we have over here
let's copy that and paste it over here
and where we can you know make some
changes according to our preference
first we'll have to import the
background color
then the svg picture asset
right now we want our actions button to
be a bit different
so our icon button is over here we want
the messenger to show up last we want
other icons to be shown
so we'll have the home icon first then
the search icon
then the add file icon
and the notification icon then a profile
icon
yeah and well we can neglect the chart
icon for now because it's not having any
usage in our app
so where the first icon we had was icons
dot
home and
well
we are going to show the home icon for
now
then the next thing we want is search
icon
then we need add a photo
then a favorite
icon which is for the notifications
and lastly a person icon which will tell
us the
well the you know
the profile
and if we save we should see in the top
right corner all of these icons coming
up and that's exactly where they come
now the next thing we want to do is well
whenever we click over here we should
see the output coming on the screen
so to do that what you're going to do is
we're going to go in the feed screen
again
and from
we're going to go in the
mobile screen layout and we're going to
copy all of these functions from here
because we need to well basically have a
page view
and we're going to paste it over here
right having that in place what we need
to do is
we need to check
so if the page over here is equal to 0
so over here we'll have a primary color
so instead of the color what we're going
to have if page is equal equal to 1
then we need to show a primary color
or else a secondary color
not one our numbering will start from
zero so we can do zero
and why are we getting this error over
here because we don't want it as a
constant anymore so we'll remove the
constraint and then we'll have the
condition once again over here
so we can paste it
if page is equal to one
we have done all of this you know in our
uh mobile screen layout it's just that
we are copying stuff from here and
pasting it over here because we needed
the app bar in the top right corner
and that's why we need to to create
responsive layout and plus with this uh
kind of format you can add more stuff
which we'll talk about at the end of the
video
so
we have one two now we need to put in a
third
we'll remove the const
we'll again remove the const
and we'll paste it over here and we'll
have fourth
now let's remove some extra comma that
we've got
now let's format the document
and
tap r to see the changes coming place
but uh when
we click over here their color doesn't
get changed because we haven't called
the navigate so what we want to do is
take this search state from here and
paste it over here as well and we're
going to take this navigation tab
function
and we're going to call this over here
so we're going to go navigation tab and
we're going to call in the we get we are
going to given a page so this is going
to be the 0th page
we can copy this and paste it
again over here this is going to be 4
and yeah
this is it
now
in our body what we're going to have is
well a page view that we had exactly
like we had in the mobile screen so we
can have page view
and we're going to have children of home
screen items
that is in the global variable then
we're going to pass in the controller
and the controller is going to be a page
controller and on page change we need to
call
on page changed so we can copy this from
here and paste it over here
now let's tap r and see
if we go where
we should be seeing another page and
yeah this looks pretty cool
now if we go over here we can see the
search screen also showing up
and
this is scrollable over here because we
haven't set the physics we can do so by
scaling physics and never scrollable
physics
and it will be a const
now if we do r again
let's go over here and we can see
we are not able to
well change the app again
so yeah
now let's try to make the screen
responsive and get this app bar out of
here because we don't want it in the web
screen
so to do that what we're going to do is
go to the
feed screen over here
and we have our width over here
now in the app bar what we can do is
we can check if width is greater than
web screen size
then we don't need to show the app bar
so we can pass in null
or else we'll show the app bar
we can perform a hot restart and see
that we are getting no app bar
cool
now if we rerun our app
you can see
that bar is not showing also the
background color in the instagram web is
a bit different so what we can do is
go to the background scaffold and over
here we have passed in mobile background
color here we can check if the web is
the width is greater than the web screen
size
then we are going to have a web
background color
which is present in the colors dot dot
file now if we save this
we won't be seeing any difference as of
now but we'll see that in a while now we
want to go in our postcard because that
is where these things are
so we can go in our postcard
dot dot
and we are getting these borders over
here because i had added a border just
to check if it's working and all so you
can copy this line from here so if width
is greater than the web screen size we
need to put in a secondary color which
is uh
you know this background border color
which is gray
and else we will have a mobile
background color so if you do like this
you know shrink the size you can see no
background uh you can see no border but
this is because well the border is of
the background color so it merges
where you can see that our
background is showing up now we also
need to reduce the size of this postcard
over here so what we can do is in the
feed screen
we have our
postcard over here we can we have it
trapped with a container now we can add
a margin to our container
and in the margin we can add edge insets
dot symmetric
in the horizontal direction it will be
if width is greater than the web screen
size
then our width will be
then the
horizontal margin will be the total size
of the device into 0.3
and if it's not web screen size we don't
want it we don't want any margin so we
can just put zero and
and
for the vertical what we can do is paste
it
we can pass in vertical we'll pass in
the same conditions if width is greater
than the web screen size then we are
going to have a value of
15 in the vertical direction and nothing
in the horizontal direction like and
nothing when in the mobile screen layout
so we can format this
let's rerun our app
and see that our value over here has
decreased which is pretty cool
now if i you know
save our and we
now we try to you know
change the
size of our application you can see that
the change is happening
and if we go over here our app returns
to the normal app state that it was in
so this is the process for the
responsive ui you can do the same for
the sign up ui that we had followed
earlier for the login
and in the search i'm going to show you
how we can make changes over here
because well we are not familiar with
staggered grid view so we can go in the
search screen and in the search screen
we will have
our staggered grid view builder over
here we can have a check if with
we don't have a width ready so we can do
media query
dot of context dot size dot width is
greater than the web screen size
then uh we need to show something else
and because this is the configuration we
made for the mobile for the web we need
to show
three of them side by side and nothing
like this
so what we can do is
uh over here we can have one is to one
and one or one
so with basically this making the values
change over here and here
we will be able to get a three by three
layout over here
if we go over here you can see we are
getting a three by three layout and
that's what we wanted
and uh the rest of the responsive ui is
up to you you know you can make changes
i love it this way so i've uh
kept it this way only
uh then yeah this is pretty much it so
here we complete our course for the
beginners tutorial for firebase i hope
you could follow along and build this
application
and uh i just want to say that you know
it is very easy to create an application
with firebase you might have seen that
most of the functions that we used be it
in the auth methods or firestore methods
all of our functions were basically
getting reused and reused again and
again and it had the same layout
firebase is pretty easy to use and it's
very beginner friendly so you can check
it out
and regarding the application i just
want to say that
there might be some bugs that i'm unable
to notice and there might be some
features you want to add and make it a
full stack instagram clone i didn't make
that because well this was a firebase
teaching course and not a instagram
clone build
well we try i just tried to teach you
how we can use firebase by building
instagram so you can definitely add more
features the github link will be
mentioned in the description below you
can check it out and let me know in the
comment section below if you are able to
add more features and send the github
link in the comments as well but if you
have any doubts you can obviously
message me on instagram or you can
message me or you can comment down below
thank you so much for watching the video
see you in the next video